[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> WHAT UP, AND WELCOME TO THE
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
THIS AFTERNOON, FENWAY PARK,
BOSTON, MASS, RED SOX AND RAYS
FINISHING AT THREE HAVING GAME
SERIES AT WHAT IS TRULY MY
FAVORITE BALLPARK OF ALL THE
MAJOR LEAGUES.
AFTER-HOUR TO GET YOU READY FOR
THIS ONE IS NATHAN EOVALDI
AGAINST RYAN YARBROUGH.
TAMPA BAY IS TRYING TO SNAP A
THREE-GAME LOSING SKID.
BILL: I HAVE TO THROW THIS OUT
THERE.
STEPHEN: HIT ME.
BILL: IF ANYONE OF US TO IS
GOING TO BE CONFUSED AS
OLD-SCHOOL, IT WOULD BE MEAT
RATHER THAN YOU.
WITH THAT, YOU SAID THAT FENWAY
WAS HER FAVORITE BALLPARK.
STEPHEN: MY FAVORITE EXTREMES.
I'VE NOT BEEN TO CAMDEN YARDS
YET.
EVERYONE SAYS THAT IS ONE OF
THEIR FAVORITE EXPERIENCES.
BILL: IT IS REALLY NICE.
I JUST THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE THE
NEW AND IMPROVED KIND OF GUY.
STEPHEN: I LIKE HISTORY.
BILL: I GO BACK TO LOOKING AT A
COUPLE BALLPARKS I PLAYED YOU
STILL REMEMBER.
YANKEE STADIUM ONE, FENWAY THE
OTHER.
THERE ARE NICE BALLPARKS IN THE
GAME.
NOT SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT OLD
YANKEE AND FENWAY.
BUT THE HISTORY OF WHAT YOU SAW,
FENWAY WAS AS CLOSE AS COMING
INTO THE BALLPARK AS BLACK AND
WHITE.
AS SOON AS YOU CAME OUT ANY
LOOKED AT THE FIELD, EVERYTHING
WAS IN FULL COLOR.
IT WAS PRETTY COOL.
STEPHEN: IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
GO, TAKE THE TOUR AND GORE ON
THE BALLPARK, IT IS AMAZING.
BILL RIPKEN, STEPHEN NELSON.
WE ARE A WEEK INTO THE SEASON,
162-GAME SEASON, NOT 60.
WHAT ARE YOUR TAKEAWAYS, KNOWING
WE ARE WATCHING THINGS AT A
DIFFERENT SPEED?
LAST YEAR WE WERE FREAKING OUT
BECAUSE GAMES ARE THREE TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE, FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM.
BILL: RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THE OVERALL JIST I HAD
IN THE FIRST WEEK COME THERE WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF SLOPPINESS.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF BASEBALLS
THROWN ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IF THE BALL IS THERE WHEN THE
BIG-LEAGUE PLAYS HAPPENING AND
YOU SEE THIS, THAT IS NOT A GOOD
SIGN.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL: SOMETHING WENT AWRY.
I SUSPECT OVER TIME WE WILL
CLEAN THIS UP, BECAUSE LET'S
FACE IT, I THOUGHT THE PLAYERS
DID A REALLY GOOD JOB WITH THAT
60 HAVING GAME SCENARIO, NO FANS
IN THE STANDS.
IT LOOKED REAL IF YOU JUST HONED
IN ON THE GAME.
NO MATTER HOW MANY FANS ARE IN
SOME OF THESE BALLPARKS OR HOW
LITTLE AMOUNT OF THE FENCE OF
THE BALLPARK, IT MIGHT BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK IN PERIOD
FOR THE FANS TO BE BACK IN THE
PARK AND SEE SCATTERED FANS.
STEPHEN: MORE OF A BUZZ, AND THE
FOLKS IN BOSTON WERE DEFINITELY
BUZZING IN GAME TWO.
IN CASE YOU MISSED THE ACTION,
WE HAVE SOME HIGHLIGHTS.
>> JUST THREE HITS OFF THIS TALL
ACE, GLASNOW.
>> SLIDER BECOMING THE GO TO
AFTER THE FASTBALL.
CURVEBALL MAINLY HAS BEEN TO PUT
GUYS AWAY AT THE END OF THE
COUNT.
>> EIGHTH STRIKEOUT FOR TYLER
GLASNOW.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> WATCH HIS REACTION AFTER HE
GETS THE OUT.
>> J.D. MARTINEZ HASN'T HAD MANY
QUIET ONES YET, BUT HE IS 0-3 SO
FAR TONIGHT.
SLAPS THAT ONE THE OTHER WAY.
DRIVING BACK, THE RIGHT FIELDER,
OVER THE HEAD OF ARENA.
VERDUGO ROUNDING THIRD.
HE IS IN.
THE SLIDE AND SCORE.
ANOTHER EXTRA-BASE HIT FOR
MARTINEZ.
IT IS A ONE-RUN GAME.
>> 3-2, RAYS.
>> GROUNDED OUT TO THIRD,
WALKED, STRUCK OUT.
HIGH FLY BALL.
THAT ONE WAY BACK THERE.
WATCH IT GO.
IT IS GONE!
AND THIS GAME IS TIED!
OH, YOU GOT ALL OF IT -- HE GOT
ALL OF IT.
THE RED SOX TIE A 3-3 TONIGHT.
>> WINNING RUN IS IN THIRD, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO INTENTIONALLY
WALKED ALSO J.D. MARTINEZ COME
HE HAS A CHANCE TO WIN IT.
>> TERRIFIC PLATE THERE.
-- TERRIFIC PLAY THERE.
>> RUNNER AT SECOND BASE IS
BRANDON LOWE.
ADAMES ONE OF THE HEROES OF THE
10TH.
>> LINER OF THE LEFT SIDE.
THAT IS GOING TO SCORE THE RUN.
RAYS WILL TAKE THE LEAD IN THE
11TH INNING.
>> XANDER BOGAERTS ME THE LEAST
OUT IN THE 10TH INNING.
-- MADE THE LAST OUT IN THE 10TH
INNING.
GIVING CHASE.
HERE COMES XANDER, THE
GAME IS TIED AGAIN.
>> THE WINNING RUN IS ON BASE,
AND VERDUGO -- SINGLE COULD WIN
THE GAME.
>> THAT ONE IS DRIVEN TO RIGHT
FIELD.
AROZARENA BACKING UP --IT'S OVER
HIS HEAD!
IT'S OVER HIS HEAD!
AND THE RED SOX ARE GOING TO WIN
THE GAME!
TWO-RUN SCORE!
AUSTIN WYNNS! -- BOSTON WINS!
BOY, IS THAT A FITTING END TO
THIS ONE.
>> WHAT A BALLGAME THIS WAS
.
STEPHEN: SIX RUNS AFTER FIVE AND
THE FIRST THREE GAMES --
BILL: THREE CY YOUNG AWARD
WINNER'S BALTIMORE WHEN IN THERE
--
STEPHEN: SHUT HIM DOWN.
BILL: NOBODY ELSE HAS
NECESSARILY GOT IT GOING.
I THINK THE NAMES ON THE BACKS
AND SOME OF THE FLIP SIDES OF
THE BASEBALL CARDS -- THESE GUYS
ARE GOING TO BE FINE.
THEY HAVE PRETTY GOOD OFFENSIVE
PLAYERS.
DEVERS HAS INTERESTED ME A LOT.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT.
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
STAYING ON THE BASEBALL.
WE HAVE HEARD THIS PHRASE GO AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME FOR THE THIS
IS KIND OF WHAT IT IS.
RIGHT DOWN BROADWAY AT 92.
TIES THE GAME AT LEFT FIELD.
LOOK AT THAT FRONT SHOULDER.
THE LONGER THE FRONT SHOULDER
STAYS CLOSED, THAT IS HOW YOU
STATE ON THE BASEBALL.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN DOING IT.
THIS IS HIS GAME RIGHT THERE.
EVEN THOUGH THE 78 IS THE SLOWER
SPEED OF THE PITCH, IT IS THE
BREAKING BALL, SWEEPING AWAY
FROM JD.
HE STAYS CLOSED LONG ENOUGH.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT STAYING
CLOSED AND HOW IT WORKS.
WE LOOK AT VIDEO AND WE BREAK
THINGS DOWN EVERY FRAME.
THERE IS TIMES WHERE PEOPLE
THINK THIS GETS OUT OF HERE --
BOTH OF THOSE WERE OPPOSITE
FIELD.
DEVERS WENT THAT WAY, HITTING
OUT OF THAT BOX.
JD GOES THAT WAY AS WELL AS
ANYBODY IN THE GAME.
YES, THERE WILL BE A TIME WHEN
THIS THING GOES SO YOU CAN GET
TO IT.
BUT IF THIS THING LEAKS EARLY,
PRETTY MUCH THE ONLY PITCH I CAN
HANDLE IS THE BALL MIDDLE IN.
YOU HIT IT THIS WAY.
WITH JD, THE BALL WAS INNER
THIRD-ISH, MORE ON THIS SITE.
BREAKING BALL IS GOING AWAY.
IF HIS APPROACH IS THINKING I'M
GOING TO HIT THE PITCHER RIGHT,
THIS WILL STAY CLOSED A LITTLE
BIT LONGER.
THAT STAYS CLOSED, YOU HAVE A
FLY BALL OVER THERE, YOU STAY
CLOSED AND YOU GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE THE BAT HEAD CAN GET TO IT
A LITTLE MORE DIRECT.
STEPHEN: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION?
BILL: YES, SIR.
STEPHEN: WE HAVE OFFENSES
SUBSCRIBE TO THE MLB YOUTUBE
CHANNEL--FANS SUBSCRIBED TO THE
MLB YOUTUBE CHANNEL NOW.
IS THERE A DRILL THAT YOU HELP
STAY ON TOP OF THE BASEBALL?
BILL: I LIKE THE SOFT TOSS FROM
THE FRONT.
YOU CAN GO LOOK THROUGH THE
YOUTUBE CHANNEL AND YOU CAN SEE
SEAN CASEY HITTING IT RIGHT IN
THE LIMB WHEN I'M SITTING OUT
THERE.
THE BALL AWAY -- A HITTER MUST
DO MORE RIGHT IN ORDER TO HIT
THAT.
I CAN CHEAT AND DO THINGS WRONG
MECHANICALLY AND STILL HAVE SOME
SUCCESS IN HERE.
IN ORDER TO HIT THIS BALL ON THE
OUTER PART OF THE PLATE, YOU
HAVE TO BE MORE DIRECT WITH THE
BAT INTO THE BALL.
THE BEST DRILL TO STAY ON THE
BALL IS SOFT TOSS FROM THE
FRONT, LET'S TOSS IT OUT ON THE
INNER THIRD.
DON'T TRY TO TRICK HIM.
DON'T MIX IT UP.
ESPECIALLY IF IT IS A YOUNG KID,
PLUS THE BALL OUT HERE --
STEPHEN: HIT ME IN THE FACE.
BILL: USE THE SCREEN.
HIT THE BALL BACK UP THE MIDDLE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I REMEMBER
BEING ON THE PHONE WITH MY
FATHER IN 1986, AA.
I CALLED HIM AND SAY, "DUDE, I
HAD A COUPLE PITCHES DOWN THE
MIDDLE AND FLY BALLS TO RIGHT
FIELD.
I SHOULD HIT THE BALL BETTER."
"DO ME A FAVOR, SON, TOMORROW
DURING BATTING PRACTICE THINK OF
ONE THING, IT LINE DRIVES OF THE
MIDDLE."
HE WAS DIAGNOSING WITHOUT SEEING
VIDEO.
MY SHOULDER WAS PROBABLY
LEAKING.
HIT FLY BALL THE RIGHT.
HE SAYS GO OUT THERE AND TAKE
BATTING PRACTICE AND HIT THE
BALL UP THE MIDDLE AND THROW BP
IN THE UP SCREEN AND WHEN THE
GAME STARTS ALL CAPS OUT OF YOUR
HEAD GO HIT THE BALL HARD A
COUPLE TIMES.
DON'T GET A HIT.
GO HIT THE BALL HARD A COUPLE
TIMES AND REPORT BACK.
USUALLY THAT FIXED THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IF THAT THING LEAKS, I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO HIT IT WEEK
FLY BALL.
STEPHEN: LEARNING YOU SOME STUFF
IN STUDIO 42.
GETTING CLOSER AND CLOSER THE
FIRST PITCH IN FENWAY.
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
WE WANT YOU TO GET INVOLVED.
WE WILL PUT UP THIS -- WAS GOING
TO WIN TODAY, TAMPA BAY OR
BOSTON?
YOU LET US KNOW.
ONLY GAME OF THE WEEK PRESENTED
BY FIDELITY PREGAME POLE.
SUN IS SHINING, MUCH BETTER THAN
OPENING DATE A WEEK AGO WHEN IT
WAS RAINING AND IT POSTPONED THE
GAME AGAINST THE ORIOLES.
THEY ARE DEFINITELY PLAYING
BOSTON TODAY.
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN SMOLTZ, COLAS
PEÑA.
-- CARLOS PENA.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE!
>> HE WILL GO AFTER THAT ONE AND
DRIVE THAT ONE HIGH.
DEEP TO LEFT.
THAT BALL IS GONE.
THERE IS NUMBER TWO.
DIDN'T WAIT VERY LONG.
DON'T YOU THINK THE RED SOX HAVE
TO MAKE SURE HE IS IN THE LINEUP
EVERY DAY?
THAT BALL IS HAMMERED.
THAT IS A HIGH FLY BALL.
TWISTING DEEP DEEP DEEP.
GONE.
VERDUGO STRIKES AGAIN.
THAT IS A WAY TO GET SOME WIGGLE
ROOM.
ALSO TO THE OPPOSITE FIELD.
HIGH FLY BALL THROUGH THE DEEP
TO RIGHT.
VERDUGO BACK TO THE PEN ALSO
LEAPS UP, HE CAUGHT IT.
HE CAUGHT THE BALL.
HE TOOK IT BACK.
>> WHAT A NIGHT!
WHAT A NIGHT!
>> DRIVE DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE DEEP.
IT IS GONE.
OPPOSITE FIELD HOME RUN.
HE HAS HOMERED NOW IN FIVE
STRAIGHT GAMES.
DIDN'T GET IT ALL, BUT SO STRONG
HE JUMPED.
>> AROZARENA BACKING UP --IT'S
OVER HIS HEAD!
IT'S OVER HIS HEAD!
RED SOX ARE GOING TO WIN THE
GAME!
TWO-RUN SCORE!
AUSTIN WYNNS! -- BOSTON WINS!
>> THAT'S OVATION GOES ALL THE
WAY DOWN THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
STEPHEN: IN CASE YOU FORGOT, YOU
ARE WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
STEPHEN: LET'S TURN ON THAT
CREATIVE SPOTLIGHT ONTO GI
RAFFENECKMARC.
IF YOU KNOW BASEBALL ON YOUTUBE,
HE NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION, BUT I
WILL INITIATE YOU.
HIS CHANNEL GETTING CLOSE TO
200,000 SUBSCRIBERS ON YOUTUBE.
HE HAS OPINIONATED BUT ALSO
INFORMATIVE VIDEOS ABOUT
EVERYTHING IN BASEBALL, JERSEYS,
STADIUMS, PREDICTIONS, RANKINGS,
REACTIONS TO WHAT IS GOING ON.
HIS FAVORITE TEAM, THE NEW YORK
METS.
HE IS NOT ALONE.
TRUST ME, AND THIS BUILDING
THERE IS A LOT OF METS FANS.
LET'S SAY HI TO MARC NOW.
GREAT TO VISIT WITH YOU FINALLY.
GIVE ME THE GENESIS OF YOUR
CHANNEL AND YOUR STORY.
>> SO I AM A HUGE BASEBALL FAN,
AND GROWING UP, BASEBALL IS A
HUGE PART OF MY LIFE.
PLATED EVERY SINGLE SUMMER,
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WHEN I WENT TO COLLEGE AND THE
BASEBALL CAREER WAS OVER I
NEEDED A WAY TO CONTINUE MY
PASSION FOR BASEBALL, SO YOUTUBE
WAS A WAY TO DO THAT.
I STARTED MAKING VIDEOS AND
PEOPLE STARTED WATCHING IT AND
NOW IT HAS TURNED INTO A JOB
EVERY DAY.
I COULDN'T ASK FOR BETTER JOB.
STEPHEN: HOW DID HE FALL IN LOVE
WITH THE NEW YORK METS?
>> I HAVE GOT TO GIVE A
SHOUT-OUT TO MY DAD.
HE IS A HUGE METS FAN.
IT COMES FROM MY DAD.
HOW CAN YOU NOT LOVE THIS TEAM?
THERE THE BEST.
STEPHEN: ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR,
SO MUCH BUZZ AND EXAMINE.
BUT YOU ARE NOT A BANDWAGONER AS
A METS FAN, YOU'VE SEEN SOME
THINGS.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST METS MOMENTS
I CAN REMEMBER IS WHEN TODD HIT
THE HOME RUN IN THE POSTSEASON.
I WAS THREE OR FOUR YEARS OLD AT
THE TIME, DON'T REMEMBER MY
EXACT AGE, BUT I WAS REALLY
YOUNG, AND MY DAD'S NUMBER
WAS 917 AND I CALL 11 AND THE
POLICE ENDED UP COMING TO MY
FATHER'S HOUSE.
I GOT A GREAT STORY WITH THE
POLICE THINKING SOMETHING WAS
WRONG.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS GAME WE HAVE GOTTEN BOSTON,
RED SOX AND RAYS?
>> THIS IS A GREAT GAME, SUPER
EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT THIS ONE.
STEPHEN: I WATCHED YOUR
PREDICTION VIDEO.
THE RED SOX WERE 16TH, I WANT TO
SAY, ON THAT LIST, AND THE RAYS
WERE 10.
WE ARE NOT A WEEK OLD IN THE
SEASON, WOULD YOU WANT TO CHANGE
THE RANKING SETTLE?--THE RANKING
SETTLE?
>> NO, I USUALLY STAY TRUE TO MY
PREDICTIONS AND RANKINGS.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF GOOD STUFF
FROM THE RED SOX THE LAST FEW
GAMES.
THE RAYS, YOU CAN'T EVER DOUBT
THEM.
THEY ARE A FUN TEAM TO WATCH.
STEPHEN: HOW DO YOU FORECAST THE
DIVISION RACE BEYOND THESE TWO
TEAMS?
>> IT PAINS ME TO SAY IT, BUT
THE YANKEES ARE PROBABLY THE
BEST IN THE DIVISION.
IT REALLY HURTS ME, BUT THE
YANKEES ARE IN SUCH A DEEP
DIVISION WITH THE BLUE JAYS.
STEPHEN: BALTIMORE HAS MADE SOME
NOISE AT THE START.
ARE YOU BUYING OR SELLING IT?
>> I AM BUYING INTO THEIR
HEIGHT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF STUFF GOING
ON, ESPECIALLY ON THE PITCHING
SIDE.
WE KNOW HOW GOOD THEY ARE WITH
THE PITCHING DEPARTMENT.
YOU CAN SEE WITH SOME OF THE
ARMS.
I AM BUYING INTO THE ORIOLES
HYPE.
STEPHEN: IF PEOPLE WATCH
GIRAFFENECKMARC ON YOUTUBE, THEY
KNOW THEY WILL GET SOME UNIFORM
AND SWAG VIDEOS AS WELL.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT THE RED
SOX JERSEYS WERE UNVEILED COME
WHAT THEY WILL BE WEARING ON
PATRIOTS' DAY AGAINST THE
CHICAGO WHITE SOX.
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK THEY ARE SO AWESOME.
I AM ALWAYS FOR TEAMS, ACROSS
MLB, GETTING DIFFERENT JERSEYS
EVEN THOUGH YELLOW AND
LIGHT BLUES NOT TYPICALLY THE
COLOR YOU SEE WITH THE RED SOX,
I LOVE THE DESIGN.
I WILL BUY A JERSEY FOR MYSELF.
STEPHEN: LOVE IT.
THE OF US ARE TOP FIVE PLAYERS
TO WATCH IN BASEBALL RIGHT NOW.
>> SUCH A GOOD LIST, BUT WE HAVE
TO START OFF WITH THE BEST
PLAYER IN BASEBALL AND THE BEST
PLAYER OF ALL TIME, MIKE TROUT.
FERNANDO TATIS, ARGUABLY THE
FACE OF BASEBALL.
HE IS INCREDIBLE AS WELL --
RUNNING, HITTING, THROWING,
FEELING.
YOU GOTTA WATCH HIM AT ALL
TIMES.
GOTTA GIVE A SHOUT-OUT TO SHOHEI
OHTANI, TOO, TEAMMATE OF
TROUT'S.
PITCHING, HITTING, THROWING 100
MILES AN HOUR.
POSSIBLY THE MOST TALENTED
PLAYER WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
JUAN SOTO WITH THE NATIONALS,
ANOTHER ONE THAT HURTS ME A
LITTLE BIT AS A METS FAN.
HE IS ONLY 22, 23 YEARS OLD, AND
USING READILY TALENTED, THROUGH
THE ROOF.
GOTTA GIVE A SHOUT-OUT TO MY OWN
FAVORITE TEAM, THE METS, AND
JACOB DEGROM.
BEST PITCHER IN BASEBALL WHO
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANYTHING
ELSE.
EVERY TIME HE IS ON THE MOUND HE
IS GOING TO DO SOME THING
SPECIAL.
STEPHEN: JACOB DEGROM, IF YOU
ASK ANYBODY COME ANY PITCHER IN
THE GAME, THEY SAY HE IS THE
BEST WALKING THE PLANET RIGHT
NOW.
BUT IT IS FRANCISCO LINDOR WHO
HAS EVERYBODY LIT UP IN AND
AROUND FLUSHING, QUEENS, BECAUSE
OF HIS MASSIVE EXTENSION.
HOW HAPPY ARE YOU THAT HE IS
GOING TO BE AROUND FOR A
DECADE-PLUS?
>> YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE THE
SMILE ON MY FACE.
I HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO WIPE IT
OFF SINCE WE TRADED FOR HIM, AND
ONCE THEY EXTENDED HIM, THE
SMILE HAS GONE NOWHERE.
I CANNOT BE HAPPY ARE SIGNED
THIS GUY.
YOU WILL BE HERE FOR 11
YEARS--HE WILL BE HERE FOR THE
NEXT 11 YEARS.
I AM THROUGH THE ROOF EXCITED.
STEPHEN: HE IS THE SIX-TOOL
STAR.
JUST SO ELECTRIC, SO MAGNETIC,
NOT JUST TO METS WERE CLEVELAND
FANS, BUT ANYONE WHO LOVES
BASEBALL, PURE JOY, THEY LOVE
FRANCISCO LINDOR.
IF THERE WAS ONE PLAYER IN THE
GAME THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO HAVE
JOINED YOUR RANKS AS A YOUTUBE
CREATE FOR, WHO WOULD IT BE?
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD,
IT IS FRANCISCO LINDOR.
SO MUCH CHARISMA, SO MUCH
PERSONALITY.
WITH THIS NEW YORK METS TEAM, WE
WILL SEE THAT SHINE.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM GRAB A
CAMERA AND VLOG, BE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE, WHAT HE IS DOING
BEFORE THE GAME.
THIS TEAM IS SO MUCH FUN, AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE KIND OF
EXCITEMENT THAT HE ALSO BRINGS
ALONG WITH THE REST OF THE GUYS.
STEPHEN: I AM NOT GOING TO TALK
TO GIRAFFENECKMARC AND NOT GET A
PRODUCTION.
RED SOX, RAYS, WHO YOU GOT
TODAY.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE RED
SOX ON THIS ONE.
I HAVE A LOT OF RED SOX FANS WHO
WATCH ME AND THEY'VE BEEN
PLAYING GOOD BASEBALL.
STEPHEN: GIRAFFENECKMARC,
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL, LIKE
VIDEOS, LEAVE COMMENTS.
HE IS ALL OVER SOCIAL MEDIA AND
LOVES CHOPPING IT UP WITH
BASEBALL FANS AND WE LOVE
CHOPPING IT UP WITH HIM.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
STEPHEN: SPEAKING OF PICKS,
TO CLICK.
JOHN SMOLTZ IS GOING TO MAKE
THEM.
>> OH, MY!
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE!
>> BOY, HE IS HANGING TOUGH.
WHAT AN AT-BAT.
>> BROSSEAU SENDS WENT TO LEFT
FIELD.
GARDNER GOING BACK.
IT IS UP AND GONE!
MIKE BROSSEAU HAS HOMERED, AND
THE RAYS HAVE A 2-1 LEAD!
WHAT A MOMENT FOR BROSSEAU!
>> HERE IS THE SHOT INTO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
HE'S GOT ANOTHER.
IN THE ALL-TIME RECORD FOR HOME
RUNS IN A SINGLE POSTSEASON WITH
NUMBER NINE.
>> THAT BALL WAS TATTOOED.
>> JANSEN, STRIKE AWAY.
1-2 PITCH.
PHILLIPS HAS CASHED IN!
BASE HIT BACK UP THE MIDDLE!
THE BALL IS MISHANDLED!
AND NOW THEY HAVE GOT AROZARENA!
RAYS HAVE WON THE GAME!
>> AND THAT IS A LINER OF THE
LEFT SIDE, BACK TOWARD THE
CORNER.
THAT IS GOING TO SCORE THE RUN.
EXTRA-BASES FOR ADAMES, AND THE
RAYS WILL TAKE THE LEAD IN THE
11TH INNING.
>> HE PICKS UP A BIG R.B.I.
DOUBLE AND GIVES THE RAYS A 4-3
LEAD.
STEPHEN: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED
BY FIDELITY.
WITH JOHN SMOLTZ, HE IS CALLING
THE GAME WITH SCOTT BRAUN,
CARLOS PENA, ALANNA RIZZO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
JOHN: COULD BE BACK.
STEPHEN: DO YOU HAVE A FAVORITE
YOUTUBE VIDEO?
JOHN: UNFORTUNATELY IT REVOLVES
AROUND ME IN THE STADIUM THEY
ARE PLAYING, FENWAY.
I'M IN A SMALL BOX.
GOT HIT IN THE WRONG PLACE ON A
FOUL BALL AS AN ANNOUNCER.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: THE WRONG PLACE?
GOTCHA.
JOHN: IT WAS BAD.
STEPHEN: YOU HAVE BAD RED SOX
MEMORIES.
DESPITE THAT COME HE IS GOING TO
BE OBJECTIVE IN CALLING THIS
GAME.
RED SOX, RAYS, INTERESTING PITCH
PITCHING MATCHUP.
JOHN: IT IS LIKE OPPOSITES.
HARD THROWING GUY IN EOVALDI AND
THEN YOU HAVE YARBROUGH, WHO IS
GOING TO DO THE OPPOSITE.
SPIN IT, SOFT CONTACT.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE A BASIC
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW TO GUYS
GET IT DONE.
STEPHEN: NATHAN EOVALDI'S GOING
TO DIE LIT UP, AND YARBOROUGH
THE LAST COUPLE SEASONS HAS BEEN
BEST AT THE MEETING OR CONTACT
IN TERMS OF EXIT -- AVERAGE EXIT
VELOCITY AGAINST WHILE WE ARE
WITH YOU, WE WILL PLAY A GAME.
I WILL PEPPER YOU WITH SOME
QUESTIONS.
WE ARE YOUNG IN THE SEASON.
YANKEES CAME INTO THE IS THE
FAVORITE FOR THE DIVISION,
CURRENTLY BEHIND THE ORIOLES IN
THE STANDINGS.
WHO IS GOING TO CHALLENGE THEM?
JOHN: THE EASIEST ANSWER WOULD
BE THE RAYS BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
DID LAST YEAR, BUT I THINK IT
WILL BE SOMETHING THAT RHYMES
WITH RAYS, AND THAT IS JAYS.
TORONTO HAS DONE ENOUGH.
IF THEY STAY HEALTHY, THEY CAN
COMPETE IN THE DIVISION AND GIFT
THE YANKEES A CHALLENGE THAT
MIGHT GO THROUGH MOST OF THE
YEAR.
STEPHEN: TORONTO BLUE JAYS
HOPING THAT THE STARTING
ROTATION CAN BE HEALTHY BEYOND
HYUN-JIN RYU.
IT'S TALK ABOUT A GUY WE WILL
SAVE--LET'S TALK ABOUT A GUY WE
WILL SEE TODAY.
J.D. MARTINEZ OFF TO A NICE
START.
79 THE TWO SEASONS COMBINED
PRIOR.
OVER OR UNDER 2.5 FINGERS FOR
JD?
JOHN: I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
NUMBER BUT I DON'T THINK LAST
YEAR REPRESENTS THE HITTER JD
IS.
I WILL TAKE THE OVER ON THAT,
BECAUSE J.D. MARTINEZ IS A
PROFESSIONAL HITTER, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT HAVE YOU DONE FOR ME
LATELY SOCIETY IN BASEBALL,
DON'T GET CAUGHT UP IN THAT.
HE IS GOING TO PLAY A LOT, AND
THE NUMBERS WILL SHOW UP THIS
YEAR.
STEPHEN: HE IS ONE OF THE GUYS
WHO TALKED ABOUT THE LACK OF
VIDEO LAST YEAR AND HOW IT
REALLY HURT HIM.
FEELS MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE AT
THE PLATE.
IT COULD BE SAID FOR A LOT OF
PLAYERS.
JOHN: RIGHT, WRONG, OR
INDIFFERENT MENTALLY IS THE
BIGGEST THING.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE NUMBERS
SAY.
IF YOU ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT AND YOU STRUGGLE TO GET OUT
OF YOUR COMFORT ZONE, CAN AFFECT
YOU, AND IT DID LAST YEAR FOR
HIM.
STEPHEN: TWO ALREADY THIS YEAR
IN FIVE GAMES, 7 EXTRA-BASE
HITS, NINE R.B.I.'S.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, THE
POSTSEASON DARLING FOR THE TAMPA
BAY RAYS, RANDY AROZARENA.
CS M.V.P., NOW ELIGIBLE TO WIN
ROOKIE OF WOULD YOU CALL HIM
YOUR FAVORITE IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE?
JOHN: I WOULD CALL HIM
EVERYBODY'S FAVORITE, BUT THAT
IS TOO STRONG TO THINK THAT
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE FAVORITE
THAT HE WILL ROLL IN AND PICK UP
WHERE HE LEFT OFFICE OF I THINK
HE WILL BE--WHERE HE LEFT OFF.
I THINK IT WILL BE A TOTAL
DIFFERENT PATIENT SELECTION.
I DON'T THINK YOU WILL STRUGGLE,
BUT I DON'T THINK HE WILL WIN
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR FROM ALL THE
TALK OF THE UNBELIEVABLE
POSTSEASON.
I WISH IT WOULD CARRYOVER LIKE
THAT.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS CARRY OVER
LIKE THAT.
STEPHEN: THAT IS A BAR THAT IS
JUST SET WAY TOO HIGH FOR
ANYBODY.
ANYBODY WHO PICKS 10 HOME RUNS
IN THE POSTSEASON COME NOW YOU
GOT A LOT OF EYEBALLS ON YOU.
THEY TRIED TO SNEAK FASTBALLS BY
HIM LAST YEAR AND HE CRUSHED
THEM.
LET'S GET IN YOUR WHEELHOUSE,
THE PITCHING SIDE.
IF YOU WERE TO FORECAST THE CY
YOUNG AWARD IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE, WHO HAVE YOU GOT IN
FRONT?
JOHN: ARTICLE AGAINST THE
YANKEES AND GERRIT COLE.
HE HAS HIS ADJUSTMENT PERIOD
INCOME HONESTLY A FANTASTIC
PITCHER.
NOT A BIG LIMB I'M JUMPING ON,
BUT IT IS HIS TO LOSE.
I HATED IT WHEN SOMEBODY SAID
THAT ABOUT ME, BUT I THINK HE IS
THAT GOOD AND THE YANKEES'
OFFENSE WILL BE THAT GOOD THAT
IT IS HIS.
STEPHEN: SHANE BIEBER THE
REIGNING CY YOUNG AWARD WINNER.
WHO WOULD YOU SAY THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT YOU LOVE THE MOST
AFTER COLE WOULD BE?
JOHN: YOU MENTIONED GLASNOW, AND
THE FACT THAT HE WON LAST YEAR
AND ENDED THAT PITCH IS GOING TO
BE A WEAPON.
IT IS GOING TO COME DOWN TO DOES
HE PICTURE ENOUGH INNINGS IN
THIS YEAR?
THAT WILL BE A BIGGER PRIORITY
THAN IN THE PAST BECAUSE YOU CAN
HAVE A BIG GAP BETWEEN PITCHERS.
HE IS GOING TO PITCH INNINGS AND
HE IS GOING TO STRIKE OUT A LOT
OF GUYS.
IT IS A GREAT RAYS FROM THE
POWER ARMS.
AS NOW IS A NICE SNEAKY PICK --
GLASNOW IS A NICE SNEAKY PICK
BECAUSE THE ARMS.
STEPHEN: HE IS KEEPING THEM
HONEST WITH THE THIRD WEAPON.
OK, I THINK IF SOMEONE WERE TO
ASK YOU THE FAVORITE PITCHER
IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW, IS IT
SAFE TO SAY JACOB DEGROM?
JOHN: YES.
STEPHEN: IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE,
WINS ARE WHAT IS HARD TO COME BY
FOR JACOB DEGROM POLICE FROM HIS
TENURE WITH THE NEW YORK METS.
OVER OR UNDER 15.5?
JOHN: ANOTHER GREAT NUMBER AND
IT IS EASY TO BUY INTO THE
NUMBER OF WHAT HE HAS AND HAS
NOT BEEN IN THE WIN CATEGORY.
WIPE THAT FROM YOUR MIND.
I KNOW THE FIRST GAME DIDN'T GO
THE WAY IT IS SUPPOSED TO, BUT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A TOTALLY
REVAMPED OFFENSIVE TEAM WITH THE
NEW YORK METS FOR THE JACOB
DEGROM KEEPS GETTING BETTER AND
BETTER.
YOUR IS A GUY WHO KNOWS HOW TO
PITCH NOT ONLY MULTIPLE PITCHES,
BUT WHETHER HE IS ON OR OFF.
JACOB DEGROM WILL BREAK THROUGH
IN THE WIN COLUMN.
I WOULD GO 17-3 OR 18-4.
THERE IS NO WAY IT CAN CONTINUE.
THERE IS NO WAY IT CAN CONTINUE,
AND I THINK AS TIME BUILDS UP,
YOU WON'T SEE THE EARLY EXITS TO
PROTECT FOR THE WHOLE SEASON.
AS TIME BUILDS UP, YOU WILL SEE
THE OFFENSE FINALLY GIVE WAY OF
WHATEVER -- LOOK, IF YOU ARE
PITCHING AGAINST JACOB DEGROM,
YOU WILL PITCH YOUR BEST GAME,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO.
THE OFFENSE GETS A LOT OF BLAME
SOMETIMES.
THE PRESSURE IS MOUNTING BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME EVERY TIME HE PITCHES.
STEPHEN: SINCE 2018 IS E.R.A. IS
2.07.
JOHN: THAT CANNOT CONTINUE.
STEPHEN: METS FANS ARE LIKE, YOU
WOULD THINK THAT, BUT IT KEEPS
HAPPENING TO HIM.
17 WINS, THAT'S A BOLD
PREDICTION, BUT I LIKE IT.
JOHN SMOLTZ, YOU WILL HEAR HIM
PLENTY WITH SCOTT BRAUN, CARLOS
PENA, ALANNA RIZZO.
SMOLTZY, THANK YOU.
JOHN: YOU GOT IT.
STEPHEN: WHO IS GOING TO WIN
TODAY?
TAMPA BAY OR BOSTON?
55% IF YOU GOING WITH THE RED
SOX TO SWEEP THE RAYS.
BILL: THAT LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF
NORTHEASTERN ROSE.
THESE ARE TWO PRETTY GOOD TEAMS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE RAYS
WILL BE THERE ONCE AGAIN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT LAUGH TEAMS DOWN THE
STRETCH.
RED SOX WILL GO AS FAR AS THE
BIG THREE, BOGAERTS, DEVERS,
J.D. MARTINEZ.
IF YOU HIT THOSE GUYS IN ORDER
T VE SE WORK.
STHEN: FIRST PITCH, SCOTTY
B'S GOT YOU.
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP!
>> WHAT A PLAY! >> ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
OH, MY!
SCOTT: SIGNS OF SPRING THIS WEEK
WITH TEMPERATURES RISING IN THE
NORTHEAST.
STRESS LEVELS HIGH YESTERDAY
WITH THE RED SOX MOUNTING THREE
LEG COMEBACKS AND WALKING OFF
WITH EXTRAS.
BACK AT IT 14 HOURS LATER FOR A
GLOBAL AUDIENCE.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
IN MASSACHUSETTS, IT IS THE
BOSTON RED SOX.--IT IS THE TAMPA
BAY RAYS WITH THE BOSTON RED
SOX.
I'M SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH HALL
OF FAMER JOHN SMOLTZ, BRINGING
YOU THE ACTION FROM STUDIO K.
HELLO TO THE YOUTUBE AUDIENCE
AROUND THE GLOBE FOR THE FIRST
JOURNEY ON YOUTUBE IN 2021.
JOHN, YOU LIKE TO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH TEAMS,
AND SOME I NOT KNOW, LONGTIME
BRAVE BUT A LITTLE SLIVER WITH
THE BOSTON RED SOX IN 2009.
JOHN: THERE MIGHT BE PEOPLE
SCRATCHING THEIR HEAD, WHAT IS
SMOLTZ DOING ON THE BROADCAST?
I WAS ABLE TO GET WITH THE
HISTORIC ORGANIZATION AFTER A
SOLDIER SURGERY.
IF I COULD HAVE A REDO --
SCOTT: WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT.
INTRODUCING THE YOUTUBE AUDIENCE
TO THE GAME OF THE WEEK.
THIS IS GLOBAL ON MLB'S YOUTUBE
CHANNEL, AND IT IS ALL FREE,
TELL YOUR FRIENDS.
JOIN THE 2.7 MILLION OTHER FANS
IN SUBSCRIBING TO THE MLB
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
CLICK THE BELL ICON TO RECEIVE A
NOTIFICATION PRIOR TO UPCOMING
GAME SYSTEM WE HAVE MORE
FRIENDS AS WELL.
CARLOS PENA REPRESENTS THE
TEMPER BAY RACE.
LONGTIME--TAMPA BAY RAYS.
YOU REALLY KNOW THE TEAM WELL,
CARLOS.
HOW ARE YOU DOING TODAY?
CARLOS: DOING VERY WELL.
EXCITED TO BE WITH YOU GUYS.
I GUESS I'M THE PERFECT GUY WITH
THE SITUATION BECAUSE I KNOW
BOSTON LIKE THE PALM OF MY HAND,
AND AT THE SAME TIME, I PLAYED
FOR THE RAYS.
VERY PROUD TO SAY SO.
EXPERIENCE TO 2008 WORLD SERIES
WITH THEM.
I'M EXCITED TO GET IT ON WITH
THIS BALLGAME.
SCOTT: AND THE CAPE COD LEAK
M.V.P.
THE LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS WITH
THE RAYS AND RED SOX, WE WILL
RUN THROUGH IT.
YARBOROUGH MATCHING UP AGAINST
NATE EOVALDI.
SMOLTZY,, YOU CAN CALL THESE TWO
VERY DIFFERENT PITCHERS.
JOHN: YOU COULDN'T BE MORE
OPPOSITE THESE GUYS.
THROWING WITH A DIFFERENT AND
TOMORROW.
YARBOROUGH IS GOING TO
MIX-AND-MATCH SPIN, SOFT
CONTACT.
EOVALDI WILL HAVE THE RADAR GUN
LIGHTED UP AND USE HIS STUFF TO
POWER THROUGH THE LINEUP.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THESE
PITCHERS, YOU GOTTA THINK
TOTALLY OPPOSITE OF WHAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
WE KNOW WHAT THE RAYS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO AS A PITCHING STAFF
ALSO CAN MIX-AND-MATCH WITH
ANYBODY.
EOVALDI'S START TODAY WILL BE
SUPER IMPORTANT.
I KNOW IT IS EARLY, BUT AS THEY
GET HEALTHY, PITCHING WILL KEEP
THEM IN.
SCOTT: HE IS COMING OFF A GOOD
ONE ON OPENING DAY AGAINST THE
ORIOLES.
YARBOROUGH WAS GOOD IN HIS FIRST
START AS WELL.
THE PROBLEM FOR EOVALDI, I WOULD
SAY, CARLOS HE WILL CIRCLE THE
LINEUP IN THE SPOT WHERE RANDY
AROZARENA IS.
HOW DO I PITCH THIS GUY?
HE WAS INCREDIBLE IN THE
PLAYOFFS LAST YEAR.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
JOHN: YOU --
CARLOS: HE REALLY WAS
IMPRESSIVE.
HIS APPROACH WAS PRISTINE.
HE STARTED FROM THE STRIKE ZONE
DOWN AND THAT HELPED HIM.
THEY THREW HIM FASTBALL.
MOSTLY OFFSPEED, IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT.
LOOK AT THE REGULAR-SEASON,
POSTSEASON SPLIT.
THE POSTSEASON WAS MONSTROUS.
THOSE ARE RECORD-SETTING
NUMBERS.
10 HOME RUNS IN THE POSTSEASON,
THAT IS A RECORD.
HE WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT REALLY
PERFORMED OFFENSIVELY.
THIS IS PERHAPS WHY THE RAYS
COULD NOT WIN THAT WORLD SERIES.
IF HE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN A LITTLE
BIT OF HELP, MAYBE WE WOULD BE
TELLING A DIFFERENT STORY AND HE
WOULD HAVE A RING ON HIS FINGER.
HERE THEY GO AGAIN, THEY WILL
GIVE IT ANOTHER WHIRL.
RANDY AROZARENA WITH VERY HIGH
EXPECTATIONS.
SCOTT: IT'S CRAZY, BUT HE IS
STILL RICKY-ELIGIBLE-- ROOKIE-
ELIGIBLE EVEN THOUGH HE PLAYED
MORE IN THE PLAYOFFS DURING THE
REGULAR--THEN DURING THE SEASON.
ACCORDING TO ALEX CORA, HE SAID
WE HAVE PLAYERS WITH WORLD
SERIES RINGS AND PLAYERS WITH
PROVEN TRACK RECORDS.
JOHN: THEY DO, AND THEIR OFFENSE
SHOULD NOT TAKE A BACKSEAT?
LAST YEAR WAS NOT GREAT FOR THE
RED SOX FOR A LOT OF REASONS.
BUT THEY HAVE A STABLE OFFENSE
THAT SUITS THE BALLPARK WELL.
XANDER BOGAERTS, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SHORTSTOPS ALL THROUGHOUT
BASEBALL.
HE HAD A BIG CONTRACT EXTENSION.
HE IS THE HEART AND SOUL OF THE
MIDDLE INFIELD.
J.D. MARTINEZ, WHAT CAN YOU SAY
ABOUT HIM?
THE AS A PITCHER'S NIGHTMARE.
LAST YEAR WAS AN OUTLIER.
A LOT OF THINGS CHANGE FOR A LOT
OF PLAYERS.
HE HAD A DEATH LOOK FOR HIM TO
HAVE A MONSTER YEAR AGAIN.
-- LOOK FOR HIM TO HAVE A
MONSTER YEAR AGAIN.
IT IS ABOUT WHETHER THEY CAN
KEEP THE ARMS ON THE MOUND
HEALTHY TO COMPLEMENT THE
OFFENSE.
IT IS NOT TOO EARLY TO SAY THAT
OFFENSIVELY, LAST FEW GAMES HAVE
BEEN HUGE.
THEY NEEDED TO GET UP TO A GOOD
START.
THEY RALLIED AND ARE IN POSITION
TO UTILIZE THE OFFENSE.
SCOTT: IT WAS A TOP FIVE TEAM IN
TERMS OF OFFENSE IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE LAST YEAR BUT THE
LAST-PLACE TEAM IN THE AL EAST.
ALEX CORA PULLED HIS EARLIER THE
J.D. MARTINEZ IS BACK, HE SAID
HE WAS NEVER BACK.
LET'S WELCOME THE FOURTH MEMBER
OF OUR TEAM, ALANNA RIZZO, WHO
IS STATIONED AT FENWAY PARK.
ALANNA: RED SOX SLUGGER J.D.
MARTINEZ HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
VOCAL ABOUT HIS PREFERENCE TO BE
ABLE TO USE VIDEO IN THE GAME TO
MAKE THOSE IN GAME OFFENSIVE
ADJUSTMENTS.
IN 2020, THAT ROUTINE WAS
DISRUPTED WHEN MLB DISALLOWED
VIDEO ROOMS AS WELL AS VIDEO IN
THE DUGOUT TO TRY TO PROMOTE
SOCIAL DISTANCING, ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE COMING OFF
THE HEELS OF THAT 2017
INVESTIGATION INTO THE WORLD
SERIES.
IN 2021, THE VIDEO IS BACK ON
THE LEAGUE-ISSUED IPADS IN
MAKING DIVIDENDS FOR J.D.
MARTINEZ.
SO FAR THIS SEASON, TWO HOME
RUNS FIVE DOUBLES.
THAT TWOP-RUN, TWO-OUT DOUBLE
SECURED THE WIN.
LAST SEASON WAS ABSOLUTELY AN
ANOMALY.
YOU CAN SEE ALL THE OFFENSIVE
CATEGORIES THAT PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT, ALL DOWN IN THE 2020
YEAR.
J.D. MARTINEZ LIKING THE VIDEO
COMEBACK IN THE DUGOUT, BACK IN
THE VIDEO ROOMS COME NOT ONLY
FOR HIMSELF, BUT TO HELP HIS
TEAMMATES AS WELL.
SCOTT: THANKS, ALANNA.
HE HAS BEEN SAYING JUST SHOW ME
THEEO, AND HE IS RIGHT.
MONROE FROM LAST SEASON VISITING
THE '-- RUNNER UP FROM LAST
SEASON VISITING THE '18
CHAMPS.
>> THESE TWO TEAMS HATE EACH
OTHER.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SOME BEAN
BALLS IN THIS SERIES.
>> THESE TWO TEAMS GO AT IT.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN.
>> THAT IS WHAT MAKES THIS A
GREAT RIVALRY.
>> OH, AND HE HITS WILLIAMS.
PEDRO MARTINEZ.
>> NO CRYING IN BASEBALL.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS, UP AND IN.
>> THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
INTENTIONAL.
>> THAT WAS ABOUT THE FIFTH OR
SIXTH GUY HIT VALUE PITCHING THE
SERIES.
>> LET'S HOPE THAT IS THE END OF
THE FUNNY STUFF NOW.
SWING AND A DRIVE!
YOU WILL HIT IT OUT-- HE WILL
HIT IT OUT.
ORTIZ IS GOING DOWN TOWARDS THE
MOUND.
>> HERE WE GO.
LOOK OUT, AND ORTIZ GETS HIT IN
THE BACK.
>> IT'S A WAR.
IT'S ON.
>> AN ABSOLUTELY IN-YOUR-FACE
MOVE.
>> PLAYER AGAINST PLAYER,
ORGANIZATION AGAINST
ORGANIZATION.
>> TO ME THAT IS A TRUE RIVALRY.
SCOTT: IT'S A CLOUDY DAY IN
BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS.
TEMPERATURES IN THE 50'S FOR THE
RAYS AND THE RED SOX, REVVING UP
THE SERIES AGAINST EACH OTHER.
LET'S INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
STARTING LINEUP, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
YOUR SHEETS ARE TO GO WILL LEAD
THE WAY FOR TAMPA BAY--YOSHI
TSUTSUGO WILL LEAD THE WAY FOR,
TAMPA BAY.
YANDY DIAZ IS THE DH THIS
AFTERNOON.
JOEY WENDLE WITH EXCELLENT
CAREER NUMBERS AGAINST EOVALDI,
5-7.
MARGOT, MEJIA, AND ADAMES TO
WRAP UP THE NIN-- ROUND OUT THE
NIEN.
THE FIRST START OF THE SEASON
FOR NATE EOVALDI FUTURE
TEMPERATURES IN THE LOW 30'S.
20-DEGREE BUMP, HOW DOES THAT
HELP?
JOHN: THAT IS GOING TO HELP.
YOU NEED THE SECONDARY STUFF
WORKING.
THIS GUY IS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
RED SOX AS THEY GET THEIR OTHER
GUYS HEALTHY.
HE IS JUST GO GET 'EM.
HE CAN LIGHT UP THE RADAR GUN.
AT TIMES IF HE IS NOT AHEAD IN
THE COUNT, HE DOES HAVE A HUGE
ADVANTAGE SO FAR THAT HITTERS
HAVE A FEW IT -- HITTERS HAVE A
FEW ADVANTAGE SO FAR.
KIND OF A NOLAN RYAN THROWBACK.
SCOTT: FUNNY YOU MENTION THAT
NAME BECAUSE HE IS FROM ALVIN,
TEXAS COME JUST LIKE NOLAN RYAN.
GREW UP IDOLIZING NOLAN RYAN.
FIDELITY DEFENSE FOR THE BOSTON
RED SOX.
BOBBY DALBEC IS BACK AT FIRST
BASE.
CHRISTIAN ARROYO NEXT TO HIM.
EOVALDI PLAYING CATCH WITH KEVIN
PLAWECKI THIS AFTERNOON.
J.D. MARTINEZ, KIKÉ HERNANDEZ,
AND HUNTER RENFROE.
FIRST START OF THE SEASON FOR
J.D.
GETS A RUN ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BASEBALL.
CARLOS: THAT IS A DIFFERENT
OUTFIELD, SCOTTY.
WE SEE KIKÉ HERNANDEZ PLAYING
CENTER FIELD.
HE WILL BE PLAYING ALL OVER THE
PLACE, AS WELL AS MOMENT IN
DOLLARS.
IT ADDS A LOT OF VERSATILITY FOR
THE RED SOX TO HAVE THOSE GUYS
ON BOARD.
SCOTT: THERE IS KIKÉ IN CENTER.
MARMON HAS BEEN PLAYING
EVERYWHERE ALREADY.
HE SAYS HE IS MORE COMFORTABLE
PLAYING IN DIFFERENT SPOTS ON
DIFFERENT OCCASIONS.
EOVALDI'S SET.
FIRST PITCH OF THE SEASON
DELIVERED LIVE ON YOUTUBE AS WE
ARE READY TO GO FOR RAYS AND THE
RED SOX.
THIS IS OUTSIDE FOR YOU SHEEP --
YOSHI TSUTSUGO.
1-1.
CARLOS, HE HAD TROUBLE HANDLING
HIGH VELOCITY LAST YEAR, COMING
OVER FROM JAPAN, SIGNING A
TWO-YEAR CONTRACT WITH TAMPA
BAY, LOOKING TO GET HIMSELF
ACCLIMATED.
PULLS THE 1-1 DOWN THE LINE.
NICE PLAY BY DELL BACK -- DALBEC
FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
CARLOS: RIGHT THERE IT ISN'T
THAT HE NEEDS TO GET AN
ADJUSTMENT ON TO GET THE HIGH
SPEED FASTBALL.
SORT OF A CUTTER THAT COUNTS
HIM, BUT ABLE TO GET GOOD
BARREL, AND JUST A BETTER PLAY
IN DALBEC'S HAND.
SCOTT: DALBEC A NATURAL THIRD
BASEMAN.
PICKING UP FIRST VERY QUICKLY.
HE LOOKS LIKE A NATURAL THERE.
NOW IT IS AUSTIN MEADOWS.
HEALTH SETBACKS LAST YEAR.
BUT AN ALL-STAR IN 2019.
HE HAD A COUPLE YEARS AGO, WITH
89 RBIS.
LAST YEAR JUST FOUR AND THE
SHORTENED SEASON.
JOHN: A LOT OF THE OFFENSE
PREDICATED ON THE LONG BALL.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE GOT THE
SAME BASIC OFFENSE THEY HAD LAST
YEAR, EVEN THOUGH THEY STRUGGLED
DOWN THE STRETCH OF THE
POSTSEASON.
A LOT OF THAT WOULD BE
CONTRIBUTED TO BIG PITCHING.
SCOTT: BREAKDOWN FROM YOU,
SMOLTZY, PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
JOHN: FOR EOVALDI, IT WILL BE
KEY TO ESTABLISH HIS FASTBALL
AND GET AHEAD OF THE COUNT.
HE HAD STRUGGLES AGAINST
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS IN PITCHED
AHEAD.
WHEN HE IS BEHIND, THE NUMBERS
ARE NOT GOOD.
GIVE THE RED SOX SOME INNINGS.
SCOTT: POPPED UP.
HERE COMES DEVERS AND VAL GROUND
FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
-- IN FOUL GROUND FOR OUT NUMBER
TWO.
JOHN: HE IS BEHIND IN THE COUNT
OVER THE LAST -- UNTIL 2019,
HITTING AGAINST HIM .449.
EVERY PITCHER WANTS TO GO STRIKE
ONE, BUT TO BE ABLE TO PITCH
WITH HIS STUFF AND GET HITTERS
OFF THE HARD FASTBALL BECAUSE
THE CUTTER-FASTBALL COMBINATION
-- HE HAS GIVEN UP A HIGHER
AVERAGE THEN HE SHOULD WITHOUT
BID.
-- WITH THAT PITCH.
SCOTT: HERE IS THE MATCHUP WITH
AROZARENA.
HE TAKES THE FIRST PITCH ON THE
INSIDE CORNER.
ALEX CORA MENTIONED TO US THAT
THE RAYS FACED EOVALDI IN SPRING
TRAINING AND THEY AMBUSHED HIM
ON FIRST PITCH, SO ALEX THINKS
IT WAS A GOOD LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR NATE FOR THE
REGULAR SEASON MATCHUP.
ON HANDS, A LITTLE BLOOPER FOUL.
JOHN: SPRING TRAINING, IF YOU
ARE A VETERAN PITCHER, YOU CAN
PLAY MIND TRICKS WITH THE OTHER
TEAM, ESPECIALLY WITH NO TRAVEL,
THEY GOT TO FACE EACH OTHER.
WHAT I WOULD'VE DONE IS THROW
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN I WAS
GOING TO THROW KNOWING MY
MATCHUPS IN THE REGULAR SEASON,
GET THEM SCRATCHING THEIR HEAD A
LITTLE BIT.
ON THE REVERSE HE CAN UTILIZE
SOME THE INFORMATION IN SPRING
TRAINING AND GO, OK, I WILL MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENT.
SCOTT: SO FAR HIM SO GOOD.
HE IS AHEAD OF--SO FAR, SO GOOD.
HE IS AHEAD OF AROZARENA.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THE DEFENSE, A
LOT OF SPACE UP THE MIDDLE.
HE JUST MISSED.
CARLOS: YOU CAN SEE HIM WORKING
RIGHT HERE, JUST WITH THE HIGH
FASTBALL, AND THEN THE OFFSPEED.
AROZARENA LATE ON SOME OF THOSE
FASTBALLS, AND THAT IS WHAT
EOVALDI WANTS, TO KEEP HIM IN
BETWEEN AS FAR AS TIMING IS
CONCERNED.
SCOTT: GOES WITH A SLOWER STUFF
TO GET THE EASY ROLLER, DOWN THE
SIDE IN ORDER.
1-2-3 FIRST FRED SOX BATTING INF
THE FIRST.
>> RED SOX HAVE A BUNCH OF GUYS
WHO ARE DUE, AND HERE IS ONE OF
THEM, HUNTER RENFROE.
0-8.
LONG DIVE!
WHAT A PLAY BY AROZARENA!
SPECTACULAR PLAY.
VAZQUEZ WILL TAG IT.
HE IS IN TO SCORE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU WILL SEE A
BETTER PLAY BY AN OUTFIELDER ALL
SEASON LON.
>> THIS ONE WAS GOING TO GO OVER
HIS HEAD.
HE JUMPS, DIVES.
>> AROZARENA GOING BACK.
STILL GOING BACK.
THIS ONE IS OVER.
IN THE THIRD, J.D.
BEING WAVED HOME.
TOO LATE.
GOES DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE!
XANDER WILL SCORE.
RED SOX LEAD 5-0.
>> WENT AFTER THAT ONE ON THE
OUTSIDE CORNER.
THAT ONE SAILING, AND IT IS GONE
.
THREE-RUN HOMER FOR J.D.
MARTINEZ, AND THE SOX BLOW
IT OPEN AND THE EIGHTH INNING.
SCOTT: A CLEAN FIRST FROM NATE
EOVALDI.
AGAINST THE STARTING LINEUP FOR
THE RED SOX, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
GAY HERNANDEZ --KIKÉ HERNANDEZ
IN CENTER.
J.D. ON FIRE TO START
THE SEASON.
RENFRO, ARROYO, DALBEC BACK IN
THE LINEUP, AND PLAWECKI, THE
CATCHER.
HERE'S THE PITCHER.
EVERY DIFFERENT LOOK.
OFFENDER RYAN YARBROUGH--
LEFT-HANDER RYAN YARBROUGH.
THEY CALL IT CONTACT
SUPPRESSION.
JOHN: HE CREATES THE ILLUSION TO
THE HITTER THAT THE BALL IS
GOING TO GET THERE AND IT
DOESN'T.
HE RELIES A LOT ON SPIN AND A
LOT OF CHANGE OF DIRECTION OF
THE BASEBALL.
TELL YOU WHAT TO MY KNOW HE HAS
BEEN VIEWED AS A RELIEVER
STATISTICALLY, BUT HE IS A
STARTER.
THE USE HIM OUT OF THE BULLPEN
AFTER THE OPENER OR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT, BUT NOW I THINK
YOU WILL PROVIDE A LOT OF
INNINGS AS A STARTER.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH TO KIKÉ
HERNANDEZ MISSES WIDE.
COMING OFF AN EXCELLENT OPENING
PERFORMANCE AGAINST THE MARLINS.
NOT A LONG LEASH.
THAT IS TAMPA BAY STYLE.
HE FINDS THE ZONE AGAINST
HERNANDEZ.
CARLOS, ALSO, RYAN YARBROUGH
GREW UP IN FLORIDA, HUGE TAMPA
BAY RAYS FAN, CARLOS PENA FAT.
HE LOVES THE 2008 SQUAD.
CARLOS: HOW ABOUT THAT?
THIS IS GREAT WHEN YOU SEE GUYS
ROOTING FOR A BALLCLUB AND THEN
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
ON THAT JERSEY.
IT IS LITERALLY A DREAM COME
TRUE.
YARBOROUGH IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
WHO DOES NOT TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED.
YOU HEAR HIM TALK ABOUT HIS
STYLE OF PITCHING.
HE DOESN'T CARE THAT HE'S
DIFFERENT FROM THE EPIC LEFTIES
THE RAYS HAD.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT STYLE.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE CONTACT.
ADAMES PUTS AWAY HERNANDEZ.
MORE ON THAT WEAK CONTACT.
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE FOR RYAN
YARBROUGH.
BREAKDOWN PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
JOHN: SOFT CONTACT, THAT IS WHAT
A LOT OF PITCHERS LIKE TO HEAR.
HE GETS THEM TO DO WHAT THEY CAN
DO, PLAY GREAT DEFENSE.
WE SAW WITH THE FIRST HITTER,
PITCHED LIKE A STARTER.
I MENTIONED ALL BEGINNINGS HE
GETS AS A RELIEVER AFTER SOMEONE
ELSE STARTED THE GAME.
I THINK THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE
A THROWBACK A GUY IN AN ERA OF
VELOCITY.
HE KNOWS HOW TO PITCH, HOW TO
CHANGE ARM ANGLES, AND QUADRANTS
OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
SCOTT: HE FINDS THE ZONE AGAINST
RAFAEL DEVERS, WHO PICKED UP HIS
FIRST TWO HITS OF THE SEASON
YESTERDAY, RECORDING A 2-5
PERFORMANCE WASN'T 24 YEARS OLD,
IN HIS FOURTH SEASON ALREADY, IS
DEVERS, THE THIRD BASEMAN.
JOHN: I MEAN, HE IS PRETTY MUCH
GOING TO GO AFTER RIGHT-HANDERS
WITH A LOT OF CHANGEUPS, AND
LEFT-HANDERS THAT DO FACE HIM IN
THE LINEUP, HE WILL GIVE YOU
MORE FASTBALLS BECAUSE HE GIVES
THE ILLUSION THAT THE 88 IS
REALLY 96 AND 95 BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGE IN TEMPO.
TO MEET, PITCHING IT IS ABOUT
CHANGING THE TIMING OF THE
HITTER AND CRATING FEAR THAT THE
HEATER CANNOT LAY OUT INTO ONE
OF THOSE PITCHES.
HAS TO HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THOUGHTS IN HIS HEAD IN DISGUISE
ON THE MOUND--WHEN THIS GUY IS
ON THE MOUND.
SCOTT: TWO QUICK STRIKES.
DEVERS STAYS ALIVE.
CARLOS: THIS IS A VERY DYNAMIC
CONFRONTATION, BECAUSE DEVERS
HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR HIS EXIT
VELOCITY.
FIFTH AMONG HITTERS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE IN 2020.
93 MILES PER HOUR OFF OF HIS
BAT.
YARBOROUGH IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
WHO TRIES TO DO THE OPPOSITE,
INDUCE WEAK CONTACT.
VERY INTERESTING MATCHUP WE HAVE
GOT GOING TODAY.
SCOTT: YARBOROUGH LIKES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OVERAGGRESSIVE
HITTERS.
FEASTS ON LONG SWING.
DEVERS GOES FISHING.
JOHN: JUST A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF YOU DON'T HAVE TO JUST FIRE
THE BASEBALL AND LET YOUR STUFF
TAKE CARE OF HITTERS.
SEE THAT ARM ANGLE AND THAT
RELEASE POINT?
I GUARANTEE YOU NEVER THOUGHT
THAT WAS IN THE STRIKE ZONE A
LOT LONGER WHEN IT WAS.
THAT IS WHY WHEN YOU SIT AT HOME
HOW CAN IT LOOK THAT BAD, IT IS
BECAUSE WHEN HE SAW THAT TUNNEL
OUT OF THE PITCHERS HAND, IT
LOOKS LIKE A STRIKE.
WE CAN SEE THE RESULTS WERE
NOWHERE CLOSE WASN'T  WHEN
YOU HAVE THE ANGLE YOU ARE
TRYING TO HIT OFF OF.
SCOTT: GOOD LUCK TO YARBOROUGH.
GOING THE OTHER WAY.
WE WILL SEE IF IT IS PLAYABLE
FOR AROZARENA IN RIGHT FIELD.
HE'S GOT IT IN HIS GLOVE!
CATCH IS MADE RIGHT NEXT TO THE
FANS.
GREAT TO HAVE FANS BACK FOR
2021.
RANDY AROZARENA UNFAZED.
WHAT A PLAY.
CARLOS: THAT IS A TOUGH CORNER
RIGHT THERE IN FENWAY PARK.
SCOTT: HEY, WATCH OUT.
ABOUT SIX PEOPLE GOING FOR THAT
BALL, AND THE RIGHT MAN FOR THE
RAYS CAME UP WITH IT.
>> RED SOX HAVE JUST THREE HITS.
GLASNOW.
>> YOU SEE ONCE AGAIN THE SLIDER
BEING THE GO-TO AFTER THE
FASTBALL.
CURVEBALL HAS MAINLY BEEN TO PUT
GUYS AWAY AT THE END OF THE
COUNT.
>> 8TH STRIKEOUT FOR TYLER
GLASNOW.
>> SWING AND A MISS!
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> WATCH HIS REACTION AFTER HE
GETS THE OUT.
>> GROUNDED OUT TO THIRD,
WALKED, AND STRUCK OUT.
I FLYBALL!-- HIGH FLY BALL!
WATCH IT GO!
IT IS GONE!
THIS GAME IS TIED!
>> WINNING RUN IS ON BASE, AND
NOW A SINGLE GOOD WIN THE GAME.
>> THAT ONE IS DRIVEN RIGHT
FIELD.
AROZARENA BACKING UP, BACKING
UP.
IT'S OVER HIS HEAD!
AND THE RED SOX ARE GOING TO WIN
THE GAME!
TWO-RUN SCORE!
BOSTON WINS!
BOY IS THAT A FITTING END TO
THIS ONE.
>> WHAT A BALLGAME THIS WAS.
SCOTT: BACK AT FENWAY PARK, AND
THE LAST CATCH, MAYBE CATCH FOR
RANDY AROZARENA, IS UNDER REVIEW
AT THE MOMENT.
THAT IS GOOD, BECAUSE, CARLOS, I
WANTED TO GET A FEW MORE LOOKS
AT THAT CATCH IN RIGHT FIELD
AMIDST THE FANS.
CARLOS: I MEAN, WE REALLY HAD NO
CLUE WHAT WAS GOING ON.
I THINK IT WENT THROUGH A
DIFFERENT SET OF HANDS, ENDED UP
IN HIS GLOVE.
IS IT INTERFERENCE?
AT THE END OF THE DAY HE ENDED
UP WITH A BASEBALL IN THE MITT.
THAT LOOKS CLEAN TO ME RIGHT
THERE.
I THINK THAT'S AN OUT, NO
PROBLEM.
SCOTT: THAT'S EXCELLENT
CONCENTRATION, JOHN.
JOHN: YEAH.
HEH.
WITH THE PARK'S NOT HAVING FULL
CAPACITY, OF COURSE, YOU ARE
SUBJECT TO WHERE FANS ARE
LOCATED.
J.D. HAD ONE OF THOSE
RARE HOME RUNS THE OTHER NIGHT
OFF THAT POLE DOWN THE LINE,
WHICH CAN'T BE OTHER THAN A
NIGHTMARE FOR A PITCHER.
SCOTT: DO YOU CRINGE WHEN YOU
SEE THAT?
JOHN: OH.
SCOTT: 306 FEET OFF THE HOMER ON
MONDAY FOR THE PAST -- PE
SKY POLE.
JOHN: THAT'S PART OF THE DEAL,
THOUGH.
CARLOS: IT IS A DIFFICULT
CORNER.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO FOUL
TERRITORY.
YOU ARE RUNNING FULL SPEED, YOU
ARE GOING TOWARDS THE WALL.
YOU KNOW IF YOU DROP IT, IT IS A
FAIR BALL.
NOW FANS DO FACTOR IN.
I'M SURE AROZARENA DOESN'T MIND
THAT.
PLAYERS WANT  FANS AND THE
STANDS.
BUT THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT SPOTS TO PLAY DEFENSE
IN IN ENTIRE BALLPARK.
SCOTT: AND WE WILL CONTINUE THE
FIRST INNING.
J.D. BACK TO THE PLATE.
JOHN: I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED.
SCOTT: IT'S ONE OF THOSE WERE
DESPITE THE RULES, AND IT BEING
OUT OF PLAY BECAUSE IT TOUCHES A
FAN, YOU WISH, CARLOS, THAT FOR
THIS CASE THE RULE DOESN'T
EXIST, BECAUSE THINK ABOUT THE
CONCENTRATION, HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO DEAL WITH SURROUNDINGS.
J.D. IS GOING TO STEP
UP WITH NOBODY ON AND TWO OUTS,
AND WE CONTINUE THE FIRST
INNING.
CARLOS: YES, HE GETS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO SWING AT BAT.
THIS IS NOT WHAT THE RAYS.
YES, I DO AGREE WITH YOU, SCOTTY
-- YOU LOOK AT THAT PLAY, WAY TO
SECOND, AROZARENA JUST MADE A
GREAT DEFENSIVE PLAY, AND IT
REALLY LOOKS -- COMMON SENSE
WOULD TELL YOU, THAT GUY SHOULD
BE OUT.
BUT IF YOU GO TO THE
NITTY-GRITTY OF THE RULE,
INTERFERENCE IS CALLED, THE BALL
IS DEAD, AND NOW HERE WE HAVE
J.D. WITH ANOTHER SHOT.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY CAN CLOSE
OUT VISITING.
JOHN: GOOD NEWS FOR THE PITCHER
BECAUSE THIS CAN BE A MENTALLY
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
WE SEE THE REPLAY ONE MORE TIME.
CAN'T QUITE SEE THE PERFECT
ANGLE, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT GOT
TOUCHED.
FROM A PITCHER'S STANDPOINT, YOU
JUST GOT OUT OF A GREAT HITTER
AND YOU GO, OH, SHOOT, I HAVE
GOT TO GO FACE THIS GREAT
HITTER.
ALREADY MADE THE ADJUSTMENTS HE
TALKED ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE
THAT HE COULDN'T MAKE LAST YEAR.
HE CRUSHED CHANGEUPS LAST YEAR
AND IS GOOD AGAINST LEFT HANDED
BREAKING BALLS WITH HIS POWER.
FIVE HOME RUN SINCE THE ALL-STAR
BREAK OF 2019 ON BREAKING BALLS
OFF THE LEFT-HAND.
SCOTT: J.D. LEADS
BASEBALL IN EXTRA-BASE HITS
ABOUT A WEEK INTO THE SEASON.
HE HAS SEVEN OF THEM ALREADY.
JOHN: AS A PITCHER, THE ONE
THING ABOUT GREATEST IS YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE VIDEOS AND SEE THE
INFORMATION, BUT THEIR ABILITY
TO ADJUST YEAR-TO-YEAR AND EVEN
IN SEASON IS WHY THEY ARE GREAT
CATERERS.
IT IS WHY YOU CANNOT JUST PITCH
THEM ONE WAY EVEN THOUGH THE
INFORMATION WILL TELL YOU SOME
OF HIS WEAKNESSES.
SCOTT: THAT WENT ON THE GROUND,
GOBBLED UP IN THIRD.
WENDLE RETIRES MARTINEZ.
THAT WILL OFFICIALLY CONCLUDE
THE FIRST INNING.
SCORELESS AT FEN
>> HI, I AM RYAN YARBROUGH,
PITCHER FOR THE TAMPA BAY RAYS
AND THIS IS GOOGLE.
WHY DID RYAN YARBROUGH PLAY
BASEBALL?
I STARTED IN TEE-BALL ABOUT FOUR
YEARS OLD AND ALWAYS HAD A LOOK
FOR THE GAME, JUST CAP PLAYING
MY WHOLE LIFE AND FORTUNATE TO
PLAY THE BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
WHY DOES RYAN YARBROUGH HAVE
SHORT HAIR?
BECAUSE MY LONG HAIR LOOKS LIKE
A MOP, AND NOBODY WANTS TO SEE
THAT, SO WE KEEP IT SHORT.
PLUS, THAT KEEPS THE WIFE HAPPY.
WHY RYAN YARBROUGH LEFT-HANDED?
DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY ARE
CERTAIN HANDED, JUST IT IS WHAT
IS FEEL COMFORTABLE.
WHY IS RYAN YARBROUGH TELL?
AGAIN, I THINK IT IS JUST
GENETICS.
WHY IS RYAN YARBROUGH NAMED
RYAN?
BECAUSE MY PARENTS LIKED THE
NAME.
I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW THE OTHER
NAMES THEY WERE THINKING, BUT
I'M OK WITH IT.
SCOTT: THE FIRST MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK, LIVE ON YOUTUBE IN 2021,
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN SMOLTZ, CARLOS
PENA ANDALON ARIST -- CARLOS
PENA, AND ALANNA RIZZO.
THIS SERIES HAS HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF EVERYTHING.
DAVE VIVALDI BACK TO WORK.
BRANDON LOWE IN THE FOURTH SPOT
FOR TAMPA BAY.
JOHN: STRENGTH AGAINST STRENGTH.
BRANDON LOVES IT UP.
YOU HAVE TO GET THEM OUT DOWN.
YOU SEE WHERE THAT TARGET IS?THE
HIM SO MUCH TROUBLE LAST YEAR.
IT IS HARD TO GET A GOOD -- I
DON'T KNOW, AVERAGE ON LOW
FASTBALLS IS NOT GOOD AGAINST
BRANDON.
HE LIKES THE BALL MIDDLE UP THE
MIDDLE AND.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR BIG SWING.
COULD NOT CATCH UP TO 97.
BRANDON LOWE FINISHED IN EIGHTH
IN AL M.V.P. VOTING LAST YEAR,
THE BEST REGULAR-SEASON
PERFORMER FOR TAMPERE. STREAKY
IN THE
TAMPERE'S.
JOHN: THE RESEARCH I'VE BEEN
DOING IS THE LOWEST BATTING
AVERAGE AGAINST PITCHES BUT
FASTBALL DOWN.
THE LOWEST BATTING AVERAGE AND
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL, SO YOU
CAN TELL WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
STUFF OF THE NEW POWER ARMS
TRYING TO GET THE BALL UP.
TYPICALLY, HE WILL NOT MISS A
LOT BUT THAT IS WHERE YOU WANT
TO GET HIM DOWN.
SCOTT: HE WILL MOSTLY PULL THOSE
BASEBALLS.
BUT, CARLOS, REMEMBER IN THE
WORLD SERIES, YOU HIT THREE HOME
RUNS, ALL TO THE OPPOSITE FIELD.
CARLOS: YES.
THAT IS WHEN YOU KNOW HE IS
GOING GOOD.
IF HE EVER GETS EOVALDI, HE
NEEDS TO GET IT EARLY ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO GET TO THAT UPPER
90'S FASTBALL WASTE IN THE UPPER
SIDE OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO, BUT IT IS
A MATTER OF TIMING.
I LOVE THIS SWING.
LOWE HAS A CRISP DELIVERY OF THE
BARREL TO THE BASEBALL AND
NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
SCOTT: THEY DO.
YOU CAN SEE HE WAS ONE OF THE
BEST SECOND BASEMAN IN BASEBALL
LAST YEAR.
ALONG WITH DJ LEMAHIEU, OF
COURSE.
3-2 SPOTTED.
JOHN: THAT IS THAT SPLITTER.
THAT IS THE SPLITTER THAT REALLY
HAS TAKEN EOVALDI AND HIS SECOND
TRACKBACK TO STARTING SINCE
COMING BACK FROM INJURIES.
IF HE HAS THAT PITCH GOING RIGHT
THERE, IT DEFINITELY TAKES A
STING OUT OF THE HITTER TRYING
TO GET READY FOR 97, 98, 99.
SCOTT: 12 PITCH, FIRST INNING
FROM NATE EOVALDI.
SEVENTH PITCH OR MAKE IT EIGHTH
PAGE OF THE SECOND.
-- EIGHTH PITCH OF THE SECOND.
AND THAT IS YANDY DIAZ.
FLOATER.
FOR RENFROE.
JOHN: THIS YEAR, I'M GOING TO BE
REALLY INTRIGUED TO SEE HOW THE
RAYS OVER 162, YOU KNOW THE
APPROACH LAST YEAR DID NOT
CONTINUE AND THEY TOOK
ADVANTAGE.
THEY THOUGHT 60 GAMES -- IT'S
NOT LIKE IT SURPRISED ANYBODY.
YOU KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY WERE GOING TO -- NO PUN
INTENDED -- CASH IN ON THAT
THEORY AND PHILOSOPHY THEY TOOK
LAST YEAR, BUT THIS YEAR, 162
WITH THE OFFENSE THEY HAVE IN
THE PHILOSOPHY THEY HAVE, WILL
THAT BE SUSTAINABLE FOR 162?
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT.
SCOTT: OF COURSE, EVERYONE
THINKS BACK TO GAME SIX OF THE
WORLD SERIES, BLAKE SNELL, AND
THEN REMOVED.
MOST OF THE WORLD SAID REMOVED
TOO SOON.
ALANNA RIZZO, WHAT DID YOU THINK
OF THE TAMPA BAY FROM LAST YEAR?
ALANNA: I WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF IT BEING WITH THE LOS ANGELES
DODGERS FOR SEVEN SEASONS.
I WAS VERY THANKFUL TO KEVIN
CASH FOR PULLING BLAKE SNELL
WHEN HE DID, GOING THROUGH THE
SCENARIOS AND HE WAS TALKING TO
JOHN SMOLTZ ABOUT IT EARLIER
TODAY, THAT IS THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO THAT PLAYED OUT IN
FRONT OF HIS EYES.
I ASKED, YOU HAVE MADE THAT
DECISION AGAIN?
HE SAID, ABSOLUTELY.
I GUESS YOU CAN SLEEP THEN
KNOWING IN THAT MOMENT THAT WAS
THE BEST DECISION HE THOUGHT FOR
THAT CLUB.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE STYLE THEY
HAVE AND IS A GOING TO SUSTAIN
OVER A 162 GAME SEASON?
HE SAYS SOME TEAMS ARE BUILT
THAT HAVE NINE GUYS TO WIN IT.
WE HAD 26 GUYS AND THAT IS WHAT
WE USE.
SCOTT: AND ONE OF THEM IS JOEY
WENDLE WHO FLIES THAT TO KIKÉ
HERNANDEZ INORLD SERIES
LAST YEAR.
AND OTHER TIGHT INNING FROM NATE
EOVALDI.
WE HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND.
>> HE SHOOTS THIS ONE INTO DEEP
RIGHT.
THAT HAS GOT A CHANCE TO GO AND
IT IS OUT OF HERE.
OFF THE FACING OF THE UPPER DECK
ON A 0-2 PITCH.
AUSTIN MEADOWS DOES IT AGAIN.
HIGH FLY BALL BACK TO LEFT.
TWO BALLS HAVE TO GO TO THE
WALL.
THAT BABY IS GONE!
HOME RUN FOR MANUEL MARGOT AND
THE RAYS LEAD 2-0.
ZUNINO HITS ONE DEEP TO LEFT.
BOY, THEY ARE GOING TO CATCH IT!
ZUNINO HITS IT OUT OF FEAR.
THE RAYS GRABBED A 2-1 LEAD.
>> YANDY DIAZ DRIVES ONE THROUGH
THE RIGHT SIDE AND GETS DOWN FOR
A BASE HIT.
MAYBE GOES ALL THE WAY TO THE
WALL.
MARGOT SCORES.
HERE COMES WENDELL AROUND THIRD.
NOT IN TIME.
IT IS A TWO RUN DOUBLE FOR YANDY
DIAZ AND THE RAYS HAVE TAKEN A
LEAD, 6-4.
>> RENFRO SHOOTS THIS INTO RIGHT
INTO AROZARENA.
A DIVING CATCH.
HE WILL GET UP TO TAG BY VAZQUEZ
AND SCORE BUT, OH, MY, WHAT A
GRAB BY AROZARENA!
SCOTT: HOME HALF OF THE SECOND
AT FENWAY PARK WITH 4, 5, 6 DUE
UP.
HERE IS A NEW FEATURE WE ARE
GOING TO AMPLIFY THIS YEAR ON
YOUTUBE, ANOTHER UNIQUE ASPECT
OF WATCHING, ARE INTERACTIVE
BOWLING FEATURE ALLOWS YOU TO
OFFER MULTIPLE-CHOICE RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS AND THE LOGIN
COMMENTARY, SO STAY TUNED AS
RESULTS ARE REVEALED AND
DISCUSSED IN THE BROADCAST.
WE WILL HAVE EVERYONE WEIGH IN.
SUPER EASY WITH A POLL RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU.
HE WAS GOING TO HAVE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT ON TODAY'S GAME?
AROZARENA, MEADOWS, BOGAERTS, OR
J.D. MARTINEZ?
JOHN: ONE ME TO ANSWER?
SCOTT: YES.
JOHN: I'M GOING C.
THE GUY AT THE PLATE RIGHT NOW,
JUST MY GUT.
HE LOVES LEFTIES.
SCOTT: SO IT IS MORE THAN YOUR
GUT.
IT IS AN INFORMED DECISION.
I LIKE IT.
XANDER BOGAERTS TAKES A STRIKE.
IT IS TIME TO WELCOME RFID
GENERALL -- WELCOME OUR
FIDELITY GUEST, MARTIN PEREZ.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
MARTIN: DOING WELL, HOW ARE YOU?
SCOTT: THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US THIS BOTTOM SECOND.
YARBOROUGH DEALS, A WEAKLY HIT
BALL TO THIRD AND WENDELL THROWS
IT AWAY.
XANDER BOGAERTS REACHES AND
STARTING TO MAKE JOHN SMOLTZ
LOOK GOOD.
LET'S START WITH THEIR LATEST
PERFORMANCE.
HOW DID YOU FEEL YESTERDAY?
MARTIN: I FEEL GREAT.
I WAS IN THE ZONE, REALLY GOOD
AND I THROUGH A LOT AND
EVERYTHING WORKED THE WAY THAT I
WAS SUPPOSED TO DO, BUT IT WAS
FUN LAST NIGHT.
JOHN: I LIKE WATCHING GUYS THAT
KNOW HOW TO PITCH.
IN A DAY AND ERA WHERE THERE IS
SO MUCH VELOCITY AND THAT'S ALL
WE TALK ABOUT, TALK ABOUT HOW
YOU USE THE INFORMATION AS YOU
KNOW HOW TO PITCH AND DON'T RELY
SO MUCH ON VELOCITY.
MARTIN: I THINK YOU KNOW MORE
THAN US.
EVERYTHING IS WHERE YOU ARE
GOING TO THROW THE BALL.
I KNOW VELOCITY IS GOOD
SOMETIMES, BUT IT DOES NOT MEAN
FOR ME THAT YOU NEED TO THROW
100 EVERY TIME TO GET PEOPLE OUT
.
I THINK IF YOU PUT THE BALL
WHERE YOU WANT, YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE A GOOD RESULT.
THAT IS THE WAY I HAVE BEEN
PITCHING RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION FROM
THE HITTERS, AND I JUST LIKE TO
GO OUT THERE AND USE IT THE WAY
THAT I CAN PITCH, JUST TRYING TO
MOVE THE BALL, STAY DOWN WITH
THE HITTERS THAT I KNOW DO NOT
HIT BALLS DOWN OR THE HITTERS
THAT DO NOT HIT THE BALL UP AND
IN, SO THAT IS HOW I LIKE TO
PITCH RIGHT NOW BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, AND THE YEARS BEFORE,
THROWING 96, 97, AND I GOT HIT
TOO EASILY.
NOW, IT IS TIME FOR ME TO MOVE
THE BALL AND THROW A LOT OF
STRIKES, JUST TRYING TO HIT THE
GLOVE EVERY TIME AND GO TO HOME
PLATE.
JOHN: AS A VISITOR WHEN I
PITCHED THERE, I PITCHED
ACCORDING TO THE WALL.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS GOOD OR
NOT, BUT HOW DOES THE WALL
AFFECT YOU KNOWING THIS BALLPARK
IS SO UNIQUE AND YOU PITCH AT
HOME?
MARTÍN: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T THINK TOO MUCH OF THE
WALL BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN
PITCHING HERE, YOU KNOW, LAST
YEAR, AND WHEN I WAS WITH THE
RANGERS AND TWINS, A PINCH
HITTER, TOO, AND THE WALL DID
NOT AFFECT ME AND I HAVE GREAT
NUMBERS HERE.
LIKE I SAID, JUST TRY TO FOCUS
ON THE HITTERS.
JUST TRYING TO GET, YOU KNOW,
MOST HITTERS OUT, AND THEN JUST
TRYING TO GIVE A CHANCE TO MY
TEAM TO WIN THE GAME.
CARLOS: YOU HAVE HEARD PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT YOU CAN ONLY THROW
INSIDE IF YOU THROW 90 AND IN
THE UPPER 90'S WHERE YOU CAN
ONLY GO UP AND IN IF YOU DON'T
97, 96, BUT YOU ARE THROWING
MORE INSIDE AND MORE UP IN THE
ZONE THAN EVER BEFORE.
WHAT DOES THAT COME FROM?
MARTÍN: I TALKED A LOT WITH A.C.
AND WE CHECK THE NUMBERS BEFORE
WE CAME HERE TO BOSTON.
I DO NOT HAVE TOO MANY HITS OR
THEY DON'T HIT WELL UP AND IN
AGAINST ME, SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO, TRYING TO START
WITH MY FASTBALL IN AND UP, AND
AFTER WITH THE CUTTER IN AND
THAT HAS WORKED GOOD FOR ME.
THAT IS ONE THING I HAVE ON MY
MIND RIGHT NOW, AND, YOU KNOW,
AFTER I DO THE JOB OPENING, I
CAN GO DOWN AND AWAY WITH A
CHANGE OR CUT IT OUTSIDE.
THAT IS ONE THING WE HAVE BEEN
DOING SPRING TRAINING AND NOW WE
ARE JUST TRYING TO DO IT HERE IN
THIS SEASON, TOO.
SCOTT: BOGAERTS ON FIRST AFTER
THE INFIELD SINGLE, AND NOW
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ WATCHES A
PITCH SALE OUTSIDE.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF NATE
EOVALDI AND HIS OPENING-DAY
PERFORMANCE?
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN FROM HIM SO
FAR TODAY?
MARTÍN: I THINK HE IS ATTACKING
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
YOU KNOW, HE GOT A GREAT STUFF,
MAN.
HE CAN USE ALL HIS PITCHES.
I THINK NOW HE IS MORE UNDER
CONTROL AND HE THROWS MORE FIRST
STRIKES.
THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US.
I THINK FIRST PITCH IS THE KEY.
WHEN YOU GO OUT THERE, YOU HAVE
TO THROW STRIKES QUICK.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TOO MUCH
TO ATTACK THE HITTERS.
ONE THING WE ALWAYS LIKE TO DO
IS JUST THROW A LOT OF STRIKES
TO THE HITTERS AND DON'T GIVE
TOO MUCH CREDIT TO THEM BECAUSE
THEY GET COMFORTABLE.
SCOTT: HERE IS ANOTHER LOOK AT
THE RAYS.
INFIELDERS CHOICE GOING THE
SHORT WAY TO SECOND BUT NOT IN
TIME TO FIRST, SO VAZQUEZ
REPLACES BOGAERTS AT FIRST.
TALKING TO MARTÍN PÉREZ DURING
THIS HOME HALF OF THE SECOND,
SCORELESS BETWEEN THE RAYS AND
RED SOX, LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
HUNTER RENFROE WILL DIG IN.
ALSO, FOR OUR CREATORS HANGING
OUT WITH THIS IN THE CHAT ROOM,
GIVE US A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
MARTÍN PÉREZ, AND WE WILL ASK
HIM LIVE DURING THIS INNING.
I HAVE ANOTHER FOR YOU AFTER
THIS, FIRST PITCH FROM
YARBOROUGH TO RENFRO, STRIKE
ONE.
GIVE ME MORE ON YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CUTTER,
AND I BELIEVE WHEN WE SPOKE A
FEW YEARS BACK, YOU PICKED UP
SOME OF THE TRICKS OF THE TRADE
FROM JAKE ODORIZZI?
MARTÍN: YES, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THAT WAS IN 2019.
MY FIRST WEEK, NO, I THINK IT
WAS THE LAST WEEK OF SPRING
TRAINING.
HE ALWAYS TOLD ME, I THINK YOU
HAVE TO TRY TO THROW OUT A
CUTTER.
I WOULD ALWAYS SAY NO BECAUSE I
HAD A GREAT CHANGEUP, AND I HAVE
A FOUR SEAM AND TWO SEAM.
AT THAT TIME, I GAVE UP A LOT OF
GROUND BALLS, BUT THAT YEAR I
SAY, OK, THIS IS A NEW YEAR AND
NEW TEAM AND IT IS NEVER TOO
LATE TO TRY THINGS AND PUT THEM
IN A GAME, AND HE TOLD ME, HEY,
THIS IS HOW YOU ARE GOING TO
THROW YOUR CUTTER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO MUCH WITH
THEIR HANDS.
THROW IT LIKE A CUT FASTBALL AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I REMEMBER I THROUGH EIGHT
CUTTERS IN A ROW, AND I FELT
GOOD AND STRONG WITH MY HANDS,
AND BY THE TIME I THREW THE
BALL, I SAID I GOT IT.
THEY ASKED ME, ARE YOU GOING TO
THROW IT AGAIN?
I SAID, YES, WHY NOT?
IT IS TIME TO COMPETE AND I FEEL
GOOD WITH THIS PITCH.
I'M GOING TO TRY IT.
AFTER THAT, I WAS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT PITCHER BECAUSE I HAD
A GREAT CHANGEUP AND THAT CUTTER
HELPED ME A LOT, TOO, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU ARE BEHIND IN THE
COUNT.
SCOTT: MARTÍN, IT IS WORKING FOR
YOU.
I'M SO YOU GIVE JAKE A TEXT
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE SAINT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
HAPPENING.
HE IS PROBABLY WATCHING, TOO,
GETTING READY FOR TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US, MARTÍN.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY,
OK?
MARTÍN: THANK YOU.
HAVE A GOOD DAY GUYS.
THE RAYS TURN TWO IN THE
BOOKS, NO SCORE FROM FENWAY.
>> GOES THE OTHER WAY FOR A BASE
HIT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
HERNANDEZ QUICKLY ABOARD.
>> SO NICELY DONE.
HE STAYED BACK, STAYED BACK, AND
WITH TWO STRIKES, YOU ARE GOING
TO LOVE THIS SWING.
>> J.D. MARTINEZ LANE INTO ONE,
HIGH DEEP DRIVE INTO LEFT CENTER
THAT BALL IS GONE!
RED SOX AT THEIR FIRST HOME RUN
OF 2021.
J.D. MARTINEZ WILL TOUCH THE
BALL.
>> 3-1 INTO RIGHT FIELD, RACING
BACK, THERESE RENNA.
CAN'T GET IT -- RACING BACK,
AROZARENA.CAN'T
GET IT.
J.D. MARTINEZ TRIES TO SCORE AND
THEY WILL NOT GET THEM.
DOWN THE LINE.
XANDER IS UP AND HE WILL SCORE!
>> 2-2 COMING.
FLY BALL, WELL STRUCK CENTER
FIELD.
WE WILL SEE THAT OFF THE BOTTOM
OF THE WALL.
RED SOX LOOKING TO ADD ON.
HERE IS THE THROW THE MOMENT.
GONZALEZ FLIES IN.
AFTER THAT ONE OFF THE OUTSIDE
CORNER DOWN THE LINE, THAT WHEN
SAILING AND IS GONE!
INTO THE PESKY POLE!
A THREE-RUN HOMER FOR J.D.
MARTINEZ!
SCOTT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK FOR THE 2021 SEASON IS
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
WHERE FRIENDS WATCHING ON
COMPUTER DEVICES CAN VOTE FOR
WHICH PLAYER WILL RECEIVE A
TROPHY DURING THE POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS LATER IN
THE SHOW.
GREAT WAY.
WE ARE BEING SENT GREAT
QUESTIONS FROM TEAM PÉREZ, BUT
THEN THE RAYS TURN TWO AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN WE ARE OFF TO THE
TOP OF THE THIRD WITH MANNY
MARGOT LEADING OFF.
7, 8, 9 COMING UP FOR TAMPA.
HERE COMES BOGAERTS BAREHANDED
FOR THE OUT.
JOHN: WHAT A PLAY RIGHT THERE.
CARLOS: XANDER BOGAERTS SHOWING
WHAT HE IS CAPABLE OF DOING.
HE DID NOT WASTE ANY TIME AND
CHARGING THE BASEBALL.
AS SOON AS YOU SAW IT, HE WENT
AFTER IT, AND HE HAS TO HURRY,
HE BAREHANDED VERY CLEANLY WITH
A VERY ATHLETIC MOVE, WE SHOULD
NEVER TAKE THIS FOR GRANTED.
THAT IS A LOT HARDER THAN IT
LOOKS.
SCOTT: AGAIN, MAKING JOHN SMOLTZ
LOOK GOOD AS HE SELECTED
BOGAERTS FOR WHICH PLAYER WOULD
HAVE THE BIGGEST IMPACT IN THE
GAME TODAY.
THAT MIGHT BE YOUR PICK IF YOU
KEEP THIS -- IF HE KEEPS THIS
UP, JOHN.
JOHN: TELL YOU WHAT, HE HAS HAD
AN IMPACT EVER SINCE HE CAME TO
THE ORGANIZATION.
HE HANDLED HIMSELF WAY BEYOND
HIS YEARS AS A YOUNG SHORTSTOP
AND CONTINUALLY IMPROVING.
HE HAS A CHANCE TO BE IN THIS
ORGANIZATION THE LONGEST AND THE
FACE OF THE ORGANIZATION FOR A
LONG TIME.
SCOTT: FRANCISCO MEJIA SENDS ONE
DOWN THE LEFT SIDE, AND HE TURNS
THAT INTO EXTRA BASES.
J.D. MARTINEZ CORRALS IT IN THE
CORNER.
A ONE-OUT DOUBLE FOR THE CATCHER
THIS AFTERNOON.
D.H. YESTERDAY, KNOWN FOR HIS
HITTING PROWESS IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES AND EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE, YOU GET ONE OF THESE,
CARLOS.
CARLOS: HE HAS A VERY HIGH
PROBABILITY SWING, IT IS A LEVEL
HACK THROUGH THE ZONE.
WHEN HE CATCHES THE BALL DEEP
INTO THE STRIKE ZONE, HE IS ABLE
TO HIT LOW GROUND BALLS DOWN THE
OTHER WAY OR LINE DRIVES.
THAT'S GOOD HITTING, A PRODUCT
OF A NICE LEVEL SWING.
SCOTT: CATCHING HIS DOUBLES
TOTAL FROM LAST YEAR.
THAT IS TOWARDS THE LEFT SIDE.
DEVERS TAKING HIS TIME.
HIGH THROW, BROUGHT DOWN BY THE
TALL BOBBY DALBEC AT FIRST.
TWO GONE.
JOHN: WE DID NOT GET A CHANCE TO
TALK ABOUT ADONIS, BUT HE IS ONE
OF THE GUYS I'M LOOKING FOR TO
SEE HOW HE REBOUNDS AFTER LAST
YEAR.
HE STRUGGLED AT THE PLATE.
HE IS A HIGH ENERGY TYPE GUY AND
MEANS SO MUCH TO THE BALLCLUB.
I THINK GETTING OFF TO A GOOD
START AND KIND OF RACING THE
LAST MEMORY HE HAD WHEN HE
FINISHED THE SEASON.
SCOTT: ALEX CORA SAID DEVERS
SHOWED UP AFTER THE PANDEMIC
SHUTDOWN NOT IN THE BEST SHAPE.
IT SHOWED EARLY ON AND STARTED
TO PICK UP IN THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER.
SOME OF HIS STATCAST NUMBERS
WERE AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH AT THE
END OF THE SHORTENED SEASON.
EXIT VELOCITY, HARD-HIT
PERCENTAGE, ALL OF THE TALENT IN
THE WORLD, AND WORLD SERIES RING
ALREADY.
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE LINEUP
AND YOSHI TSUTSUGO.
I PROMISE THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE
PICKS, NOT JUST FROM YOU, JOHN,
BUT CARLOS AND ALANNA.
CARLOS, PLAYER WITH THE BIGGEST
IMPACT TODAY OUT OF JD, RANDY,
AND AUSTIN?
CARLOS: I'M GOING TO GO WITH
J.D. MARTINEZ.
HE HAD TWO VERY GOOD SWINGS.
SEEMS LIKE HE IS SEEING THE
BASEBALL WILL OFF OF YARBOROUGH.
SCOTT: J.D. WITH A WALKOFF IN
THE 12TH INNING FOR THE RED SOX
YESTERDAY.
TSUTSUGO GROUNDED OUT IN THE TOP
OF THE FIRST.
JOHN: TOP OF THE ZONE FASTBALL
RIGHT HERE, MIDDLE TO MIDDLE IN.
I DON'T BELIEVE TSUTSUGO WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BARREL THAT
PITCH UP.
2-2 AFTER SEEING A BREAKING
BALL.
SCOTT: EOVALDI HAS FLASHED ALL
FIVE PITCHES TODAY ALREADY.
OFF THE END OF THE BAT.
BROKEN BAT.
IT FALLS IN FRONT OF HERNANDEZ.
HERE COMES MEJIA.
HE IS IN THERE.
TSUTSUGO DRIVES IN THE FIRST RUN
OF THE DAY FOR TAMPA BAY.
1-0.
JOHN: WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE FINAL RESULT, BUT I DID
NOT LIKE THAT PITCH ON OFF-SPEED
SPLIT AFTER A GUY STRUGGLING
WITH FASTBALL VELOCITY, AND HE
GAVE THEM A CHANCE TO BATTLE THE
BALL.
WHEN YOU SEE THE SPLITTER, IT
STAYS IN THE STRIKE ZONE,
DOESN'T TUMBLE AND STAYS AT THE
END OF THE BAT.
THAT IS WHEN YOU GO BACK AND YOU
SAY, I KNOW IF I EXECUTE, IT IS
STILL IN OUTS, BUT I LIKE MY
CHANCES BETTER WITH VELOCITY
OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE ZONE.
SCOTT: YOU CANNOT GET MUCH
BETTER ON THAT THROW, TOO.
CARLOS: I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
100%, SMOLTZ.
LOW, FOLLOWED BY ANOTHER
OFF-SPEED, TO GET INTO THE
CADENCE OF THE TIMING AND
TSUTSUGO WAS ABLE TO PUT THE
BARREL ON THAT BASEBALL, DRIVE
IT IN AND RUN.
SCOTT: HERE COMES AUSTIN MEADOWS
, WHO POPPED OUT IN FOUL GROUND
IN THE FIRST.
DID THAT JUST MISSED?
JOHN: NO.
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
I'M SITTING NEXT TO A PITCHER.
LET'S BRING IN ALANNA.
ALANNA: WE KNOW THAT EOVALDI
NEVER HAS TO WORRY ABOUT THE
VELOCITY.
IT IS ALWAYS THERE BUT IT SEEMS
HE IS USING HIS CUTTER MORE IN
THE SECOND OUTING GETTING WEAK
CONTACT.
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW, GUYS, FROM
A PITCHER AND HITTERS
PERSPECTIVE, WE CAN TALK ABOUT
IT NEXT INNING, DO YOU HAVE TO
PICK ONE OR THE OTHER?
YOU CAN'T DO BOTH AS FAR AS
TIMING IS CONCERNED.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS.
SCOTT: WE WILL BRING THAT
QUESTION WHEN WE RETURN FOR THE
EOVALDI SHAKING HIS HEAD BECAUSE
HE GAVE UP A RUN.
ALSO RECEIVED SOME HELP.
>> HE LOVES THE GAME.
>> WHAT A CAREER.
>> HALL OF FAMER.
>> AND HE IS FROM HERE.
THAT'S WHY THEY RETIRED THE
NUMBER, NOT BECAUSE HE PLAYED
THAT LONG BUT HE'S A LOCAL GUY.
>> HITTING IT DEEP TO RIGHT
FIELD AND IT IS GONE!
THE FIRST DEVIL RAYS HOME RUN,
WADE BOGGS TAKES THE GRAND TOUR,
AND HE NEEDS 199 HITS FOR 3000!
>> HERE COMES WADE BOGGS THROUGH
A STANDING OVATION AT TROPICANA
FIELD.
NEEDING ONE MORE HIT TO GET TO
3000.
AND THERE IS THE DRIVE TO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT IS GONE!
THE HIT THAT MAKES HISTORY IS A
TWO RUN HOME RUN!
3000 BASE HITS FOR WADE BOGGS,
AND HE HITS A HOME RUN TO DO IT!
SCOTT: 1-0 TAMPA BAY.
LET'S BRING IN THE RESULTS OF
OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION.
BIGGEST IMPACT IN THIS GAME AND
THE CROWD VOTES J.D., 38% OF
THIS YEAR.
SAME WITH CARLOS' PICK.
JOHN SMOLTZY'S PICK GOES INTO
NUMBER TWO, BOGAERTS.
RED SOX FANS WAITING IN HARD
THIS AFTERNOON.
J.D. THE MAN YESTERDAY WITH A
WALKOFF HIT IN THE 12TH.
THAT IS A FAMILIAR SIGHT, TOO.
OUTFIELDERS CHECKING OUT CARDS,
SEEING WHERE THEY SHOULD STAND.
CARLOS, WE SEE A LOT OF THAT
NOWADAYS AS CHRISTIAN ARROYO
GETS READY FOR THE RED SOX HALF
OF THE THIRD.
CARLOS: WE HAVE SEEN THAT EVEN
WITH PITCHERS.
PITCHERS TAKING LITTLE CARDS OUT
OF THEIR BACK POCKET AND
CHECKING FOR SIGNS OR A SCOUTING
REPORT THAT COULD HELP A PITCHER
SEQUENCE BETTER AND STRATEGIZE.
THIS IS HOW FAR WE HAVE COME IN
THIS GAME.
I THINK IT IS EFFICIENT AND
GREAT IF IT ALLOWS YOU TO WIN
BALL GAMES, WHY NOT?
SCOTT: CHRISTIAN ARROYO SWINGS
THROUGH THE OFFSPEED STUFF FROM
RYAN YARBROUGH.
STILL ON A ROLL TODAY FOR TAMPA
BAY.
HASN'T GIVEN UP A RUN IN A LONG
TIME.
NOT THIS SEASON, AND GOING BACK
TO LAST SEASON.
UP TO 17 CONSECUTIVE SCORELESS
INNINGS, DATING BACK TO 2020.
LET'S BRING ALANA BACK.
THE INNING RUDELY INTERRUPTED
THE FINISHED TO YOUR REPORT.
ALANNA: HATE IT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS, SCOTT.
MY QUESTION FOR THE GUYS WAS WE
KNOW EOVALDI THROWS A BILLION
AND HE IS USING THE CUTTER A
LOT, LOTS OF POOR CONTACT SO
FAR.
THE RAYS' HITTERS NEED TO PICK
ONE PITCH.
TIMING WISE YOU CAN'T COVER
BOTH.
YOU EITHER HAVE TO BE ON THE
FASTBALL OR CUTTER, SO FROM A
HITTERS PERSPECTIVE, DO YOU HAVE
TO PICK ONE AND GO WITH IT?
PITCHER AND FROM APITCHER'S
PERSPECTIVE, -- AND FROM A
PITCHER'S PERSPECTIVE, HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT TO MAKE THEM
GUESS?
CARLOS: I WILL GO FIRST, ALANNA,
WHEN WE TRY TO GET THEM TO HIT,
TO COVER BOTH SPEEDS, IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
IF THE PITCHES LOOK EXACTLY THE
SAME BUT HAVE DIFFERENT TIMINGS,
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SINK A FASTBALL
HARD, YOU STAY WITH IT, YOU STAY
WITH THE CADENCE AND TIMING AND
HIT IT EARLY ENOUGH TO GET TO IT
AND HOPEFULLY YOU TAKE THE
OFFSPEED.
IF YOU SING ONE BECAUSE YOU GOT
FOOLED, YOU SWING THROUGH IT AND
DON'T MODIFY YOUR SWING.
THAT TAKES A LOT OF DISCIPLINE
AND EASIER SAID THAN DONE, BUT
THAT IS THE ONLY WAY TO ASSURE
YOU WILL HAVE GOOD HACKS AT THE
BASEBALL.
YOU HAVE TO PICK ONE OR THE
OTHER.
JOHN: I WOULD SAY FROM A PITCHER
'S STANDPOINT, TODAY'S
PHILOSOPHY IS DIFFERENT.
IF A LOT OF HITTERS HAVE A
ONE-WEEK SWING, YOU HAVE TO HIT
THAT BAT IN THE AREA.
IF YOU CAN'T PUT PRESSURE ON A
HITTER CHANGING LANES AND
DIRECTIONS AWAY FROM EIGHT
RIGHT-HANDED AND LEFT-HANDED
HITTER, THAT AREA BECOMES THE
FOCUS FOR THE SWING PATH TO STAY
THE SAME.
IF THE HITTER DOESN'T BREAK AND
YOU ARE THINKING FASTBALL AND IT
DOESN'T BREAK AND IT IS IN THE
AREA OF A SWING PATH, THERE
ISN'T A DIFFERENCE TO THE
HITTER.
THAT IS WHY I THINK PITCHING
STILL HAS TO CREATE STRESS ON
THE HITTERS BY NOT ONLY HAVING
YOUR BEST STUFF BUT THE ABILITY
TO CHANGE EYE LEVELS AND THE
FOCUS OF YOU JUST CANNOT SWING
ONE WAY AGAINST ME.
I THINK A LOT OF HITTERS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
VELOCITY BASED ON THAT BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T A DIFFERENT
APPROACH, AND IF A HITTER OR
PITCHER DOESN'T MAKE THEM CHANGE
OR ARE UNWILLING, A PITCHER WILL
HAVE SUCCESS, SO EOVALDI AND MY
OPINION WHEN HE PITCHES OFF HIS
FASTBALL, HAS TO REMEMBER WHERE
THAT LAST FAST ALL WAS, EITHER
TAKEN OR SWUNG, AND THEN PITCH
EFFECTIVELY OFF OF THAT.
SCOTT: BROKEN BAT, ARROYO INTO
THE GLOVE OF LOWE.
JOHN: THE REASON HE HAS BEEN HIT
TOO HARD FOR A GUY WHO THROWS
99, HE DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF
MOVEMENT ON HIS PITCH, AND THAT
IS WHY HE THROWS THE CUTTER TO
CREATE MOVEMENT AND GET IT OFF
THE BARREL.
THAT IS WHY IT GOES OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THE LEFT-HANDED HITTER
SHOULD SEE.
WHEN THE MIRROR EACH OTHER AND
THE VELOCITY CHANGE OF SPEEDS
ISN'T THAT GREAT, THE HITTER --
I GUESS INTIMIDATES OR ALTERS
ANYTHING HE IS DOING.
YOU CAN LITERALLY GO UP THERE
AND SWING FROM YOUR HEELS AND
FIND ONE OF THOSE PITCHES IN THE
ZONE YOU LIKE AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF HIS POWER.
SCOTT: BOBBY DALBEC KNOWN FOR
HIS POWER BUT DROPS ONE INTO
CENTER FIELD.
SINGLE TO START THINGS OFF IN
THE THIRD FOR BOSTON.
CARLOS: I COULD TALK HITTING ALL
DAY, SMOLTZY.
YOU BRING A GREAT POINT FORWARD.
RIGHT HERE, DALBEC GETS THAT
FASTBALL LIKE A CUTTER TYPE
INSIDE, AND HE IS ABLE TO GET TO
IT.
YARBOROUGH WILL USE THAT PITCH
TO CROWD HITTERS, BUT DALBEC WAS
READY EARLY ENOUGH TO MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFERENTIAL, THE SPEED
DIFFERENTIAL, ISN'T THAT GREAT
FROM THE FASTBALL UP.
WHEN YOU START WITH YOU FASTBALL
UP, YOU PROBABLY WILL BE ON TIME
FOR THAT CUTTER.
SPEED DIFFERENTIAL IS A HUGE
DEAL IF YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
SUCCESS AS A PITCHER.
SCOTT: THAT IS IN THERE TO KEVIN
NUMBER NINE HITTER -- THAT IS IN
THERE TO KEVIN PLAWECKI, NUMBER
NINE HITTER.
JOHN: THE SIMPLE RULE I ADOPTED
BASED ON THE HITTER I FACED, IF
HE SWUNG AT A FASTBALL AND DID
NOT PUT IT INTO PLAY, I FOLLOWED
WITH A CURVEBALL BECAUSE THE
PLANE OF HIS EYES, WHAT HE LAST
SAW IS WHAT HE REMEMBERS BUT IF
I THREW A LOW FASTBALL AND HE
SWUNG HER FAULT OFF -- SWUNG OR
FOULED OFF, I WOULD FOLLOW AT
THE SLIDER BECAUSE THE PLANES
ARE THE SAME.
IF YOU GET TO CREATIVE AND
THROUGH A HIGH FASTBALL FOLLOWED
BY A LOW SLIDER, THAT VARIANCE
OF THE HITTER IS TOO BIG.
ANYONE WHO SWINGS AT THAT IS A
FREE SWINGER.
SAME WITH THE LEFT-HANDER.
IF I GOT AN OUTSIDE FASTBALL
THAT HE TOOK FOR A STRIKE, THEN
I FOLLOWED WITH A SPLIT GOING
AWAY.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CREATE AN
AWARENESS TO THE HITTER THAT
THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF FEAR OF
WHAT THE GUY ON THE MOUND HAS.
IT IS HARD TO ELIMINATE THINGS
IN THIS GAME IF YOU HAVE A JACOB
DEGROM.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY THE BEST, SOME
OF THE BEST WE HAVE, BUT I THINK
THE INFORMATION SOMETIMES AND
THIS IS WHAT I HAVE BEEN WANTING
TO TALK YEARS ABOUT, THE
INFORMATION OF A PITCHER AND
SCOTT BRAUN IS A HITTER, I THINK
TOO MANY PITCHERS PITCHED TO
YOUR WEAKNESS VERSUS THE PITCHER
'S STRENGTH, MEANING MY STRENGTH
IS WHAT IT IS.
IT HAS TO BE GLARING IF A HITTER
CANNOT HIT A CURVEBALL, FOR
EXAMPLE.
WHAT I THINK YARBOROUGH AND EVEN
EOVALDI DO, THEY GET TO PITCH
OFF THEIR STRENGTHS.
YARBOROUGH HAS SO MANY MORE
MOVEMENT PITCHES.
THAT IS WHY HE DOESN'T NEED THE
VELOCITY THAT EOVALDI HAS
BECAUSE EOVALDI'S MOVEMENT IS
NOT AS GOOD AS YARBOROUGH.
OF COURSE, I ALWAYS SEE IF YOU
ARE LEFT-HANDED, AND YOU BREATHE
A MENU THROW STRIKES, YOU ARE IN
THE BIG LEAGUES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SUCH AN ADVANTAGE THAT
HITTERS DON'T SEE ALL THE TIME.
SCOTT: STATCAST 3D POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD GIVING US A NICE
LOOK AT THE REPERTOIRE FROM
YARBOROUGH.
THIS IS WHAT HE CUES UP, WEAK
CONTACT AND LAZY FLY BALL FOR
BRANDON LOWE TO HEAD OUT AND
HAUL IN.
CARLOS: THAT IS ALL IT TAKES.
IF YOU ARE ABLE TO GET SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TIMING RIGHT THERE,
THAT IS WHEN IT IS SLIGHTLY
EARLY, JUST GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE
HITTER TO HIT THAT OFF THE END
OF THE BAT WITH NO DAMAGE DONE.
IF YOU TRY TO SIT BACK A LITTLE
BIT AND YOU ARE LIKE, I HAVE TO
SIT BACK AND WAIT, HE COMES WITH
THAT CUTTER AND YOU ARE LATE
HITTING THE BALL OFF THE HANDLE.
THAT IS THE ART OF PITCHING.
THIS IS WHAT SMOLTZY WAS
EXPLAINING WITH THROWING THE
FASTBALL AWAY AND FOLLOWING IT
UP WITH A SPLIT OFF OF THE SAME
LINE OR THE HIGH FASTBALL.
THEN THE CURVEBALL.
THAT IS THE SIMPLEST WAY OF
EXPLAINING.
EVERYONE AT HOME, YOU JUST GOT A
LESSON IN PITCHING FROM JOHN
SMOLTZY.
THAT ALONE WILL TAKE YOU A LONG
WAY TO BECOME A DECENT PITCHER
ON THE MOUND.
SCOTT: AND THE GOOD NEWS IS THIS
IS ON YOUTUBE, YOU CAN SCROLL
BACK EASILY AND WATCH IT BACK AT
ANY TIME.
IT IS EVERY GAME.
JOHN: TAKE NOTES.
SCOTT: IF YOU FORGET, IT IS IN
FRONT OF YOU.
EASY REWIND.
DALBEC OFF OF FIRST AND KIKÉ
HERNANDEZ EVENS THE COUNT.
CARLOS: SMOLTZY, OR I WANTED TO
ASK, WHEN YOU ARE ON THE MOUND,
I HAVE HEARD YOU MENTION A
COUPLE OF TIMES, I HAVE SEEN
THAT IF THE HITTER SWINGS AT
THAT PITCH OR TAKES IT, OR WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING IS YOU ARE
READING THE HITTER, CORRECT?
JOHN: THE BEST YOU CAN TRY TO
DO, A LOT OF GUYS, YOU CAN ASK
DOESN'T ALLOW THEM TO TAKE THEIR
HEAD AWAY FROM THE REACTION OF
THE HITTER, SO YOU RELY ON THE
CATCHER AND INFORMATION.
I LEARNED SO MUCH FROM GREG
MADDUX WHERE HE WOULD BE ABLE TO
READ THE SWING SO MUCH BETTER
AND HE GAVE HIM A MENU OF
OPTIONS AND YOU KNEW WHY HE WAS
SO GOOD AT OUTGASSING THE
HITTER, RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY HITTERS
TODAY, BACK IN OUR ERA, MORE
HITTERS TEST AND WERE GUESS
HITTERS TO CREATE AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY DO THAT NOW.
THEY KIND OF SWING, THEIR SWING
IS WHAT THEIR SWING IS, SO
ENDGAME -- IN GAME ADJUSTMENTS
ARE HUGE FOR GUYS WHO DO THAT.
SOME GUYS NEED TO WATCH HER
START OR -- WATCH THEY ARE START
OR THE VIDEO, SO YOU RELY ON
YOUR CATCHER FOR INFORMATION.
IF YOU MOVED IN THE BOX FROM ONE
BAT TO ANOTHER AND I DID NOT
NOTICE THAT, I AM IN TROUBLE.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT THAT CALL?
JOHN: THAT'S CLOSE.
THAT IS THE KIND OF PRESSURE YOU
WANT TO PUT ON THE HITTER.
I WOULD COME BACK AND SEE BY
COULD FADE IT LITTLE MORE AND
MAKE THAT HITTER THINK HE CANNOT
TAKE THAT PITCH.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN LANDING THAT
CUTTER WHERE HE WANTS IT.
JOHN: HE WENT RIGHT BACK TO IT.
SCOTT: SAME SPOT.
RYAN YARBROUGH BRINGING IT THIS
AFTERNOON FOR TAMPA RUN.
THREE AND THE BOOKS FROM FENWAY.
-- THREE IN THE BOOKS FROM
FENWAY.
.
>> MY GOAL IS TO HAVE MY BEST
YEAR YET.
YOU KNOW?
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH IT, TO HAVE
MY BEST YEAR I HAVE EVER HAD.
GOT HIM!
DO YOU, YOU HAVE A CANNON.
YOU HAVE A CANNON, DOG.
HE LOVES IT.
>> 1, 2, 3.
>> OUTFIELD.
>> BEST TIME OF THE DAY.
♪
>> YES.
SCOTT: THE RAYS POUNCED FIRST
AND SCORE A RUN IN THE THIRD.
DUE UP IN THE FOURTH, AROZARENA,
LOWE AND DIAZ.
WHO WILL WIN AL ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR?
HARD TO BELIEVE, BUT AROZARENA
DID NOT QUALIFY AS A ROOKIE LAST
YEAR BECAUSE HE DID NOT PLAY
ENOUGH GAMES.
HE IS ON THE LIST AND SO WAS
WANDER FRANCO.
AND WE ROUND OUT OUR FOUR WITH
MOUNTCASTLE.
LET'S FOCUS OUR FIDELITY PLAYER
SPOTLIGHT ON THE TOP PROSPECT IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL TRADE THE
RAYS MAKE IT TO THE WORLD SERIES
ON THE RICH GET RICHER IN TERMS
OF TALENT.
THIS MAN IS COMING SOON TO A
BALLPARK NEAR YOU.
JOHN: I KNOW A LOT OF THEM WISH
IT WAS SOONER.
I UNDERSTAND.
BOTH SIDES OF IT.
SCOTT: PATIENTS.
AND -- PATIENCE.
JOHN: PATIENCE?
I HAD NONE OF THAT EARLY IN MY
CAREER.
CARLOS: [LAUGHTER]
JOHN: PRACTICE?
SCOTT: MINOR LEAGUES?
FORGET THAT.
THAT IS FOR DEVERS.
ONE AWAY.
HERE'S THE LAST AT-BAT FROM
BRANDON LOWE AS HE GETS READY TO
FACE NATE EOVALDI AGAIN.
HOW DID IT GO LAST TIME?
WELL, HE STRUCK OUT LOOKING.
EOVALDI WAS JUST THROWING THE
ENTIRE MENU AT HIM, CARLOS.
CARLOS: YES, USING A COMBINATION
OF THE UP FASTBALL IN THE ZONE,
PAIRED UP WITH A CUTTER AND THEN
SLOWER CURVEBALL AND RANDY LOWE
IS IN BETWEEN.
LIKE ALANNA WAS SAYING, YOU HAVE
TO PICK ONE OR YOU WILL BE IN
TROUBLE.
SCOTT: HE THREW ALL OF HIS
PITCHES AND THAT AT BAT.
JOHN: HE DID NOT EXACTLY WHAT HE
WANTED TO.
HE GOT AWAY WITH A COUPLE.
YOU GO ON YOUR FIELD, AND IT
LOOKS LIKE HE IS A LITTLE
ERRATIC, MEANING EOVALDI, ON HIS
FASTBALL COMMAND.
FASTBALL COMMAND, TO ME, WILL
SET UP HIS OTHER PITCHES AND
TAKE THE PRESSURE OFF OF IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE CLASSIC GET THE
BALL DOWN, YOU HAVE TO GET AHEAD
TO GET THE BALL DOWN TO GET THIS
GUY OUT BECAUSE IF YOU GET
BEHIND AND THE UP, HE CRUSHES.
-- AND THE BALL UP, HE CRUSHES.
TO ME, PITCHING, I USED TO
ALWAYS WANT TO KNOW SIMPLE
THINGS, IS THE GUY AGGRESSIVE?
DOES HE WANT TO HIT THE FIRST
PITCH?
DOES HE WANT TO TAKE A WALK
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
TAKE A WALK AGAINST ME, YOU ARE
OUT.
BUT IF YOU MAKE ME PITCH OR LIKE
THIS CLASSIC AT BAT WHERE HE DID
NOT GO UP JUMPY AND MADE EOVALDI
PITCH, THESE ARE THE GOOD THINGS
THE RAYS CAN DO WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THEIR WALKS AND HOMERS AND
STRIKEOUTS TYPE PHILOSOPHY.
SCOTT: FOURTH PITCH, FREE PASS.
CARLOS: IT ISN'T WHEN YOU GO OUT
THERE TAKING PITCHES.
AS A HITTER, WE ARE WAITING FOR
A PITCH WE WANT TO HIT, BUT WE
HAVE TO BE AGGRESSIVE IN THE
ZONE WHERE WE WANTED.
THAT WOULD ALLOW -- WHERE WE
WANT IT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO TAKE MORE
BALLS AND GET WALKS.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
IF YOU HIT, YOU WALK MORE.THE
MORE AGGRESSIVE YOU ARE IN YOUR
ZONE, YOU WILL END UP WALKING
MORE BECAUSE YOU ARE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST A HITTER.
SCOTT: THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT LOWE
DID THREE OF THE PAST SIX RAYS
HITTERS HAVE REACHED BASE.
THAT MISSES LOW TO YANDY DIAZ.
JOHN: IT IS FUNNY WHAT YOU LEARN
IN THIS GAME IF YOU PLAY LONG
ENOUGH.
I WILL NEVER FORGET ONE OF MY
GUYS I PITCHED AGAINST CAME TO
ME AFTER AN OUTING AND SAID I
WILL NEVER SWING AT YOUR SLIDER
AGAIN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE HIM.
HE WAS A RIGHT-HANDED HITTER AND
I THOUGHT, THERE'S NO WAY YOU
CAN LAY OFF OF THE SLIDER.
HE NEVER SWUNG AT MY SLIDER
AGAIN.
WHAT IT INDIRECTLY TAUGHT ME WAS
I DID NOT WANT TO THROW MY
SLIDER FOR A STRIKE.
I WANTED IT TO LOOK LIKE ONE AND
END UP AS A BALL.
HE TAUGHT ME INDIRECTLY HOW TO
LEARN TO THROW MY SLIDER FOR A
STRIKE ANYTIME I WANTED IN CASE
HITTERS STARTED TO HAVE THAT
APPROACH BECAUSE WHEN A GUY GOES
UP THERE AND SWINGS WILD AT IT,
LIKE THAT IS A GOOD TAKE BUT
THAT IS A GREAT PITCH.
AND SO BECAUSE THE COUNT ALLOWED
HIM TO TAKE THAT PITCH AND SPIT
ON IT, AS A HITTER WOULD SAY, IF
IT WAS THE  OPPOSITE COUNT,
LIKE1-2, HE CANNOT LAY OFF THAT
PITCH, SO THE COUNT AND A LOT OF
THINGS ABOUT PITCHING DETERMINE
WHETHER THE HITTER HAS STRESS OR
IS GOING TO BE AGGRESSIVE.
YOU SAW AROZARENA, THE FIRST
PITCH HE DETERMINED HE WAS GOING
TO SWING OUT OF THE HAND OF THE
PITCHER.IT WASN'T EVEN CLOSE.
IT LED THAT AT-BAT TO BE THREE
STRAIGHT BREAKING BALLS.
SCOTT: NOW EOVALDI HAS MISSED
SEVEN OF HIS LAST EIGHT HOUSES.
JOHN: YEAH, THAT IS WHAT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT, HE IS SLINGING
IT, BUT THE LOCATION, HE IS
MISSING TOO BIG IN SPOTS, AND IT
IS PUTTING HIM IN A DEFENSIVE
ACCOUNT.
I LOVE PEOPLE THAT USED TO GO,
3-1 FASTBALL , THROW IT
AGAIN,3-2.
IT IS NOT THAT EASY TO KEEP
THROWING EVERYTHING WHERE YOU
WANT IT.
SCOTT: DIAZ SWINGS THROUGH.
CARLOS: THAT WAS A GREAT
COMBINATION RIGHT THERE,
SMOLTZY.
IF YOU WATCH THE PITCH PRIOR TO
THAT, IT WAS UP AND INSIDE AND
DIAZ WAS LATE.
THEN HE THROWS HIS SLIDER OFF OF
EXACTLY THE SAME LINE AND DIAZ
IS AHEAD OF IT BECAUSE HE
REMEMBERED HE WAS LATE ON THE
FASTBALL OF THE PREVIOUS PITCH.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT, THAT FASTBALL COMMAND IS
KEY TO PITCHING.
RIGHT THERE, THOSE LAST TWO
OFFERINGS PRETTY MUCH IT IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHAT GOOD
TUNNELING IS ALL ABOUT.
SCOTT: 3 FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS ON
THREE SLIDERS IN THAT SEQUENCE
AGAINST YANDY DIAZ FOR A SECOND
STRIKEOUT OF THE DAY.
NOW JOEY WENDLE, FLEW OUT TO
CENTER BACK IN THE SECOND.
BRINGING SOME OF THOSE COMMENTS
FROM THE CREATORS, HANGING OUT
WITH US ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
JOLLY OLIVE SAYS, A
MILE-PER-HOUR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
EOVALDI'S FASTBALL AND
CURVEBALL, GROSS.
JOHN: FOR WENDLE, AND MOST OF
HIS STRIKEOUTS, NOT THE HIGHEST
STATISTIC I'VE SEEN IN A LONG
NON-FASTBALL STRIKEOUTS ARE OUT
OF THE ZONE.
HE IS CHASING ON FASTBALLS OUT
OF THE ZONE, AND BY --
NON-FASTBALLS OUT OF THE ZONE
AND BY A HIGH MARGIN OUT OF ALL
OF BASEBALL LAST YEAR.
THIS PITCH SHOULD BE NOWHERE
CLOSE TO THE STRIKE ZONE.
SCOTT: HE DOES HAVE SOME SUCCESS
AGAINST EOVALDI.
FIVE FOR EIGHT WITH A HOMER IN
THE PAST.
WOULD THAT MEAN ANYTHING TO YOU?
JOHN: OH, YEAH.
THAT'S NOT SMALL.
ANYTIME A NUMBER STARTS WITH A
SUCCESS AN AVERAGE, PRETTY GOOD
REPRESENTATION THAT HE SEES THE
BALL BETTER THAN WHAT THE
PITCHER IS HOPING HE WOULD DO,
SO YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING TO
CHANGE THE WAY HE SEES IT.
THERE IS THE PITCH RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: NOT EVEN CLOSE.
PLAWECKI CLEANS IT UP.
A PAIR OF PUNCH-OUTS FOR NATE
EOVALDI IN THE FOURTH.
IMPRESSIVE FINISH TO THE HALF
INNING.
WE WILL SEE IF THE RED SOX HAVE
THEIR FIRST ANSWER OF THE DAY IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE FOURTH COMING
UP.
♪
>> RANDY AROZARENA USED TO HAVE
DREAMS THAT LOOKED KIND OF LIKE
THIS.
IN THEN, HE WOULD BE THE MAN IN
THE MIDDLE OF EVERYTHING,
TREASURED BY HIS TEAMMATES.
AND LOVED BY HIS LITTLE GIRL.
RANDY: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> WHEN AROZARENA ARRIVED IN THE
STATES, HE SAID HE WASN'T
COMFORTABLE SHOWING HIS
PERSONALITY AND OFTEN FELT
ALONE.
RANDY: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> M.V.P.!
M.V.P.!
>> NOW HE IS NOT ONLY ONE OF THE
GUYS SPLIT HE IS THE GUY, LIVING
THE LIFE HE ONCE DREAMED OF.
RANDY: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SCOTT: IT IS 1-0 RAYS AFTER 3.5,
ADDING TO THE UNIQUE VIEWING
EXPERIENCE, DON'T FORGET TO
CHECK OUT YOUTUBE'S LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY, FEATURING THE RAYS,
RED SOX AND A SELECT GROUP OF
YOUTUBE CREATORS JOINING US.
VIEW THE LIVE GAME COMMENTARY ON
YOUR COMPUTER OR MOBILE DEVICE
OR ON YOUR SMART TV.
WE WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THE
DISCUSSION THROUGH THE
BROADCAST.
WE ARE FEATURING ONE SPECIAL
CREATOR FOR THIS AFTERNOON'S
GAME, A FRIEND OF MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
GIRAFFE NECK MARC.
AN ADDED FOCUS ON A SINGLE
YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR FEATURED
IN THE LIVE GAME COMMENTARY.
OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT SHINED ON
MARC LUINO, BETTER KNOWN AS
GIRAFFENECKMARC, FEATURING
OPINIONATED YET INFORMATIVE
VIDEOS OF ALL THINGS MLB TO
SEASON PREDICTIONS, STADIUMS AND
THE BEAUTY IS HE IS GREAT IN THE
CHAT WITH US.
ALWAYS CONTRIBUTING COMMENTS.
REMEMBER HIM LAST YEAR AND THE
YEAR BEFORE.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE, MARC,
I PRONOUNCED YOUR NAME RIGHT TO
BECAUSE WE'VE NEVER MET AND I'M
ALWAYS CALLING HIM
GIRAFFENECKMARC.
IN THE COMMENTS, LAY OUT YOUR
PRONUNCIATION FOR US, AND I WILL
MAKE SURE I WAS ACCURATE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
AND YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE GAME,
PLEASE, AS WELL, AS WE APPROACH
THE HALFWAY MARK PRETTY SOON
HERE WITH THE RAYS LEADING 1-0.
ANOTHER COMMENT ROLLING IN FROM
GAMINGTV, TUNNELING FOR THE WIN
IN STARK RAVING SPORTS AND
SEQUENCING REALLY GETTING INTO
IT THE LAST HAPPENING FOR NATE
EOVALDI.
AND THEN WE SEE A LOT OF THAT
EXCELLENCE FROM THE SOFT TOSSING
LEFTY, RYAN YARBROUGH.
SCORELESS BASEBALL SO FAR,
FACING DEVERS, MARTINEZ AND
BOGAERTS.
BIG NAMES FOR BOSTON.
JOHN: DEVERS WANTS TO GET RID OF
THE STREAK HE'S HAD AGAINST
LEFT-HANDERS.
HASN'T VERY GOOD HITTING THE
LAST 20 OR SO AT-BATS AGAINST
LEFT-HANDERS.
HE WILL GET GOING AND STAYS ON
THE BALL ABOUT AS WELL AS ANY
YOUNGSTER WHEN HE GOT IN THE
LEAGUE.
THE IMAGE OF HITTING CHAPMAN 102
FOR A HOMER.
SCOTT: GREAT MEMORY FROM HIS
ROOKIE SEASON.
HERE IS THE LONGEST ACTIVE
SCORELESS INNING STREAK IN
BASEBALL.
YARBOROUGH NUMBER TWO TO JOE
MUSGROVE.
NEW MEMBER OF THE PADRES.
YARBOROUGH' STREAK GOES BACK TO
SEPTEMBER 20.
DEVERS DOES NOT BITE.
HE CHASED ON A CURVE BALL LAST
TIME FOR STRIKE THREE.
JOHN: HERE'S WHAT I THINK NEEDS
TO CHANGE OVER TIME AND BASEBALL
WITH -- IN BASEBALL AND
PITCHING.
VELOCITY IS ALWAYS GOING TO GET
YOU TO THE BIG LEAGUES AND GIVE
YOU MORE CHANCES, BUT WHEN YOU
HAVE A GUY WHO KNOWS HOW TO
PITCH AND THE EFFECTIVENESS HE
HAS SHOWN IN BEING ABLE TO
DELIVER SOFT CONTACT, THERE IS A
SPOT IN EVERY TEAM FOR THAT KIND
OF GUY.
WE ARE JUST NOT LOOKING FOR IT
AS MUCH ANYMORE.
I HOPE THERE IS I GUESS A
REJUVENATION OF PITCHERS THAT
KNOW HOW TO PITCH BUT MAYBE
CANNOT LIGHT UP THE RADAR GUN AS
MUCH.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE A HIGH SCHOOL
RIGHT NOW AND THROWING IN THE
MID-80'S, YOU CAN GET TO 90 AND
LIVE IN THIS LEAGUE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO GET TO 95.
JOHN: I AGREE, BUT, AGAIN, THOSE
CHASES THAT ARE BEING MADE AND
THE REWARD SYSTEM IN THE GAME IS
FEEDING THE TYPE OF PITCHING WE
HAVE TODAY, THAT I BELIEVE IT
HAS A SHELF LIFE.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID IT HAS A SHELF
LIFE BECAUSE IT ISN'T
SUSTAINABLE, I CALL IT REDLINE
YOUR PICTURES EVERY TIME, SO IF
YOU GO IN A CAR AND THERE IS A
REASON THERE WAS A REDLINE FOR
YOUR ENGINE.
TRY TO STAY IN THAT REDLINE
FOR 1.5 HOURS AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS TO YOUR ENGINE.
PITCHERS ARE FINDING OUT
THAT IT IS HARDER EVERY TIME YOU
EMPTY THE TANK EVERY TIME YOU
PITCH.
CARLOS: AND IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY KEEP YOU SUCCEEDING.
YOU CAN THROW AS HARD AS YOU
WANT.
WE'VE SEEN IT MANY TIMES OVER
AND OVER IN THE BIG LEAGUES,
GUYS THAT THERE WHEN THE UPPER
90'S, AND THEY STILL GET HIT.
AND THEY DO NOT HAVE SUCCESS, SO
IT ISN'T ALL ABOUT SPEED.
IT IS ABOUT KNOWING HOW TO
PITCH.
SCOTT: EXCUSE ME, SWING FOR
MARTINEZ.
AFTER A BOBBLE AT FIRST,
TSUTSUGO CLEANS IT UP AND HANDS
IT OFF TO YARBOROUGH.
DEVERS MOVES ON TO SECOND.
JOHN: OH, THE OLD SPRING
TRAINING PITCHERS FUNDAMENTALS
PRAYED WERE A PITCHER HAS TO
BECOME A READY TO GO OVER THERE
IN CASE SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPENS.
THAT PLAY GETS PRACTICED, NOT
QUITE LIKE THAT, BUT THEY DID A
NICE JOB CLEANING IT UP AND
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF J.D. NOT
BEING A SPEEDSTER, NOT
PANICKING, AND GETTING OUT.
TOOK SO MUCH PRIDE IN MY
DEFENSE, WE FORGET PITCHERS ARE
STILL A DEFENDER AFTER THEY LET
GO OF THE BALL.
NOT A LOT OF THEM FINISH IN A
GOOD POSITION TO BE A DEFENDER
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY THROW A
BASEBALL, BUT I TELL YOU WHAT,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN HELP
YOU WIN 1, 2, MAYBE THREE
BASEBALL GAMES OUT OF
30-SOMETHING.
THAT IS A BIG DEAL WHEN YOU ARE
FIELDING YOUR POSITION AND
BECOMING THE NINTH DEFENDER, IF
YOU WILL, ON THE FIELD.
SCOTT: AND THAT WOULD MAKE
CARLOS PENA'S JOHN: OH YEAH --
CARLOS PENA'S JOB EASIER.
JOHN: OH YEAH.
CARLOS: TO MEDICATION AND
REPETITION.
THAT IS ALREADY GO TO P.F.P.',
NOT THES MOST FUN BUT THEY MUST
BE DONE.IT
IS A PRIORITY IN SPRING
TRAINING.
I THINK THEY SHOULD KEEP DOING
IT THROUGH THE SEASON.
IT IS NOT JUST LET'S DO IT IN
SPRING TRAINING AND BE DONE.
AT LEAST ONCE A WEEK, SMOLTZY,
IT OUT THERE AND DO A COUPLE OF
P.F.P.'S, IT WOULD NOT HURT A
BALLCLUB.
JOHN: IF I WAS PLAYING WITH
CARLOS, MY COMMUNICATION WOULD
BE LIKE THIS, IF I'M RUNNING TO
FIRST, THROWING THE BALL BECAUSE
I'M NOT READY FOR MY HEALTH.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE WOULD BE TOO MANY GUYS AT
FIRST BASE WITH PITCHERS RUNNING
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE AND HE
WAVED HIM OFF LIKE I'VE GOT IT.
SCOTT: CARLOS IS ONE OF THE
NICEST HUMANS ON THE PLANET, SO
YOU WOULD BE LIKE, SURE,
SMOLTZY, NO PROBLEM.
CARLOS: I WILL LET YOU PLAY, OF
COURSE.
I WILL NOT MAKE YOU COME ALL THE
WAY OVER HERE AND NOT GIVE YOU
THE BALL.
NO CHANCE!
SCOTT: YOU ARE A GOOD MAN,
CARLOS.
THIS IS XANDER BOGAERTS WITH
DEVERS ON SECOND.
JOHN: THIS IS A TEASE IN OUR
INDUSTRY.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE YOU A TEASE
FOR THE VIEWERS ON YOUTUBE IN A
LITTLE BIT, LATER, WHATEVER THAT
WORKS OUT TO, WE ARE GOING TO
SHOW YOU HOW WHEN YOU DO NOT
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR FIRST
BASEMAN HOW THINGS CAN GO BAD ON
A PLAY I WAS INVOLVED IN.
WE WILL GET THAT TO YOU SO THAT
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THE HOW'S AND
HOW NOT TO.
CARLOS: YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS
THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: STAY TUNED.
BOGAERTS GETS IT TO CENTER.
THAT FALLS IN FRONT OF MARGOT.
ROUNDING THIRD IS DEVERS.
AND HE IS GOING TO SCORE!
XANDER BOGAERTS EVENS THE GAME
AT ONE WITH THE R.B.I. KNOCK.
JOHN: HE IS TOO GOOD AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHERS RIGHT NOW.
HE IS TOO GOOD IN GENERAL.
HE IS ONE OF THOSE SIMPLE
APPROACH, DOESN'T MISS HIS
PITCH.
HE HAS REALLY HAD SUCCESS
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHING
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER,
AND THERE IS THAT CUTTER THAT
COMES IN, BUT HE STAYS INSIDE
THE BALL AND DOESN'T TRY TO DO
TOO MUCH.
THAT IS THE KEY.
IF YOU HAVE A GUY TRYING TO DO
TOO MUCH AND HIT THE BALL OVER
THE GREEN MONSTER, THAT IS AN
OUT.
CARLOS: GOOD POINT.
YOU SEE HOW HE JUST KEPT THAT
SWING LEVEL THROUGH THE ZONE.
HE DOES NOT RUSH THAT BASEBALL
PRAYED HE HITS IT A LITTLE BIT
ON THE LATE BECAUSE OF THE NICE,
LEVEL PATH AND IS ABLE TO STILL
HIT THAT SLOW LINE DRIVE BUT
STILL IN THE RIGHT TRAJECTORY
THAT GETS THE JOB DONE.
HOW GOOD IS THIS GUY?
SINCE 2015, HE'S BEEN ONE  OF
THE BEST SHORTSTOPSIN THE GAME.
SCOTT: SEVENTH HIT OF THE SERIES
FOR XANDER BOGAERTS.
JOHN: CARLOS, THIS IS THE GUY I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT.
FOR WHATEVER REASON THE LAST TWO
YEARS, POWER HAS CLICKED INTO
HIS GAME.
HE HAS GONE FROM OK, DECENT HOUR
TO WHAT -- DECENT POWER TO WHAT
LOOKS FOR A HITTER TO ENGAGE THE
POWER COMPONENT IN EACH GUYS
CAREER?
CARLOS: APPROACH.
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO
SPEAKING TO VAZQUEZ ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE
OBSERVED IN THE NUMBERS SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES, BUT WHEN I WAS
LOOKING AT HIS TIMING MECHANISM,
IT SEEMED LIKE HE WAS GETTING IN
CADENCE WITH PITCHES A LOT
BETTER THAN IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
ALANNA ASKED THAT QUESTION
EARLIER IN TODAY'S TELECASTER IT
IS LIKE, HEY, DO YOU HAVE TO --
YOU HAVE TO PICK ONE OR THE
OTHER.
YOU CANNOT BE IN BETWEEN.
VAZQUEZ USED TO BE ONE OF THOSE
IN BETWEEN GUYS.
OVER THE LAST FEW SEASONS HE
SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO BE READY FOR MY
FASTBALL.
OR AT TIMES, HE ADMITTED THIS TO
ME, I'M GOING TO GET AN OFFSPEED
PITCH OFF THE PLATE AND COMMIT
TO IT.
SO IT IS ALL ABOUT HIS APPROACH
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO BE ON TIME
FOR THE BASEBALL AND WHEN YOU
ARE ON TIME, YOU PUT HEALTHY
SWINGS ON THE BALL AND IT
TRANSLATES TO MORE POWER.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THAT, IN 2018
LIGHT HITTING CATCHER, A
PRISTINE REPUTATION ON DEFENSE,
BUT HE HIT 10 HOME RUNS IN HIS
FIRST FOUR SEASONS IN THE BIG
LEAGUES AND A CAREER-HIGH OF 23
IN 2019 ALL OF A SUDDEN.
2-1 OFFERING IS BLASTED!
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ LIVES UP TO
HIS NEW NAME AND GOES LONG!
CARLOS: ON CUE, SCOTTY, ON CUE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THAT PITCH WAS.
IT SEEMED LIKE SOMETHING UP AND
IN.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN THAT CUTTER AND
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ WAS READY FOR
IT.
HE GOT READY EARLY ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO GET HIS SWING IN.
WHEN WE SEE THIS REPLAY, WE WILL
BE ABLE TO SEE HOW HEALTHY THAT
HACK WAS THROUGH THE ZONE.
WHEN YOU DO THAT, GIVE YOURSELF
A SHOT.
CHECK THIS OUT, SMOLTZY.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GO TO THIS
REPLAY TO SEE WHAT A HEALTHY
SWING LOOKS LIKE.
SCOTT: AND A HEALTHY IN THE
DUGOUT, THE NEW CELEBRATION.
YOU HIT A HOMER, YOU RIDE THE
ROLLER COASTER.
CARLOS, HERE WAS THAT HEALTHY
HACK.
CARLOS: CUTTER INSIDE, VAZQUEZ
TAKES THE SWING.
YOU DON'T SEE HIM CHANGE THE
MECHANICS OR ADJUST TO WHERE THE
PITCH IS, MODIFYING HIS SWING TO
THE BASEBALL, NO.
HE TAKES A HEALTHY COT, ALMOST
LIKE HE WAS HITTING OFF THE TEE.
THAT IS BY DESIGN.
HE GOT READY FOR THAT PITCH UP
AND IN IN THE STRIKE ZONE AND
THAT IS WHY HE GOT THAT HEALTHY
HACK WE TALK ABOUT.
SCOTT: TWO-RUN SHOT MAKES IT 3-1
BOSTON, HOMERS IN BACK-TO-BACK
CONTESTS OR CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ.
AND THE FIRST REGULAR SEASON
HOME RUN ALLOWED BY YARBROUGH
SINCE AUGUST 21.
CARLOS: A LOT OF TIMES WE WILL
SEE HITTERS COLLAPSE ON THE
BACKSIDE, PULL OFF.
YOU MIGHT SAY, STAY IN THERE,
KEEP YOUR SHOULDER IN.
THE REALITY IS WE ARE SEEING
SYMPTOMS OF BEING LATE.
WHEN YOU HAVE BAD SWINGS, THE
FIRST THING YOU SHOULD ASK
YOURSELF, WAS I ON TIME?
SCOTT: MARGOT TIMES THAT UP IN
CENTER AND SITS DOWN RENFROE.
TWO OUTS, CHRISTIAN ARROYO
SETTING UP.
YOU LIKE THAT CELEBRATION IN THE
DUGOUT?
JOHN: I HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN IT
BEFORE.
I CAN ONLY THINK OF -- THAT
MIGHT BE DANGEROUS TO SOME OF
THE OLDER GUYS THAT HAVE TO DO
THAT BUT THE YOUNGER GUYS CAN
HANDLE IT.
SCOTT: YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
COME OUT OF THE CART?
JOHN: YEAH.
SCOTT: ARROYO POPPED OUT TO
SECOND IN HIS FIRST TRIP.
VAZQUEZ HAD THE HOMER YESTERDAY
IN THE NINTH INNING OFF OF DIEGO
CASTILLO, SAVED THE DAY FOR
BOSTON.
ENDED UP COMING BACK THREE TIMES
AND WINNING IN THE 12TH.
JOHN: I DON'T CARE WHAT ANYONE
SAYS, I SAID IT LONG BEFORE IT
HAPPENED.
AS YOU WATCH THE CELEBRATION,
FLYING THROUGH.
I THINK THAT RULE IS HERE TO
STAY.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO PLAY
THE GAME DON'T LIKE THE LESTER
INNING RULE BUT THAT WAS A
CLASSIC GAME LAST NIGHT OF WHAT
COULD HAPPEN WITH THE TYPE OF
ACTION STARTING A RUNNER AT
SECOND.
THAT GAME WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED IF IT WAS UNDER THE OLD
RULES, COULD HAVE GONE ON FOR 17
INNINGS, DRAINED EVERYONE'S
BULLPEN.
I GET THAT IS THE RUB OF 162
GAMES BUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH NOW WITH BASEBALL AND
THE PLAYERS, KEEPING PEOPLE AS
HEALTHY AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE,
EXTRA INNINGS, PEOPLE FORGET
ABOUT HOW HARD EXTRA INNINGS IS.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT RULE,.
INTO A FANTASTIC GAME BECAUSE OF
THAT RULE.
SCOTT: YESTERDAY WAS A ROLLER
COASTER RIDE, BACK BATTLE
BETWEEN THESE TWO TEAMS.
ARROYO THE END OF THE BAT.
THAT SITS DOWN THE SIDE BUT NOT
BEFORE THE RED SOX POUNCE.
IT IS CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ BASHING
BOSTON IN FRONT, 3-1, RED SOX
AFTER FOUR.
>> HERE WE GO, GAME ONE OF THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
SERIES.
>> THIS CROWD IS REALLY PUMPED
FOR THE RED SOX AND THE RAYS.
>> WE ARE FINALLY READY FOR
BASEBALL IN THE ALCS.
>> CHANGEUP.
STRUCK HIM OUT SWINGING.
>> HE WILL GET THE LAST TWO OUTS
OF THE FRAME.
>> STRIKE THREE CALLED.
CLIFF FLOYD AT THE PLATE.
SWINGS AND MISSES.
>> WE HAVE NO SCORE IN GAME ONE
OF THE ALCS.
>> RUNNERS AT SECOND AND THIRD
FOR JED LOWRIE.
>> FLY BALL RIGHT FIELD.
TAGGING AT THIRD.
>> BOSTON TAKES A 1-0 LEAD.
>> IT IS OFF OF HIS GLOVE!
IT ROLLS TO THE SIDE!
>> 1-2 COUNT.
HE GETS THE SIGN.
HE KICKS AND FIRES AND IT IS
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
GOT HIM ON A SPLITTER TO END IT.
THE RED SOX WIN GAME ONE OF THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
SERIES!
SCOTT: NATE EOVALDI IS PITCHING.
RANDY AROZARENA IS YOUR WINNER
BY A LANDSLIDE.
AS MANNY MARGOT TAKES STRIKE
ONE, WE ARE GOING TO BRING IN
ONE OF HIS TEAMMATES FOR OUR
SECOND DUGOUT INTERVIEW OF THE
DAY.
A REMINDER TO OUR YOUTUBE
CREATORS, BRING THOSE QUESTIONS
ONTO TYLER GLASNOW.
PERFECT, THERE HE IS, THE
PREDICTED ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
TYLER GLASNOW JOINS US NOW.
HER STYLE, WHAT IS RANDY SAYING
TO YOU, DO YOU THINK HE WILL
WIND ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AS
BOGAERTS HAS THE HIGH THROW.
DAHL BACK WITHOUT NUMBER ONE.
GO AHEAD, TYLER.
TYLER: YOU MENTIONED IT EARLIER,
I WAS THINKING RANDY THE WHOLE
WAY.
SHOE-IN ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: WHAT WAS HE SAYING TO
YOU?
TYLER: I HAVE THE HEADPHONES ON,
I DIDN'T EVEN HEAR HIM.
ALSO, WHERE AM I LOOKING, WHERE
ARE YOU AT?
SCOTT: TURN YOUR HEAD TO THE
LEFT, RIGHT FIELD.
RIGHT AROUND THERE.
YOU ARE SQUARED UP.
YOU ARE A CAMERA PRO ALREADY.
WE WILL MIX IN SOME QUESTIONS
FROM OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS.
LET'S START WITH LAST NIGHT AND
YOUR SEASON AS A WHOLE.
YESTERDAY, NINE STRIKEOUTS OVER
SIX INNINGS, ONE RUN.
GIVE US YOUR EVALUATION TO
YOU'RE BEGINNING OF THE SEASON.
TYLER: FEELING GOOD, WORKED ON A
COUPLE OF THINGS IN SPRING.
IT HAS BEEN AWESOME BEING WITH
KYLE, WORKING ON THE EVERYDAY
PROGRAM, NEW ADJUSTMENTS CAN
ACKLEY, MENTALITY.
WITH THE THIRD PITCH, IT'S BEEN
NICE TO STAY ON THAT ROUTINE,
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXECUTE MORE
CONSISTENTLY.
I FEEL REALLY COMFORTABLE ON THE
MOUND.
THE LAST FIVE OR SO TIMES ON THE
MOUND I'VE BEEN FEELING REALLY
GOOD, SO HOPEFULLY I CAN KEEP
THE MOMENTUM THROUGH THE SEASON.
SCOTT: CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN
EVERYONE WATCHING ON YOUTUBE
ABOUT THAT THIRD PITCH THAT IS
BECOMING A SOLID WEAPON RIGHT
AWAY IN THIS 2021 CAMPAIGN?
TYLER: I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY BUT I WAS WORKING
ON IT IN THE OFF-SEASON, FARTING
AROUND WITH GRIPS, NOTHING FELT
COMFORTABLE.
I FLEW IN EARLY TO FLORIDA TO
WORK WITH KYLE.
IT WAS THE FIRST BULLPEN WE
THROUGH.
WE HAD SO MUCH TO LOOK AT AS FAR
AS THE GRASS, THE CAMERAS, SO I
HAD SO MANY TOOLS TO UTILIZE TO
HONE IN ON A GRIP AND THE
FEELING OF IT.
IN A MATTER OF A BULLPEN OR TWO,
I HAVE A PRETTY AVERAGE SLIDER
THAT I CAN GO AND COMPETE WITH.
AS SPRING WENT ON --
WHOA!
I SPRING ONE ON THE GRIP CHANGE
A LITTLE BIT.
BECOMING MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
IT, THROWING WITH MORE
CONFIDENCE.
NOW IT IS A PITCH I AM
COMFORTABLE WITH.
THAT AND MY HEATER I'M EQUALLY
AS COME TROUBLE THROWING.
IT GIVE ME MORE OPTIONS, KEEPS
HITTERS AWAY FROM SELLING OUT.
SCOTT: WE ALSO JUST SHOWED YOUR
REACTION TIME ON THAT FOUL BALL.
WELL DONE.
YOU ARE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
INTERVIEWS.
WE DIDN'T GET MUCH TIME WITH YOU
AS THERE IS THE STRIKEOUT.
WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CHAT FOR LONGER
NEXT TIME.
TYLER: FOR SURE.
YOU LET ME KNOW, I'M HERE.
HAVE YOUR PEOPLE TALK TO MY
PEOPLE.
SCOTT: GOOD LUCK.
WE WILL TALK WILLY ADAMES DOWN N
STRIKES TO END THE INNING.
NATE EOVALDI NOT LETTING HIM
BREATHE VERY MUCH.
>> TWO MEN ON FOR JASON BAY.
>> INTO THE CORNER, THAT BALL IS
AT THE BASE OF THE WALL.
>> THE RED SOX LEAD 2-0.
>> 3-1 DRIVEN DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE, IT HAS A
CHANCE.
EVAN HAS TIED IT UP!
>> STILL GOING BACK, THAT BALL
IS GONE!
IT IS 3-2 RED SOX.
>> DEEP LEFT FIELD, HOW FAR IS
THIS ONE GOING TO GO?
IT IS WAY OUT OF HERE.
>> BASE HIT.
LONGORIA SCORES AND THE RED SOX
ARE IN FRONT!
>> KEVIN YOUKILIS LINING A HOME
RUN TO TIE IT AT 5-5.
>> IT IS A HOME RUN!
6-5 RED SOX.
>> THE RELAY THROW IS NOT IN
TIME.
>> THROW TO THE PLATE, NOT IN
TIME!
A WILD PITCH TIES IT UP.
>> THERE IS A POP-UP.
HERE COMES THE THROW.
AND THE RAYS HAVE WON IT!
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY FIDELITY.
SCOTT RON, CARLOS PENA, JOHN
SMOLTZ AND ALANNA RIZZO WITH
YOU.
LET'S FLASH BACK TO THE FOURTH
INNING.
RYAN YARBROUGH -- THE HESITATION
BUT LET ME COVER FIRST, JOHN,
BECAUSE THAT IS MY JOB.
WHEN TSUTSUGO PICKS UP THE
BASEBALL AND GETS THE JOB DONE.
SHARPLY STRUCK BY DAHL BACK.
WENDLE MAKES THE CATCH.
IT GETS ME REMINISCING TO A PLAY
FROM BACK IN THE DAY.
REMEMBER THIS?
JOHN: I TOLD HIM, I GOT IT, STAY
THERE.
THEN I TRY TO MAKE THE PLAY OF
THE CENTURY.
I WAS TRYING TO TELL JULIO
FRANCO I'VE GOT IT.
I AM LIKE A CAT ON THE MOUND.
WHAT I THOUGHT WHAT HAPPENED AND
WHAT YOU SAW WAS TOTALLY
OPPOSITE.
I THOUGHT THE BAG WAS TWO FEET
FROM ME, SO I WAS GOING TO ROLL
TO THE BAG.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT IS THE PLAY
THAT NEVER GOES AWAY.
AFTER THAT, THE TEAM HAD A LOT
OF FUN WITH THAT ON THE CHARTER
FLIGHT.
THEY SHOWED A VIDEO, AND THEY
WANTED ME TO BE IN THE VIDEO FOR
DROP, STOP, AND ROLL.
IT IS WHAT IT IS, DIDN'T MAKE
THE PLAY.
IT IS A VIDEO FOR EVERYONE TO
SEE WHAT NOT TO DO.
SCOTT: PLAWECKI IS HIT.
HE WILL TAKE FIRST.
JOHN, YOU ARE A GREAT SPORT,
THOUGH.
JOHN: TRY TO BE.
SCOTT: YOUR BREAKDOWN IS
EXCELLENT, ELITE.
CARLOS, THIS HURTS.
CARLOS: I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH
ARMOR YOU HAVE ON.
THAT HITS YOU IN THE FUNNYBONE,
YOU'LL BE COMPLAINING ABOUT THAT
FOR A WEEK.
THANK GOD FOR THOSE BUT STILL
HURTS.
SCOTT: YOU CAN SEE PLAWECKI
SHAKING IT OFF.
EARNS THE BASE.
HERE WE ARE, SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN
SMOLTZ, CARLOS PENA.
ALANNA RIZZO AT THE BALLPARK.
BOTTOM OF THE FIFTH INNING.
BOSTON LEADING 3-1 THANKS TO
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ WITH A TWO RUN
SHOT OVER THE GREEN MONSTER.
CARLOS: I THINK HE WILL BE A
HUGE ADDITION FOR THE RED SOX.
A LOT MORE PLAYING TIME THEN
WITH THE DODGERS.
HE WILL BE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THIS IS A ROW THAT HE EMBRACES,
SO I THINK HE WILL BLOSSOM OVER
IN BOSTON.
THE FANS WILL LOVE HIM FOR IT.
SCOTT: ALEX CORA TALKING ABOUT
HIM THIS MORNING, SAID BIGGER
THAN HE WAS A FEW YEARS AGO,
STRONGER, KNOWS HIS BODY AND
GAME MORE THAN EVER.
HE HAS BEEN A HUGE FAN FOR YEARS
AND IS EXCITED TO HAVE HIM AS
THE SPARK AT THE TOP OF THE
ORDER.
NEVER BEEN A LEADOFF HITTER BUT
LOOKS LIKE SHE CAN FILL THAT
ROLE PRETTY WELL FOR BOSTON.
JOHN: HE HAS MADE A SWING TRADER
COUPLE YEARS AGO, LOOKING TO
PLAY PEPPER WITH THAT WALL.
HIS NEW FRIEND WILL BE THAT
WALL.
CAN HE STAY OFF OF CHANGEUPS AND
OFF-SPEED PITCHES?
THAT HAS BEEN HIS KRYPTONITE
ESPECIALLY AGAINST LEFTIES.
SCOTT: KIKÉ LOVES DANCING, TOO.
CARLOS: GREAT PERSONALITY, GREAT
ENERGY COMES AND BRINGS IT TO
THE BALLPARK.
ONE OF THOSE SPARK PLUGS,
PROVERBIAL SPARK PLUG THAT HE IS
IN THAT CLUBHOUSE, WILL DO MORE
THAN WE CAN QUANTIFY.
THE RED SOX, IF YOU LOOK AT
THEIR SET UP, THEY SHOULD BE
CONTENDING.
SCOTT: IT IS LIKE "THE BRADY
BUNCH" ON THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE ONE MORE.
ALANNA, WHAT CAN YOU ADD?
ALANNA: KIKÉ AND HIM HAVE HAD A
LONG RELATIONSHIP.
KIKÉ HAS BEEN SUCH A GOOD PIECE
OF THE DODGERS PUZZLE.
I ASKED ALEX CORA, DID YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE GETTING WHEN KIKÉ
CAME TO THE RED SOX?
HE SAID THAT HE IS A BETTER
PLAYER THAN THE ONE THAT HE SAW
IN 2015.
DEFENSIVELY OUTSTANDING BUT IT'S
BEEN AN EYE-OPENER FOR ME JUST
HOW GOOD HE IS DEFENSIVELY.
ELITE DEFENDER, PARTICULARLY AT
SECOND BASE.
HE DOESN'T GET A TON OF REPS IN
THE OUTFIELD BUT HE SAYS HIS
DEFENSE IS JUST AS STELLAR ON
THE INFIELD.
REALLY JUST A GREAT ADDITION TO
THE CLUB.
SCOTT: AND AN ADDITION THAT
CONTRIBUTES AT THE PLATE.
BASE HIT, KIKÉ.
PLAWECKI OVER TO SECOND.
JOHN: I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS
SITTING ON THAT PITCH BUT HE
MADE AN ADJUSTMENT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE PITCH THAT
GAVE HIM BITS.
THE UPPER CUT FASTBALL IS
SOMETHING THAT HE IS NOT
BOTHERED BY, BUT IT IS A
PITCHERS PITCH.
YOU TAKE THAT AGGRESSIVE FULL
THROTTLE SWING, HE MISSES THAT.
KUDOS TO HIM IN MAKING THE
ADJUSTMENT AND GETTING THAT
PITCHERS PITCH REWARDED FOR A
HIT.
SCOTT: PITCHING COACH KYLE
SNYDER OUT TO TALK THINGS OVER
WITH RYAN YARBROUGH.
HERNANDEZ FROM PUERTO RICO, JUST
LIKE HIS MANAGER, ALEX CORA, THE
G.M. FOR PUERTO RICO IN THE
WORLD BASEBALL CLASSIC.
KIKÉ PLAYED ON THAT TEAM.
CARLOS: YOU WONDER WHAT THE
CONVERSATION IS LIKE ON THE
MOUND.
SMOLTZY, SOMETIMES WHEN PITCHERS
GET HIT, WE IMMEDIATELY SAY
MAYBE HE MISSED HIS SPOT, IT WAS
A MISTAKE.
BUT NOT REALLY.
SOMETIMES IT IS JUST GOOD
HITTING BEATING GOOD PITCHING.
AS IMPORTANT AS IT IS TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU MAKE A
MISTAKE, IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU JUST GOT
BEAT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE A GOOD
PITCHER, YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY.
THIS SHOULD BE AN ACTION PITCH
HERE, FIRST PITCH FASTBALL.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE HARD STUFF
FROM YARBROUGH.
JOHN: YOU GET REMINDED FROM YOUR
PITCHING COACH, NO BIG DEAL, WE
WILL GET A DOUBLE PLAY HERE.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE HOME
RUN, THERE HAS NOT BEEN A LOT OF
BALLS ROCKING ALL OVER.
JUST A GENTLE REMINDER TO RESET
THE BRAIN.
I CALL IT THE COMPUTER BECAUSE
YOU CAN GET A VIRUS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GAME, WHEN YOU
START THINKING NEGATIVELY OR
DIFFERENTLY FROM THE GAME PLAN
YOU HAD GOING IN.
SCOTT: STICK TO THE CODE.
THAT IS A SWING THAT DEVERS
WANTED BACK.
BOSTON STARTED THIS GAME 2-10 AT
THE PLATE IN THE FIRST THREE
INNINGS AGAINST YARBROUGH.
THEY HAVE BEEN CRACKING THE CODE
LATELY.
3-7 CONTRIBUTING TO THOSE THREE
RUNS.
PLAWECKI WAS HIT BY A PITCH.
HE IS IN SCORING POSITION NOW.
KIKÉ HERNANDEZ FOLLOWING WITH A
BASE HIT.
1-1 TO DEVERS.
SENT TO CENTER.
PLAYABLE FOR MARGOT, STARTS
DRIFTING IN.
TWO GONE IN THE FIFTH.
LET'S BRING IN STATCAST 3D
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
RAFAEL DEVERS STILL SO YOUNG AND
SO TALENTED, SO POWERFUL.
AND HE USES THIS BALLPARK,
CARLOS.
CARLOS: HE DOES.
HE HAS THIS ANGLE WHEN HE STEPS
SLIGHTLY INTO THE BUCKET WITH
HIS STRIDE THAT ALLOWS THE BALL
TO TRAVEL, HITS THE BALL THE
OTHER WAY OFF OF THE MUSTARD.
HE USES THAT WALL TO HIS
ADVANTAGE.
HE IS TAILOR-MADE FOR FENWAY
PARK.
THAT IS PRECISELY WHY I SEE HIM
BEING A PILLAR OF THIS
ORGANIZATION AS FAR AS OFFENSIVE
NUMBERS ARE CONCERNED,
PRODUCTION IS CONCERNED, FOR
YEARS TO COME.
HE IS STILL 24 YEARS OLD.
THAT IS HARD TO BELIEVE WITH ALL
THE SUCCESS HE HAS ALREADY HAD.
SCOTT: 24 AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT BOBBY DALBEC WHO HAS
BARELY SEEN BIG-LEAGUE TIME BUT
HAS SERIOUS POWER POTENTIAL, HE
IS OLDER THAN DEVERS.
A LOT ACCOMPLISHED BY THE RED
SOX THIRD ALREADY.
HE WAS THE SECOND OUT, NOW IT IS
J.D.
HITLESS THIS AFTERNOON BUT OFF
OF A 10-23 START.
TWO HOMERS, FIVE DOUBLES.
AND HE GIVES THAT BALL A RIDE.
DEEP LEFT, WILL IT STAY FAIR?
AND IT IS HIGH OFF THE WALL, AND
IT WILL SCORE A COUPLE OF RUNS
FOR BOSTON.
PLAWECKI COMES IN, SO DOES
HERNANDEZ.
J.D. MARTINEZ HAS HIMSELF A
RUN-SCORING DOUBLE.
4-1, BOSTON.
CARLOS: SLIGHTLY EARLY ON THIS
PITCH RIGHT HERE BUT HE WAS ABLE
TO KEEP THAT BARREL IN THE ZONE
FOR LONG ENOUGH TO GET GOOD
CONTACT WITH THE BASEBALL WITH
THAT SHORT WALL.
LOOK -- IT IS OUT IN FRONT
SLIGHTLY BUT HE IS ABLE TO HAVE
THAT LONG THROUGH THE ZONE PATH,
JUST MISSING A HOME RUN.
THERE HE IS MAKING AN IMPACT.
GREAT START.
SCOTT: 5-1, TWO SCORE FOR
BOSTON.
J.D. MARTINEZ A TECHNIQUE GREEN
MONSTER SUCCESSFULLY --
ATTACKING THE GREEN MONSTER
SUCCESSFULLY.
11 R.B.I.'S ON THE SEASON
ALREADY FOR J.D.
PLAYING IN HIS SIXTH GAME OF THE
SEASON.
BOSTON CHECKING IN AT 2-3 ON THE
YEAR.
SWEPT BY BALTIMORE, TAKEN THE
FIRST TWO AGAINST TAMPA BAY.
NOW IN GOOD POSITION IN THE
FIFTH.
TAMPA BAY AT 2-3 AS WELL.
CARLOS: AND IT DOESN'T GET ANY
EASIER.
HERE IS XANDER BOGAERTS.
SINCE 2015, ONE OF THE BEST
SHORTSTOPS IN THE GAME.
TALKING BATTING AVERAGE, HE IS
RANKING FIRST IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
RUNS, FIRST.
EXTRA-BASE HITS, SECOND ONLY TO
LINDOR.
R.B.I., FIRST AS WELL.
THREE SILVER SLUGGER AWARDS IN
THAT SPAN.
WE ARE REALLY WATCHING ONE OF
THE GAME'S GREATS, AS OF RIGHT
NOW IN THAT POSITION.
SCOTT: A COUPLE ALL-STAR
APPEARANCES.
CONSISTENTLY GREAT FOR BOSTON.
PLAYS EVERY DAY.
AND HIS TEAMMATE IS THE FIRST
PLAYER IN RED SOX HISTORY WITH
AN EXTRA-BASE HIT HIS FIRST SIX
GAMES OF THE SEASON, MAKING UP
FOR WHAT HE CALLS A LOST YEAR IN
2020 AT THE PLATE.
A LOT OF US WANT TO FORGET 2020.
JOHN: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: RERUNS IN THE FOURTH TWO
MORE IN THE FIFTH.
FIVE TOTAL FOR BOSTON.
MARTIN IS SECOND AFTER DRIVING
IN TWO.
BOGAERTS SEEKING HIS THIRD HIT
OF THE DAY.
GIRAFFENCKMAARC SAYS J.D. IS
JUST STANDING FOR DOUBLES TODAY.
I MISSED THIS.
JOHN: EVERYBODY, EVEN THE
PLAYERS.
HOPEFULLY IT WILL GET BETTER AS
TIME GOES ON AND EACH STADIUM.
SCOTT: SOME FANS ARE GOING YOU
MISS RYAN YARBROUGH TAKING HIS
TIME?
I MISSED THE ROAR OF THE CROWD,
ESPECIALLY BOSTON.
HERE COMES THAT 1-2.
BOGAERTS DID NOT GO.
JOHN: THE FANS ARE LIKE THE
SOUNDTRACK OF THE BASEBALL GAME.
CARLOS: AN INTENSE MOMENT, YOU
CAN HEAR THE CROWD, THE
CRESCENDO.
ALSO I LOVE WATCHING THE
REACTION WHEN A BALL IS HIT WELL
GOING TO WAR THE OUTFIELD AND
THEY ARE ANTICIPATING PERHAPS A
HOME RUN.
I LOVE THE WAY THEY GET UP AND
CHEER.
I TRULY MISS THAT AS A FAN
WATCHING, AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
HOW MUCH THE PLAYERS MISS IT.
SCOTT: 2-2 ON THE GROUND.
NICE., BUT ADONIS DROPS THE
BASEBALL.
MARTINEZ IS SAFE AT THIRD.
BOGAERTS GETS TO FIRST.
BACK HANDPICKED BY ADONIS WAS
STRONG BUT THE EXCHANGE DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
JOHN: I AM A FIRST GUESSER AND A
PITCHER BUT THIS HAS TO BE A
HIT.
THIS WAS ABSOLUTELY SMOKED.
IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN A GREAT
THROW, SO WE WILL SEE HOW IT WAS
SCORED BUT TWO STRIKE HITTING,
KEEPING THE INNING ALIVE.
RED SOX STARTING TO SHOW A
LITTLE BIT OF THEIR OLD SELF
WHEN THEY WERE A CROOKED NUMBER
MACHINE.
THEY COULD PUT UP A CROOKED
NUMBER IN ANY ONE OF THOSE NINE
INNINGS.
DID THEY RULE ANYTHING YET?
SCOTT: AS SOON AS I RECEIVE IT.
CARLOS: SHOULD BE A HIT.
THAT WAS SCORCHED.
SCOTT: PICK YOUR VERB.
CARLOS: YES.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOK AT THE START BY CHRISTIAN
VAZQUEZ.
THINKING ABOUT HOW GOOD OF A
STARTER, IF I HAD THAT APRIL'S,
IN MY CAREER I WAS TYPICALLY NOT
A GOOD STARTER.
IT WAS TOUGH TO DIG YOURSELF OUT
OF A HOLE WHEN YOU START OUT
SLOW.
WHEN YOU SEE THESE GUYS IN THE
.400'S WITH TWO HOME RUNS ONLY A
FEW GAMES INTO THE SEASON, THAT
MUST FEEL GREAT TO GET YOUR
SEASON GOING.
SCOTT: HE DID THIS LAST YEAR,
TOO, VAZQUEZ WITH A SIZZLING
FIRST WEEK OF THE SEASON.
NOW DROPS ONE INTO SHALLOW LEFT.
THAT WILL SCORE ANOTHER ONE FOR
BOSTON.
J.D., COME ON DOWN.
IT IS 6-1.
CARLOS: HE GOT FISTED ON THIS
SWING HERE BUT WAS ABLE TO PUSH
IT THROUGH, KEEPING IT LEVEL IN
THE ZONE.
GIVES YOU A LITTLE MORE MARGIN
FOR ERROR.
I BELIEVE THIS IS GOING TO BE
THAT CUTTER.
IT DOES JAM HIM, BUT THAT LEVEL
SWING THROUGH THE ZONE ALLOWS
HIM TO PUSH THAT BASEBALL OVER
THE INFIELDERS.
THE LINE DRIVE TRAJECTORY --
GOOD HITTERS DO THAT, THEY DON'T
NOTICE THE SWING.
YOU HAVE TO TIP YOUR HAT.
GOOD HITTING.
SCOTT: J.D. MARTINEZ AND
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ, ALL THE TALK
IN BOSTON THIS SEASON.
FOUR HOME RUNS, SLUGGING OFF THE
CHARTS.
WAITING FOR THE REST OF THE
GROUP TO CATCH UP.
LIKE HUNTER RENFROE, 0-2 TODAY.
BROKE HIS BAT, SERVES ONE UP FOR
ADONIS.
AND THE THROW SKIPS AWAY.
BOGAERTS COMES HOME.
IT IS 7-1.
AND HERE COMES ANOTHER.
IT IS VAZQUEZ.
RACING AROUND THEY GO.
KEY MISHAP FROM TAMPA BAY ON
DEFENSE.
IT OPENED THIS ONE UP.
JOHN: THIS IS ABOUT AS ROUTINE
AS IT GETS.
A BETTER HAS NO REAL FOOT SPEED
TO CREATE ANY STRESS.
THIS IS A JAM GROUND BALL A
SUREHANDED SHORTSTOP.
HE JUST TAKES HIS TIME AND THE
BALL GOES STRAIGHT DOWN AND
MAYBE, MAYBE A TOUGH PLAY ON
BOTH ENDS TO EXPECT THE FIRST
BASEMAN SHOULD COME UP WITH THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS WIDE OF THE BAG.
THE DAY THAT ENDED LAST NIGHT
AND THE MOMENTUM FOR THE RED
SOX, YOU COULD ARGUE, HAS
CARRIED OVER INTO THE SHORT
TURNAROUND GAME THIS AFTERNOON.
SCOTT: ALANNA, WHAT ELSE CAN YOU
TELL US ABOUT THAT LAST PLAY?
ALANNA: A COUPLE DEFENSIVE
MISCUES BY THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
WE HAD THE CONVERSATION EARLIER
WITH KEVIN CASH ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR HIS BALLCLUB
TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND THE
BASEBALL WHEN IT IS IN PLAY.
HE SAYS WITH THE ALTERED
BASEBALL THE SEASON WE FIGURE WE
WOULD HAVE FEWER HOME RUNS OR
BALLS IN THE AIR.
YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO CATCH THE
BASEBALL, WE MUST DEFEND AND NOT
HAVE SLOPPY PLAYS WITH THE
GLOVE.
SCOTT: WHILE WE HAVE YOU, WHAT
IS THE SCENE LIKE OUT THERE?
ALANNA: IT IS AWESOME, YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE CROWD.
WHETHER THEY ARE CHEERING OR
JEERING AGAINST YOU, IT IS SO
NICE TO HAVE A FAN BASE, ALBEIT
AT A SMALL CAPACITY, IN THE
PARK.
THE PLAYERS ABSOLUTELY THRIVE
WITH HAVING THEM BACK.
SCOTT: AND THE FANS ARE LOVING
THIS INNING FOR BOSTON.
CHRISTIAN ARROYO DELIVERS AND
SCORES ANOTHER FOR THE RED SOX
TO MAKE IT 9-1.
ALANNA: I COULD CONTINUE ON THE
FAN THING.
GUY'S, JUST TO CONTINUE ON ABOUT
THE FAN EXPERIENCE, WHEN I WAS
TALKING TO ALEX CORA, I SAID I
UNDERSTAND YOU GOT TO IN EARLY
START.
HE STOPPED ME AND HE SAID THERE
IS NO EARLY START WHEN YOU PLAY
IN BOSTON.
WE KNOW WHERE WE LIVE, WE KNOW
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THIS FAN
BASE.
HE SAID IT IS ACTUALLY A GOOD
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR THE NEW
GUYS.
THE NEW MEMBERS OF THIS BOSTON
RED SOX CLUB WHO HAVE PERHAPS
NOT PLAYED IN AN ATMOSPHERE OR
AN EXPECTATION WITH A FAN BASE
LIKE THIS.
IT REMINDS US THAT THEY WILL BE
ALLOWED.
MY JOB AS A MANAGER IS TO KEEP
THE DUGOUT AND THE CLUBHOUSE
QUIET.
SCOTT: THE FANS ARE LOUD AND
FEELING IT, AFTER A SIX-RUN
INNING, CONTINUES.
JOHN: YOU HAVE TO FEEL FOR MR.
YARBROUGH.
HAS NOT GIVEN UP A TON OF HARD
HIT BALLS THE LAST COUPLE.
MAYBE YOU QUESTION HE IS OUT
THERE.
EXTRA INNINGS, LONG SEASON, IT
IS JUST A TOUGH ONE TO SWALLOW
WHEN YOU ARE ON THE BAD END OF A
9-1 AND STILL IN THE GAME.
TRYING TO GET THAT LAST OUT AND
RESET THE GAME FOR WHOEVER IS
COMING NEXT.
SCOTT: BOBBY DALBEC STARTED THIS
INNING A MILLION YEARS AGO
LINING OUT TO JOEY WENDLE.
COLLIN MCHUGH LOOKS LIKE HE WILL
FOLLOW RYAN YARBROUGH.
CARLOS: CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT TYPE
OF EXIT VELOCITIES THESE HITS
HAVE PRODUCED.
LIKE SMOLTZ WAS SAYING, NOT A
LOT OF HARD HIT BALLS THIS
INNING.
BUT BASEBALL IS INTERESTING HOW
SOMETIMES MOMENTUM SHIFTS.
AFTER LAST NIGHT'S GAME, IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE, THE RED SOX,
EVERYTHING IS GOING THEIR WAY.
JOHN: TOUGH TO GET ANYBODY SIX
OUTS IN AN INNING.
FIVE OUTS, YOU COULD SAY IT'S
BEEN RECORDED IN THIS INNING,
BUT THE THIRD OUT HAS NOT
OFFICIALLY BEEN MADE.
SCOTT: SEE IF IT HAPPENS HERE.
DALBEC IS RETIRED.
SIX RUNS FOR BOSTON.
THE RED SOX NOW, PUT IT WELL,
CONFIRMED.
WE ARE HAVING A GOOD TIME.
INDEED.
>> NAVARRO, .295 IN THE REGULAR
SEASON.
>> HEADING FOR THE PLATE AND
SCORING IS LONGORIA.
>> FASTBALL.
THERE IS A HIGH DRIVE DEEP INTO
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
WAY BACK AND IT IS OVER
EVERYTHING!
A THREE-RUN HOMER FOR UPTON.
>> DRIVEN LEFT CENTER FIELD AND
DEEP AS WELL.
THAT HAS A CHANCE TO GO AND IT
DOES!
>> LONGORIA EXTEND THE TAMPA BAY
LEAD TO 5-0.
>> THERE IS A SWING AND A HIGH
DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT BALL IS GONE!
>> THE RAYS HAVE BUSTED THE GAME
OPEN IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
>> HIGH DRIVE DEEP INTO LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
THAT ONE IS WAY BACK, STILL
GOING, AND IT'S GONE!
>> SWING AND A FLY BALL, LEFT
FIELD.
GOES BACK CRAFTED AT THE EDGE OF
THE TRACK AND HE HAS IT.
THE FINAL, TAMPA BAY, NINE, THE
RED SOX, 1.
THE RAYS LEAD THE SERIES 2-1.
JOHN: WHAT DID THEY GIVE, DID
THEY GIVE THAT A HIT?
3-3 IF IT IS A HIT.
BOGAERTS WAS A HIT?
SCOTT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK FOR THE 2021 SEASON IS
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING ON DEVICES AND
COMPUTERS CAN VOTE AS TO WHO
WILL GET A TROPHY AT THE END OF
THE GAME.
STAY TUNED, POLLING OPTIONS
LATER IN THE SHOW.
OUR FIRST LOOK AT THE TROPHY,
THAT IS NICE.
THAT ALMOST LOOKS TOO GOOD TO BE
TRUE.
LOOK AT THE ARCHITECTURE TO PUT
THAT TOGETHER.
JOHN: TROPHY.
SOME IT IS GOING TO ADD IT.
IT IS NOT DIGITAL, ACTUALLY
PHYSICAL.
SCOTT: PERFECTLY DONE BY
YOUTUBE, AS WE ARE BRINGING IT
TO JULIE TODAY TO A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE.
THAT IS A PHYSICAL TROPHY THAT
WILL BE HANDED OUT AFTER THE
GAME.
I WILL MAKE A VERY EDUCATED
PREDICTION AND SAY THAT TROPHY
WILL PROBABLY LAND IN THE HANDS
OF A BOSTON RED SOX PLAYER.
JOHN: GOOD PREDICTION SO FAR.
SCOTT: I LIKE TO PLAY IT SAFE.
CARLOS: VERY BOLD.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: SEE HOW THE RAYS RESPOND
HERE IN THE SIXTH.
LONG BREAK FOR NATE EOVALDI
BEFORE HE STEPS BACK UP.
ONLY 66 PITCHES INTO HIS OUTING.
JOHN: YOU KNOW THAT IF A TEAM IS
GOING TO TAKE THAT LONG TO
SCORE, YOU JUST HAVE TO MENTALLY
CHECK BACK IN AS QUICK AS YOU
CAN WHEN YOU GET BACK ON THE
MOUND.
SCOTT: SIX RUNS OFF A FIVE HITS,
ONE ERROR, HIT BY PITCH ALL IN
THE FIFTH.
JOHN: IT IS A LEARNED TRAIT.
PEOPLE SAY ALL THE TIME, PITCH
LIKE IT IS 1-0.
YOU KNOW IT IS NOT 1-0, IT IS
9-1.
YOU HAVE TO TRAIN YOURSELF WITH
WHITE NOISE.
IF YOU GO OUT ON THE MOUND AND
YOU SAY, I CAN MAKE THREE
MISTAKES, THEN YOU ARE IN
TROUBLE.
YOU TRY YOUR BEST -- I ALWAYS
THOUGHT WHEN A TEAM SCORED ME
FIVE RUNS OR MORE, THE FIRST
HITTER, I DON'T CARE WHAT
HAPPENED THE SECOND HITTER, THE
FIRST HITTER WAS GOING TO BE
MADE AN OUT.
THAT WAS MY ONLY OBJECTIVE AND
THEN YOU GO AND PIECE IT
TOGETHER AFTER THAT.
SCOTT: SO THAT MEANS A BIG PITCH
COMING UP FOR EOVALDI,
PERSONALLY.
JOHN: HE STAYED AWAY FROM THE
VELOCITY ASPECT, BUT BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT EVERYONE
GETS TO SEE -- THERE IS.
SCOTT: CLIMBS A LADDER TO PUT
AWAY TSUTSUGO.
ALANNA, WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
ALANNA: ANOTHER K FOR EOVALDI.
COMING OFF OF HIS FIRST OUTING
OF THE SEASON, HE SAID HE HAD A
GOOD MIX OF THE REPERTOIRE.
ALEX CORA SAID IT WAS A TOUGH
LUCK LOSS CONSIDERING THE LACK
OF RUN SUPPORT HE RECEIVED IN
HIS FIRST OUTING.
HE WAS HOPING TODAY THAT EOVALDI
COULD GIVE HIM 110 PITCHES, SIX
OR SEVEN INNINGS.
RIGHT NOW AT A VERY EFFICIENT 69
ON THE PITCH COUNT, SO DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HIS MANAGER WAS
HOPING FOR.
SCOTT: RETIRED SIX IN A ROW FOUR
OF THOSE BE A STRIKEOUT.
AUSTIN MEADOWS IS BRINGING IT,
AND HE WILL GRANT SOMETIMES.
JOHN: THE ONE THING HE'S BEEN
ABLE TO DO OVER THE LAST COUPLE
INNINGS IS TO START AUTHORING
CURVEBALLS.
THAT CURVEBALL IS SUCH A BREAK
IN THE TENSION OF SPEED FOR A
HITTER, THAT IS WHY HE CAN THROW
THAT ALMOST AT WILL FOR STRIKES.
HE GETS AHEAD WITH IT.
SCOTT: THAT IS SHIPPED TO
CENTER.
KIKÉ HERNANDEZ IS GOING TO PLAY
THAT OFF-THE-WALL BAREHANDED.
THAT IS A DOUBLE FOR MEADOWS.
JOHN: KIKÉ IS JUST
HABIT-FORMING.
THERE IS NOBODY ON AND HE IS
TRYING TO DEKE LIKE HE HAD THAT
BALL.
AS SOON AS HE HIT THAT BALL THE
RUNNER NEW.
WHEN WE CAME IN AS A NATIONAL
LEAGUE TEAM, WE DIDN'T HIT, BUT
EVERY PITCHER WANTED TO TAKE
B.P. TO SEE WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
WAS IT REACHABLE?
WHAT DID YOU HAVE TO DO TO LOGIT
OVER THE WALL TO GET A HOME RUN?
WHEN I TOOK B.P. HERE, I WAS SO
DISAPPOINTED.
I REALIZED AS A PITCHER, THE
HITTER HAS A TERM OF THIS
ADVANTAGE WITH THE WALL.
I DIDN'T WANT THAT TO BE IN MY
HEAD WHEN I WENT ON THE MOUND.
IRONICALLY, AS A VISITING
PITCHER -- YOU MENTIONED HOW I
PLAYED FOR THE RED SOX, I'LL BE
AT SHORT.
I DIDN'T GIVE UP AN EARNED RUN I
THINK IN 29 INNINGS AS A
VISITING PITCHER AGAINST THAT
LINEUP BECAUSE THEY STRUCK FEAR
INTO YOU.
I UNDID THAT SO FAST AS A HOME
PITCHER, I MAY HAVE GIVEN UP 29
RUNS IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
I TRIED TO USE THAT VISITOR
MINDSET.
I HAVE HAD SUCCESS HERE, THAT
WILL WORK.
WELL, IT DIDN'T.
I WISH IT WERE DIFFERENT.
COME TO FIND OUT, TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE, WHEN I WENT TO
ST. LOUIS TO FINISH MY CAREER
THERE, I WAS TIPPING MY PITCHES,
WHICH IS NOT HELP THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU ARE GIVING UP A LOT OF
RUNS AND HITS.
SCOTT: AROZARENA JUST AS
FRUSTRATED AS YOU THERE, JOHN.
SCOTT BARRY, THE HOME PLATE
UMPIRE WITH THE CALL.
HE WENT AROUND.
JOHN: AS I LEARNED ABOUT THIS
ORGANIZATION, EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
SHORT, THE RICH HISTORY WAS
PHENOMENAL.
THE WAY THEY TREAT EVERY PLAYER
AS FAMILY IS PHENOMENAL.
THE CROWD AND THE FAN BASE LOVES
THEIR RED SOX.
WE TALKED EARLIER EVEN WITH ALEX
CORA ABOUT, GETTING ON THE WRONG
SIDE IF YOU WILL, NOT A FUN
PLACE IN BOSTON.
GETTING ON THE RIGHT SIDE,
EUPHORIC PLACE TO BE BECAUSE
THEY WILL LOVE YOU TO DEATH IF
YOU ARE PUTTING IN THE TIME AND
EFFORTS, AND RESULTS, OF COURSE.
SCOTT: HUG'S, FREE BEVERAGES ALL
AROUND THE CITY.
JOHN: I WILL SHARE ONE QUICK
STORY -- BROADCASTERS NOT
SUPPOSED TO DO THIS WITH TWO
OUTS.
MY FIRST WEEK, MY CAR IN A
PARKING LOT WAS PACKED WITH ALL
OF MY STUFF GOING TO PAWTUCKET.
I READ A SIGN ON THE DOOR THAT
SAID YOU SHOULD NOT BE PARKING
WHERE YOU ARE PARKING, GO BACK.
IT WAS UP ON THE TOW IN THREE
MINUTES.
THIS GUY WAS READY TO TAKE MY
CAR AND EVERYTHING AWAY.
I WAS TRYING TO GET HIS
ATTENTION.
HE WOULD HAVE NOTHING OF IT.
CAN'T YOU READ?
I AM TAKING YOUR CAR.
I MENTION PAWTUCKET, I SET I
HAVE TO GET TO PAWTUCKET.
HIS HEAD TURNED AROUND AND SAID,
ARE YOU WITH RED SOX?
I SAID, YES, SIR.
MY CAR WAS DOWN WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES, WE WERE BEST FRIENDS,
AND I GOT TO RETRIEVE ALL OF MY
STUFF.
IT WAS ABOUT TO START BAD WITH
MY SHORT CAREER IN BOSTON.
SCOTT: JOHN SMOLTZ HERE, FUTURE
HALL OF FAMER.
JOHN: I DIDN'T WANT TO NAME DROP
BUT I WAS THINKING, CAN HE
PHYSICALLY TAKE ME IN MY CAR ON
THE TOW TRUCK?
I WAS GETTING IN THE CAR.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GREAT STORY.
THAT IS BALL FOUR.
CARLOS: WHEN HE WENT HOME AND
REALIZED WHO YOU WERE, PROBABLY
KICKING HIMSELF.
WHAT IN THE WORLD, DID I JUST
EMBARRASS MYSELF?
CARLOS: JOHN: HE WAS DOING HIS
JOB.
I JUST COULDN'T BELIEVE HOW
QUICKLY.
LITERALLY FIVE MINUTES HE WAS
EFFICIENT.
SCOTT: HE WAS GOING TO IMPACT
THE RED SOX.
JOHN: I WOULD HAVE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT TO DO.
EVERYTHING I OWNED AT THE TIME
THAT WOULD BE IN BOSTON -- I HAD
A SUBURBAN.
IT WAS SO SHOCKING BUT THEN
RELIEVING AFTERWARD TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO PAWTUCKET, START MY
REHAB.
SCOTT: SAVED BY THE SOX.
[LAUGHTER]
TWO ON FOR YANDY DIAZ.
EOVALDI BLOWS 90 PAST HIM.
CARLOS: SO EFFORTLESS.
DEFINITELY A LOT OF POWER BEHIND
THAT FASTBALL.
A LOT OF US WONDER, EOVALDI HAS
GOT THE STUFF TO BE ELITE IN THE
LEAGUE.
I THOUGHT HE MIXES HIS PITCHES
WELL.
IF HE CONTINUES TO DO SO, HE
WILL HAVE A GOOD YEAR.
JOHN: OF COURSE FOR EVERY
PITCHER IT IS BEING HEALTHY, BUT
IF HIS HAND DEVIATES AT ALL TO
THE TILT SIDE OF THE BALL, HIS
98 DOES NOT MEAN 98.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A LOW
THREE-QUARTER, THAT EXTRA HOP --
AND IT CAN VARY FROM PITCH TO
PITCH.
WHEN HE STAYS BEHIND THE BALL,
THERE IS NOBODY THAT THROWS IT
LIKE HE DOES, LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: 99, NATE EOVALDI.
STRIKES OUT THE SIDE IN THE
SIXTH.
SEVEN ON THE DAY FOR EOVALDI.
>> FENWAY PARK, THE SITE FOR
GAME FOUR.
>> NOW THE PITCH, SWING AND A
DRIVE TO WHERE MONSTER IN LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
PENA HAS HIT IT OUT!
RIGHT AWAY, THE RAYS PICK UP A
2-0 LEAD.
>> LONGORIA DRIVES ONE DEEP
LEFT.
BACK-TO-BACK BOMBS FOR THE RAYS!
>> THE GROUND THAT WAS QUIETED
LAST NIGHT IS QUIETED AGAIN HERE
IN THE TOP OF THE FIRST.
>> HIGH DRIVE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
VERY DEEP, THAT BALL IS GONE!
WHAT A SHOT.
>> AND THE RAYS LEAD 5-0 HERE IN
FENWAY.
>> IT IS 10-1 TAMPA BAY.
>> YOU CAN BET THE RED SOX ARE
GLAD THERE IS AN OFF DAY
TOMORROW.
>> LINE DRIVE, ANOTHER HIT.
FIVE-R.B.I. NIGHT TONIGHT.
>> GOOD NIGHT, SWING AND A MISS,
STRIKE THREE.
THE RAYS HAVE TAKEN A 3-1 LEAD
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SCOTT: THE GREAT RANDY AROZARENA
MIKE TOP TODAY.
JOHN: WANT ME TO TAKE THIS OR
SHOULD WE GO TO CARLOS?
CARLOS: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: CARLOS, CAN YOU
TRANSLATE?
JOHN IS STILL THINKING ABOUT IT.
CARLOS: HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT HE HAD NO CLUE, THAT
BALL THAT WAS IN FOUL TERRITORY,
HOW IT GOT INTO HIS GLOVE.
HE JUST WENT AFTER IT.
TALKING TO WILLY ADAMES, WHAT
HAPPENED?
I THOUGHT IF I GOT UNDERNEATH
THE BALL AND I HAD IT, THAT WE
WERE OK.
ADAMES SAID, NO, SOMEBODY
TOUCHED IT.
HE WAS JUST PERPLEXED.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I WAS UNDERNEATH THE BALL AND I
CAUGHT IT.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT YOU WERE
GOING TO SAY, RIGHT?
JOHN: BASICALLY, I UNDERSTAND
THE LETTER OF THE RULE, BUT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND CONCEPTUALLY
HOW THAT CANNOT BE AN OUT.
SCOTT: IT WAS ENTERTAINING,
SKILLED.
J.D. CAME BACK OUT.
YARBROUGH STILL GOT THE JOB DONE
BUT LATER FALTERED AGAINST
BOSTON.
COLLIN MCHUGH IN THERE NOW.
CARLOS: WE HAVE TO REVISE THAT
RULE.
SCOTT: WE SHOULD.
CARLOS: IT JUST DOES NOT SEEM
FAIR.
JOHN: COLLIN MCHUGH, AGAIN, ON
THE OPPOSITE SPECTRUM OF
YARBROUGH.
THE RIGHT-HANDER WHO CAN SPIN
THE BALL AND CREATE DECEPTION.
HE DOESN'T HAVE AN EXERTION THAT
LOOKS LIKE HE IS EMPTYING THE
TANK BUT HE KNOWS HOW TO PITCH,
SPIN IT, LOCATE IT.
OF COURSE SOME TIME WITH THE
ASTROS, SOME SUCCESS THEIR
TEACHING HIM HOW TO SPIN THE
BASEBALL.
HIS ABILITY TO SPIN IT IS REALLY
GOOD.
SCOTT: AND HE HAS A LOT IN HIS
ARSENAL, TOO.
FOUR-SEAM CUTTER, SINKER, CHANGE
UP, SLIDER.
JOHN: I KNOW WE LOVE THE OUTPUT
OF INFORMATION ON WHAT SPIN RATE
MEANS, BUT I COULD NOT TEACH YOU
HOW TO THROW MY SLIDER SPIN
RATE.
I CAN TEACH YOU HOW TO THROW MY
SLIDER.
WHAT COMES NATURALLY TO A
PITCHER IS A GIFT.
SOME GUYS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
IMPROVE AND GET THE VELOCITY.
I CAN TEACH ANYBODY TO THROW THE
BALL HARDER.
WHETHER THAT TRANSLATES TO
SUCCESS DEPENDS ON THEIR
ATHLETICISM AND MECHANICS.
BUT SPINNING A BASEBALL AND
CHANGING DIRECTION, NOT
EVERYBODY CAN DO IT.
IF EVERYBODY COULD DO IT, THEY
WOULD HAVE SIMILAR PITCHES.
THE TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE TO
SIMULATE THOSE THINGS IS
PHENOMENAL.
THAT NEVER EXISTED.
THE TREVOR BAUER'S OF THE WORLD
THAT HAVE BEEN BASICALLY ENABLE
TO INUNDATE HIMSELF WITH ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION AND TRANSFORM
HIM INTO A PITCHER THAT NOW HAS
FOUR OR FIVE PITCHES, WHEREAS 15
YEARS AGO, YOU WOULD BE WHERE
YOU ARE.
SCOTT: IT WORKED OUT FOR MCHUGH.
DIDN'T WORK OUT WITH THE METS.
WAIVER BY THE ASTROS, STICK WITH
THAT SPIN, AND IT MADE HIS
CAREER.
GET EXCLUSIVE CONTENT AND
HIGHLIGHTS FROM YOUR FAVORITE
TEAM, THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
GO TO YOUTUBE.COM/RAYS AND HIT
THAT SUBSCRIBE BUTTON.
PLAWECKI SENDS ONE DEEP TO LEFT.
AND THAT IS CAUGHT.
AUSTIN MEADOWS TO THE TRACK
MAKES THE CATCH.
ONE GONE.
JOHN: WHAT IS AMAZING ABOUT OUR
GAME, WHETHER ON THE HITTING
SIDE OR PITCHING SIDE, WHEN
SOMEBODY OPENS UP A DOOR FOR
YOU, A VENUE FOR SUCCESS OR
THOUGHT PROCESS YOU WOULDN'T
THINK, IT CHANGES CERTAIN GUYS
CAREERS.
I CANNOT FORGET REMEMBERING THE
WAY THAT WE WERE TAUGHT, YOU
NEVER THROW A FRONT DOOR SLIDER
TO A RIGHT HITTER.
WHEN I LEARNED THAT, THAT WAS SO
INCREDIBLY LIFE-CHANGING.
YOU THROW OUT SOME OF THE
THEORIES BASED ON THE TIMEFRAME
YOU ARE PITCHING IN.
LEFTIES USED TO NEVER THROW A
LEFTY ON LEFTY CHANGEUP.
WHEN YOU START EVOLVING AS A
PLAYER AND SEE WHAT CERTAIN
TEAMS OR PHILOSOPHIES CAN GIVE
YOU A CHANCE FOR SUCCESS, IT
CHANGES.
SCOTT: HERNANDEZ, HOT SHOT PAST
THE INFIELD, AND HE IS ON BOARD.
BACK-TO-BACK BASE HITS FOR KIKÉ
HERNANDEZ AFTER AN 0-2 START.
CARLOS: THAT IS TWICE ALREADY
I'VE SEEN KIKÉ HERNANDEZ HITTING
AN OFFSPEED'S PITCH -- OFF-SPEED
PITCH.
SMOLTZY MENTION PERHAPS HE WAS
SITTING ON A CHANGEUP IN THE
PREVIOUS AT-BAT.
CERTAINLY WAS SITTING ON THIS
SLIDER.
HE DIDN'T LOOK FOOLED AT ALL.
WE WERE TALKING, IT IS A VERY
DEVASTATING ONE, BUT WHEN YOU
KNOW IT IS COMING AND YOU GET
READY FOR IT, YOU GET HEALTHY
SWINGS.
JOHN: ESPECIALLY IN THE WRONG
LOCATIONS, STAYING MIDDLE-MIDDLE
LIKE THAT ONE DID.
I HAVE HEARD YOU HITTERS TALK
ABOUT HOW SOMETIMES IT CAN BE
DANGEROUS WHEN YOU SIT ON A
PITCH.
THAT MEANS YOU SEE IT, YOU THINK
YOU HAVE TO SWING.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SITTING ON A PITCH AND GETTING
IT IN THE SPOT YOU WANT.
THAT IS DIFFERENT FROM SEEING IT
AND AUTOMATICALLY THINKING YOU
HAVE TO SWING.
CARLOS: THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THAT IS WHY WHEN YOU ARE SITTING
ON A PITCH YOU HAVE TO. HAVE A
TRAJECTORY IN MIND
VISUALIZE WHERE DOES THIS NEED
TO START IN ORDER FOR ME TO
OFFER AT IT?
IF IT IS THAT SLIDER, IT
CERTAINLY HAS TO START LETTER
HIGH, DEFINITELY ABOVE YOUR
WAIST.
IF NOT, AND AUTOMATIC TAKE.
SCOTT: DEVERS JUST FOUND OUT
BALL OFF OF HIS LEG -- FOULED
THAT BALL OFF OF HIS LEG.
JOHN: I CAN HONESTLY SAY,
HOWEVER MANY HITS, AT-BATS I
HAVE HAD, I WAS NEVER GOOD
FOULING A BALL OFF OF MY BODY.
CARLOS, I'M SURE YOU HAVE PLENTY
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THAT FEELS
LIKE.
CARLOS: IN SPANISH, WE CALL IT A
DOG BITE.
LIKE A DOG HAS BITTEN A BIG
PIECE OFF OF YOUR LEG.
IT HURTS LIKE CRAZY.
YOU SEE HIM BACK IN THE BOX BUT
THAT THING IS THROBBING.
SCOTT: UP THE MIDDLE BUT
NOWADAYS THERE IS OFTEN A MAN
THERE.
DEVERS IS RETIRED.
COLLINB FOR TAMPA BAY.
HUGE DAY FOR BOSTON, THOUGH,
DOUBLE-DIGIT HITS FOR A THIRD
CONSECUTIVE GAME.
9-1, SOX.
>> THE DEFENDING ROW CHAMPIONS
ARE TEACHING ON THE BRINK OF
ELIMINATION TONIGHT.
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL HEY
METOO LEFT FIELD.
B.J. UPTON HITS ANOTHER HOME
RUN!
>> THE POWER SURGE FOR THE RAYS
CONTINUES.
>> 5-0 FOR THE THIRD GAME IN A
ROW FOR THE RAYS.
THEY HAVE FIVE ON THE BOARD BY
THE THIRD INNING.
>> HE HAS HAD A COMING OUT PARTY
THIS YEAR IN THE ALCS.
>> THAT IS OFF THE MONSTER AND A
DOUBLE FOR UPTON!
>> THE RAYS MAY BE FINISHING UP
THE RED SOX HERE IN THE SEVENTH
INNING.
>> RED SOX FINALLY GET ON THE
BOARD.
ORTIZ, HIGH FLY BALL RIGHT
FIELD.
IT WILL COME DOWN AS A THREE-RUN
HOME RUN!
>> SWING AND A DRIVE, ONE-RUN
GAME!
>> LINE DRIVE, BASE HIT.
THE RED SOX HAVE TIED IT!
>> J.D. DREW WITH A CHANCE TO
WIN THIS ONE FOR THE SOX.
>> LINE DRIVE RIGHT FIELD!
WE ARE GOING TO TAMPA!
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
SCOTT: WE ARE BACK IN BOSTON.
RED SOX UP BIG.
TIME FOR OUR NEXT FALL QUESTION,
WHICH PLAYER HAS THE BEST DANCE
MOVES?
AROZARENA AND BRETT PHILLIPS PUT
ON A SHOW LAST YEAR.
KIKÉ HERNANDEZ ON THE LIST, AND
SO IS ANDREW MCCUTCHEN.
THIS IS A GOOD ONE.
I WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN IMPACT
THE VOTE.
JOHN, I WANT AN EARLY PICK.
CARLOS, FIRST, ACTUALLY.
WE WILL SEE HOW THINGS GO IN
ABOUT AN INNING AFTER WE GET THE
RESULTS.
CARLOS: I HAVE TO GO WITH
AROZARENA.
YOU SAW AN EARLIER PIECE IN
TODAY'S SHOW, HE WAS BREAKING IT
DOWN, SCOTTY.
I THINK HE HAS THE BEST DANCE
MOVES IN THE LEAGUE.
SCOTT: HERE IS KEVIN PRADO,
DEBUTED YESTERDAY, CALLED UP FOR
KEVIN KIERMAIER, WHO IS ON THE
SHELF.
SMOLTZY, YOUR SELECTION?
JOHN: SAME PICK.
CARLOS: THERE HE IS.
SCOTT: HE HAS THE HAIRDO TO GO
ALONG WITH IT.
CARLOS: JUST NO REASON TO DANCE
JUST YET WITH A 9-1 DEFICIT.
LOOKING TO CHANGE THINGS HERE.
JOHN: THAT PITCH WAS ON THE
HITTERS SO FAST, I DON'T THINK
HE HAD A CHANCE TO SWING AT IT.
THAT WILL BE VIEWED AS A GOOD
TAKE.
I WILL QUESTION.
I DON'T THINK HE HAD A CHANCE.
SCOTT: AND HE WORKS A WALK.
LET'S RUN THROUGH OUR
CANDIDATES.
ANDREW MCCUTCHEN.
CARLOS: LET'S BREAK IT DOWN.
SCOTT: THE VETERAN.
GIVE US THE BREAKDOWN.
CARLOS: KIKÉ RIGHT HERE, VERY
PECULIAR MOVES.
AROZARENA, HE EVEN RAPS, HAS
SOME LYRICS BEHIND THAT DANCE.
I JUST THINK AROZARENA BRINGS
MORE TO THE EQUATION.
KIKÉ'S CIRCULAR MOTION, I'M NOT
A BIG FAN OF THAT.
THE ONE GIVING HIM GOOD
COMPETITION, IT HAS TO BE
MCCUTCHEN.
SCOTT: MIKE BROSSEAU BOUNCING
INTO TWO.
JOHN: THAT IS A BIGGER PITCH
THAN WE ARE GOING TO GIVE CREDIT
FOR.
HE IS AT 90.
THAT DOUBLE PLAY WITH TWO OUTS
IN THE SEVENTH GIVES HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PITCH THE EIGHTH
FAIRLY EASY.
TALKING TO ALEX CORA, THAT WOULD
BE A DREAM SCENARIO, EVEN THOUGH
IT IS EARLY IN THE YEAR.
THE PITCHING STAFFS OF BASEBALL
WILL BE USED AT THE HIGHEST RATE
EVER I THINK THIS YEAR BECAUSE
OF THE FEAR OF LAST YEAR'S SHORT
SEASON AND THE UNKNOWN WHO WILL
BE ABLE TO PITCH INNINGS THIS
YEAR.
SCOTT: MEJIA, WEAK GROUND BALL.
LOOK AT NATE EOVALDI.
EXCELLENT DAY.
FIRST PITCHING IN A TIGHT GAME.
NOW IT IS ALL RED SOX AND HE
STILL HAS BOSTON, 9, TAMPA BAY,.
LET'S STRETCH.
>> THE RAYS IN THE BOSTON RED
SOX GETTING READY TO PLAY GAME
SIX OF THE AMERICAN LEAGUE J.B.
CHIP SERIES.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN PRETTY GOOD IN
THESE SITUATIONS IN THE PAST.
>> UPTON SWINGS AND HE CRUSHES
ONE HIGH AND DEEP TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
1-0 TAMPA BAY.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE BY
YOUKILIS, DEEP INTO CENTER
FIELD.
THAT BALL IS GONE!
KEVIN YOUKILIS HAS TIED THE
GAME.
>> GROUND BALL UP THE MIDDLE.
THEY MAKE THE PLAY AT FIRST BUT
PEDROIA SCORES.
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL.
THAT WILL GO, HOME RUN!
>> JASON BARTLETT HAS TIED THE
GAME.
>> RIGHT CENTER FIELD, IT IS
BACK AT THE WALL.
IT IS GONE!
>> DRIVE INTO RIGHT CENTER THAT
IS IN THERE, BASE HIT.
>> 4-2, BOSTON.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> LINE DRIVE CAUGHT BY
YOUKILIS.
THERE IS A GAME SEVEN TOMORROW
NIGHT!
♪
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
THE RED SOX ALL OVER THE RAYS
TODAY, FINISHING A THREE-GAME
SERIES, BOSTON GOING FOR THE
SWEEP.
RED SOX FANS, THIS IS AN INSIDE
LOOK.
CHECK OUT YOUTUBE.COM/REDSOX.
BE SURE TO SUBSCRIBE FOR ALL OF
THE LATEST VIDEOS.
MARTINEZ, BOGAERTS, VAZQUEZ DUE
UP FOR THE SOX.
BACK TO WORK IN THE SEVENTH.
J.D. WITH A HEALTHY DOSE OF
DOUBLES SO FAR THIS SEASON,
ABOUT A WEEK'S WORTH OF GAMES.
JOHN: YOU CANNOT SAY THIS FOR
EVERY TEAM AND EVERY PLAYER.
IT WAS ESSENTIAL FOR THE RED SOX
TO HAVE A GOOD FEELING ABOUT
THEIR FIRST 14 GAMES.
AFTER GOING 0-3 IN THEIR FIRST
THREE, YOU COULD JUST START TO
HEAR WHAT THE SEASON WAS GOING
TO BE LIKE, WHAT THEY ARE
WRITING ABOUT, THE PRESSURE AND
ALL THE THINGS.
THIS TURNAROUND IS HUGE FOR THE
RED SOX.
NOT FOR EVERY TEAM.
EVERY T CAN RELATE -- TEAM CAN
RELY ON THE BALANCE AND STRENGTH
OF THE ROSTER.
THE RED SOX ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
PIECE THIS TOGETHER FROM A
PITCHING STANDPOINT ALL YEAR.
OFFENSIVELY, I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO BE OK.
I HAVE BEEN INTO MANY CLUBHOUSES
WHERE YOU SENSE, WE HAVE GOT TO
WIN THIS GAME.
IT IS ONLY GAME SEVEN.
NO, WE HAVE GOT TO TURN IT
AROUND.
THE FEELING YOU HAVE LEAVING
SPRING TRAINING AND THE FEELING
YOU HAD LAST YEAR WAS NOT A GOOD
ONE FROM A RED SOX NATION
STANDPOINT AND FOR THE PLAYERS.
SCOTT: IT IS NOT LIKE THE
DODGERS.
IF THE DODGERS DID NOT START
WELL -- THAT IS JOSEPH ODOM, BY
THE WAY, A NEW CATCHER,
INFIRMITY A.
-- IN FOR MEJIA.
JOHN: THE RED SOX ARE BUILT ON A
SYSTEM THAT HAS TO RELY ON
WORKPIECES, BECAUSE --
FINANCIALLY, THE RAYS ARE NOT IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF SOME OF THE
OTHER CLUBS.
THE RED SOX, I'M NOT GOING TO
SAY IT IS A TOTAL REBUILD,
BECAUSE IT IS NOT THE CASE, BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THEY CAME
FROM AND WHERE THEY ARE NOW, A
SHELL OF THEMSELVES FROM A
PITCHING STANDPOINT.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIND
SOME DIAMONDS IN THE ROUGH, SOME
PERFORMANCES THEY DID NOT SEE
COMING, FOR THEM TO BE
COMPETITIVE ALL YEAR IN A
DIVISION THAT HAS ARGUABLY
GOTTEN BETTER THIS YEAR WITH
WHAT THE RAYS DID LAST YEAR,
WITH THE JAYS DID IN THE
OFF-SEASON.
CARLOS: IT IS A POPULAR TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE LOWER --
SCOTT: AT HIS CORDERO TO RIGHT
FIELD, FIELD AND ON A BOUNCE BY
BROSSEAU, WHO RECENTLY CHECKED
INTO THE GAME.
CORDERO CONTRIBUTES A SINGLE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MIKED UP PLAYER,
THE MAN WHO IS ABOUT TO STEP UP,
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ.
CHRISTIAN COLON LET'S GO, BABY.
-- CHRISTIAN: LET'S GO, BABY.
JOHN: I'M SO SCARED OF THOSE
ELBOW FAKES.
SCOTT: EVER SINCE CODY
BELLINGER.
JOHN: THERE ARE SOME STRONG
DONKEYS.
THEY COULD TAKE MY SHOULDER
RIGHT OFF.
SCOTT: IT DID TO CODY BELLINGER
LAST YEAR.
SEPARATED HIS SHOULDER.
CARLOS: VAST COST DID NOT SAY
MUCH EXCEPT FOR BARMES, LET'S
GO.
IT IS UNIVERSAL.
EVERY LANGUAGE UNDERSTANDS THE
CRACK OF THE BAT, RIGHT?
THAT WAS LOUD.
SCOTT: PERFECT TRANSLATION AS
USUAL, CARLOS.
YOU CAN TRANSLATE SPANISH,
BASEBALL BAT.
CARLOS: YES, I KNOW HOW TO SPEED
THAT LANGUAGE.
SCOTT: AND YOU DID IT WELL FOR
MANY YEARS.
CARLOS: MY FAVORITE.
SCOTT: CORDERO ON FOR VAZQUEZ.
BY THE WAY, WE ARE GOING TO GET
A LOT MORE OF THAT AUDIO.
HERE IS YOUR TEASER, JOHN.
A SHOW CALLED "PLAY LOUD IS
COMING SOON, ALL THE PLAYERS
MIKE UP.
FANS ALWAYS SAY, WHAT DID HE SAY
THERE?
GETTING A LOT MORE OF THAT ON
YOUTUBE.
STAY TUNED.
IT IS NOT THIS GAME, BUT KEEP AN
EYE ON MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
JOHN: I WAS MICED UP IN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP TOUR U.S. OPEN I
BRIEFLY PLAYED HIM.
SCOTT: HOW DID THAT GO?
JOHN: IT DID NOT GO WELL FOR ME,
BUT I WANTED TO GIVE A
PERSPECTIVE TO PEOPLE WHO SIT AT
HOME, SAYING, I COULD HAVE SHOT
THAT.
I COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
NO, YOU COULD NOT, AND NO, YOU
WON'T.
BUT IT WAS -- A LOT OF THE
PLAYERS ON THE TOUR ACTUALLY
SUGGESTED I SHOULD NOT DO IT.
I SAID, LISTEN.
I REALLY DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
MAKE THE CUT.
THIS IS AN UNBELIEVABLE
EXPERIENCE, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THRILLS OF MY LIFETIME.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE TO
PEOPLE WHAT IT IS LIKE, BECAUSE
A LOT OF SPORTS ARE STARTING TO
GET MORE INTEGRATED WITH
TECHNOLOGY WHERE YOU CAN HEAR
THAT BANTER, THE TALK BETWEEN
YOU AND YOUR CADDIE.
AND OBVIOUSLY, BEING ON T.V., I
KNEW WHICH LINES WERE GOING TO
GET ON T.V. AND WHICH WERE NOT.
BUT I WAS SINCERE.
I WAS NOT TRYING TO MAKE THEM UP
FOR THE SAKE OF THAT.
I REMEMBER THE ONE TIME -- I RAN
INTO BOGEY AFTER BOGEY, AND I
SAID TO MY CADDIE, I CANNOT
BELIEVE THE MANAGER IS LEAVING
ME IN THIS GAME.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
HOW COULD THEY NOT BRING IN THE
LEFTY?
BUT IN GOLF, YOU DON'T GET TO
COME OUT.
SCOTT: IT IS ALL ON YOU, BUT
THAT IS WHERE YOU LOVE THE GAME.
JOHN: I DO LOVE IT.
CARLOS: THE MANAGER PROBABLY
LEFT YOU IN BECAUSE HE KNOWS IT
COULD GET WORSE.
IF IT WAS ME, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
BOGEY, DOUBLE BOGEY.
WE WILL LEAVE MOLSON, NO
PROBLEM.
-- LEAVE SMOLTZ IN, NO PROBLEM.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD BE OUR MANAGER
CALLING US.
JOHN: I NEVER EXPERIENCED THIS
IN MY BASEBALL CAREER.
I WAS NEVER NERVOUS TO THE POINT
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO SWALLOW OR
SPIT OR FEEL LIKE I COULD NOT
PERFORM IN BASEBALL.
I STOOD ON THAT FIRST TEE, AND
IT WAS JUST ANXIOUSNESS OF
THINGS THAT I KNEW I WAS NOT AS
TALENTED IN THAT ARENA.
I SET FOR THE FIRST TIME, I CAN
NOW APPRECIATE WHAT OTHER
PLAYERS OR ATHLETES FEEL LIKE
WHEN THEY ARE OUT OF THEIR
ELEMENT.
WHEN YOUR OUT OF YOUR COMFORT
ZONE, IT CAUSES A BREATHING
PROBLEM, EXECUTION PROBLEM.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
HAVING TO TALK YOURSELF INTO
CERTAIN THINGS.
IT WAS A VALUABLE TEACHING
LESSON FOR ME, EVEN THOUGH MY
PLAYING CAREER WAS DONE.
I WAS SO THANKFUL THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN TO ME AS A PLAYER.
YOU KNOW, FOR WHATEVER IT IS
WORTH, WHENEVER I CAN PLAY GOLF,
IT WILL CERTAINLY BE BETTER THE
NEXT TIME I'M IN THAT SITUATION.
SCOTT: RENFROE BROKE HIS BAT.
MCHUGH COVERS FOR THE OUT.
OR THE SEVENTH.
THE RED SOX HAVE MORE SCORING
AGAINST TAMPA BAY TODAY.
>> HERE IS PEDROIA.
>> THAT BALL IS GONE.
A HOME RUN.
THE RED SOX LEAD.
>> BUSTER.
TRULY ONE OF THE LEAGUE'S BEST
WHEN HE IS GOT -- WHEN HE IS ON.
>> HERE IS MATT GARZA FOR THE
RAYS.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
STRIKE AT SIX.
>> WIND DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
IT WILL STAY FAIR.
>> HERE COMES PEDROIA.
NOT IN TIME.
THE RAYS HAVE TIED IT UP.
>> THE RAYS LEAD.
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL WAY
BACK.
IT IS GONE!
.
>> BASES LOADED FOR BOSTON IN
THE EIGHTH INNING.
TWO OUTS.
>> THE SEASON ON THE LINE, IN
THE HANDS OF DAVID PRICE.
>> CHECK SWING.
AND THE RED SOX LEAVE THE BASES
LOADED IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
>> JED LOWRIE, THE FINAL HOPE
FOR BOSTON TONIGHT.
GROUND BALL TO SECOND.
THE BRAVES ARE GOING TO THE
WORLD SERIES!
CARLOS: -- ALANNA: WE WELCOME
YOU BACK TO FENWAY PARK.
NIKE AND SEVERAL MLB CLUBS HAVE
COME TOGETHER FOR CITY CONNECT
JERSEYS.
WE ALL KNOW A COUPLE LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THE
PLAYERS WEEKEND JERSEYS.
NOW, A DIFFERENT ELEMENT IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH YOUR CITY, DEVELOPED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MLB CLUBS, THE
NIKE CITY CONNECT SERIES.
IT CELEBRATES THE BOND BETWEEN
EACH CLUB AND ITS CITY.
THESE ARE THE ONES THE BOSTON
RED SOX ARE GOING TO BE WEARING
ON PATRIOTS' DAY.
THE BOSTON MARATHON WEEKEND.
THEY POSTPONED IT THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF COVID.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE IN
OCTOBER, BUT THE INAUGURAL
SEASON OF THE CITY CONNECT WILL
FEATURE SEVEN CLUBS RIGHT NOW --
THE DIAMONDBACKS, THE RED SOX,
THE CUBS, THE WHITE SOX, THE
DODGERS, THE MARLINS, AND THE
GIANTS.
AND HOPEFULLY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS, ALL OF
THE TEAMS WILL HAVE THESE CITY
CONNECT JERSEYS.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
BOSTON RED SOX AND UCLA, GUYS.
SCOTT: I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
BOYLSTON STREET FINISH LINE,
GOLD AND BLUE.
UNIQUE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF NEW AND
CRANNIES TO THIS UNIQUE AS WELL.
THE 617 AREA CODE.
HERE WE GO.
POOR CARLOS.
I WILL MAIL YOU ONE, OK?
CARLOS: THANK YOU GUYS.
I'M FEELING SO LEFT OUT.
THOSE ARE BEAUTIFUL.
THEY LOOK REALLY COOL.
SCOTT: I LOVE THE HATS.
JOHN: I'M PARTIAL TO HATS FOR A
LOT OF REASONS.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: REALLY WELL DONE.
617.
CARLOS: AREA CODE.
SCOTT: YOUR CHILD IN THE AREA.
CARLOS: YES.
SCOTT: BUT ALSO IT IS THE FINISH
LINE SKETCH FIELD TO BOSTON.
JOHN: SHARP.
IT DOES HAVE THE UCLA FEEL.
SCOTT: VERY UNIQUE COLORS FOR
BASEBALL.
I WAS JUST TALKING TO BUCK
SHOWALTER THE OTHER DAY ABOUT
UNIQUE BASEBALL UNIFORM COLORS.
THOSE WERE TWO OF THE COLORS WE
BROUGHT OUT.
YOU DO NOT SEE A LOT OF YELLOW
AND YOU DO NOT SEE A LOT OF THAT
SHADE OF BLUE.
TO SEE THAT COMBINATION IS
UNIQUE AND HAS TIES TO THE
ICONIC WEEKEND IN BOSTON.
PATRIOTS' DAY COMING UP.
CLEVER, CREATIVE.
LOVE IT.
YOU CAN GRAB THOSE ON SALE SOON.
JOHN: IT IS AMAZING, GOING
THROUGH MY -- WHEN YOU SELL YOUR
HOUSE, YOU GO THROUGH EVERYTHING
YOU ACQUIRED.
YOU ACQUIRE MORE THAN YOU EVER
NEED.
I WENT TO MY MEMORABILIA ROOM,
AND I JUST FORGOT.
21 YEARS IS A LONG TIME.
I FORGOT HOW MANY DIFFERENT
JERSEYS I PITCHED HIM.
THE AMOUNT OF JERSEYS, THE
THROWBACKS, ALL THE DIFFERENT
STYLES.
I MEAN, NOW IT IS --
SCOTT: IT IS NOT LIKE YOU
PITCHED FOR A MILLION TEAMS.
JOHN: I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT
WITH THE ATLANTA BRAVES.
SCOTT: DONNA'S, EASY FLY BALL
FOR J.D. MARTINEZ, MOVING ACROSS
THE OUTFIELD NOW.
WE HAVE A POLE RESULT COMING
YOUR WAY, BEST DANCE MOVES.
KIKÉ HERNANDEZ WINS.
BOSTON SHOWING UP IN A BIG WAY.
BOSTON PLAYERS DOMINATING.
SO IS THERE TEAM.
ALANNA, YOU COVERED KIKÉ
HERNANDEZ FOR YEARS WITH THE
DODGERS.
WOULD HE TAKE YOUR VOTE AS WELL?
ALANNA: I MEAN, I CAN ONLY SAY
YES, BECAUSE I SPENT THE LAST
SIX YEARS COVERING HIM AS FAR AS
HIS DANCE MOVES AND HIS
SHENANIGANS IN THE DUGOUT.
OFTENTIMES, I WOULD BE DOING MY
PREGAME, PRE-FIRST PITCH HIT,
AND HE WOULD BE BEHIND ME DOING
ALL THESE DIFFERENT SHENANIGANS.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY A CHARACTER.
THEY USED TO BE DANCE OFFS
BETWEEN HE AND YASIEL PUIG.
TO HAVE THE PUERTO RICAN AND THE
CUBAN GOING AT IT IN THE DUGOUT
-- I CANNOT SAY THE OTHER THREE
ARE NOT GOOD.
THAT I HAVE NOT HAD AS MUCH
EXPERIENCE COVERING THOSE DANCE
MOVES.
SCOTT: KIKÉ STEALS THE SHOW,
SOMETIMES LITERALLY, JUMPING ON
SCREEN WHEN YOU LEAST EXPECT
HIM.
HE IS FUN.
HE IS VERSATILE.
TSUTSUGO TO FIRST.
JOHN: THE PITCHER WANTED NO PART
OF THAT.
YEAH.
SCOTT: THIS IS JOSH TAYLOR, IN
RELIEF OF NATE EOVALDI.
THAT IS A LOOK AT YOUR DEFENSIVE
SET UP.
THE SHIFT IS ON.
THEY HAVE REALLY SWITCHED THINGS
UP IN THE OUTFIELD.
MARTIN -- MARTINEZ FROM LEFT TO
RIGHT.
RENFROE PLAYING CENTER, STILL
WITH THE SAME INFIELD TO START
THE DAY.
ARROYO AT SECOND.
DOBNAK AT FIRST.
KIKÉ HERNANDEZ AT SHORT.
JOHN: THAT IS WHERE THE RED SOX
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GET USED TO
POSITIONING AND PLAYING DEFENSE
A LITTLE BETTER THAN THEY ARE
USED TO.
THEY HAD AN OUTFIELD NOT LONG
AGO THAT WAS AS GOOD AS ANYBODY,
AND NONE OF THOSE GUYS ARE HERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT J.D. PLAYING
OUTFIELD, RENFROE PLAYING
OUTFIELD.
HE HAS GOT A CANNON, BUT THE
PARK, OTHER THAN IN COLORADO,
DON'T THINK THERE IS A MORE
IMPORTANT PARK TO PLAY DEFENSE,
OUTFIELD WISE, THEN FENWAY.
THERE IS SO MUCH ROOM FROM
CENTER TO RIGHT.
THE LEFT IS ITS OWN PROBLEM.
IT WILL BE VERY INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW ALEX CORA NAVIGATES THAT
PART OF THEIR CLUB, AND WHETHER
THAT TRANSLATES INTO SOME OF
THEIR SUCCESS OR FAILURE AT THE
END OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: YOU THINK BACK TO 2018,
WHEN THEY WANTED ALL.
THEY HAD THREE CENTER FIELDERS
OUT THERE.
JOHN: PEOPLE USED TO SAY IF YOU
HAD TO DRAFT A RIGHT FIELDER
BETWEEN AARON JUDGE AND MOOKIE
BETTS BACK IN THE DAY, IT
DEPENDS WHERE THEY ARE PLAYING.
I'M TAKING MOOKIE BETTS AT
FENWAY.
BUT I'M TAKING AARON JUDGE IN
YANKEE STADIUM.
MOOKIE BETTS IN YANKEE STADIUM,
THE IMPACT IS NOT THE SAME.
SCOTT: DOLL BACK --E FOR HIMSELT
BASE.
JOSH TAYLOR SENT DOWN THE SIDE
IN ORDER.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> HE IS HANGING TOUGH.
WHAT AN AT-BAT.
>> BETTER AND BETTER.
SENDS ONE INTO LEFT FIELD.
IT IS UP AND GONE.
MIKE BROSSEAU ARE -- HAS
HOMERED, AND THE RAYS HAVE A 2-1
LEAD.
>> HERE IS A SHOT INTO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
THIS BALL IS BACK AT THE WALL.
AND THE ALL-TIME RECORD FOR MOST
OUTS IN A SINGLE POSTSEASON WITH
NUMBER NINE.
THAT BALL WAS TATTOOED.
>> A STRIKE AWAY.
1-2 PITCH.
AND PHILLIPS HAS CASHED IN! A
BASE HIT MIDDLE.
HERE IS KIERMAIER TO SCORE.
AND NOW THAT GOT AROZARENA IN A
RUNDOWN! THEY HAVE WON THE GAME.
SANTA MARIA!
SCOTT: WHO DO YOU THINK WILL
DOMINATE THE 21 -- 2021 SEASON?
MAKE YOUR PICKS AND COMPETE TO
WIN $50,000.
SEE RULES AND ENTER AT MLB.COM.
AND DOWN LOAD THE MLB APP TO GET
IN GAME HIGHLIGHTS, LIVE PITCH
BY PITCH, BREAKING NEWS, AND
MUCH MORE.
GOT TO LOVE THE APP.
AND IT IS OUR FIRST GAME OF THE
SEASON LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY TODAY.
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN SMOLTZ, CARLOS
PENA, AND ALANNA RIZZO WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON.
BOSTON WELL ON THEIR WAY TO
SWEEP CITY.
A VERY TALENTED TAMPA BAY TEAM.
AFTER BEING SWEPT BY THE ORIOLES
TO OPEN UP THEIR SEASON, THAT IS
BASEBALL.
JOHN: IT IS, BUT THAT IS ALSO
HAD DELICATE THE MENTAL SIDE OF
THIS GAME CAN BE.
BECAUSE OF THE TWISTS AND TURNS,
AND JUST THE NARRATIVE CHANGES
-- I USED TO LAUGH ABOUT OPENING
WEEK.
EVERY YEAR, TALK RADIO, YOU COME
OUT -- THE GREATEST TEAM I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
"THIS TEAM IS DONE."
YOU CANNOT MAKE ANY DEFINITIVE
STATEMENT UNTIL 21 DAYS.
IN 30 DAYS, THAT IS THE TEAM YOU
ARE GOING TO BE.
IT IS RARE -- THIS IS WHAT I
ALWAYS THINK.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR WHAT CARLOS
THINKS AS A FORMER PLAYER.
YOU LEAVE SPRING TRAINING, YOU
KNOW THE WORDS OF YOUR TEAM.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT YOUR
TEAM.
YOU JUST HOPE THEY DON'T GET
EXPOSED EARLY ENOUGH.
SO THE COMBAT OF THE TEAMS THAT
ARE THE BEST AND THE ONES THAT
HAVE THE LEAST EFFICIENCIES,
THEY COVER.
BUT DURING THAT WHOLE RUN WE
HAD, WE KNEW ONE THING WAS
CONSTANT.
WE ARE GOING TO OUT PITCH YOU.
CAN WE PLAY GOOD ENOUGH DEFENSE,
SCORE ENOUGH RUNS?
I ALWAYS THINK THE BREAK BETWEEN
SPRING TRAINING AND REGULAR
SEASON, THE IDENTITY OF YOUR
TEAM -- WHAT IS IT?
DOES IT IMPROVE?
DOES IT GET EXPOSED?
CARLOS: IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU NOTE EXACTLY
WHAT YOUR STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES ARE.
IN A LONG SEASON, 162 GAMES, IF
YOU HAVE WEAKNESSES, THEY WILL
BE EXPOSED FOR SURE.
AND WITH THE RAYS, THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO WHEEL AND DEAL.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
UTILIZE THEIR 26 PLAYERS.
SCOTT: ARROYO FLIES OUT TO LEFT.
CARLOS: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAY
THEY GO ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS, IT
IS JUST TRY TO BE
COST-EFFECTIVE.
IT IS A LITTLE MARKET TEAM.
THE RAYS, THEY DECLINED CHARLIE
MORTON'S $50 MILLION OFFER, YOU
KNOW?
BUT THEY SIGNED CHRIS, RICH
HILL, AND MICHAEL WACHA FOR A
COMBINED $12 MILLION.
FOR LESS, THEY ARE GETTING 341.
THAT IS THE WAY THEY OPERATE.
THESE GUYS COULD BE
CONTRIBUTORS.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN
THE MIX SOMEHOW, SOMEWAY.
TALKING ABOUT THE IDENTITY OF
THE BALLCLUB, THAT IS THEIR
IDENTITY.
THEY NEED ALL 26 PLAYERS TO
CONTRIBUTE SOMEHOW, SOMEWAY.
SCOTT: BIG CUT AND A MISS FROM
BOBBY DALBEC.
TOOK THE LEAGUE BY STORM LAST
YEAR.
EIGHT HOME RUNS AND 23 GAMES.
BURST OF STRENGTH.
0-10 IN THE FIRST SERIES AGAINST
BALTIMORE.
DID NOT START THE LAST TWO
GAMES.
BUT HE WAS COMING OFF A HOT
SPRING, SEVEN HOME RUNS.
HE LED THE GRAPEFRUIT LEAGUE.
CARLOS, YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THAT
IS A GOOD THING AND SOMETIMES IT
DOES NOT MEAN MUCH.
CARLOS: RIGHT, I MEAN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
IS A LONG SEASON.
MAYBE IT GETS A GOOD START AND
DOES NOT MEAN MUCH OR A BAD
START AND DOESN'T MEAN MUCH.
WHAT WOULD WE PREFER?
WE PREFER TO GET OFF TO GOOD
STARTS.
SCOTT: A GOOD GAME FOR DALBEC,
HIS SECOND HIT OF THE DAY.
AND YOU HAVE HAD SOME SPRINGS
WHEN YOU WERE TEARING IT UP AND
THEN YOU START SLOW, RIGHT?
AND YOU HAVE HAD SOME SPRINGS
WHERE YOU COULD NOT FIND IT, AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU FOUND IT
JUST IN TIME FOR OPENING DAY.
CARLOS: YES, I HAVE TWO EXAMPLES
OF THAT WHICH COME IMMEDIATELY
TO MIND -- MY ROOKIE SEASON WITH
THE OAKLAND A'S, IN 2002 -- I'M
SHOWING MY AGE.
I HAD A HORRIBLE SPRING
TRAINING, HORRIBLE.
AS SOON AS THE BELL RUNG, THE
LIGHTS WERE ON, IN THE SEASON
STARTED, I WENT OFF.
I HAD AN UNBELIEVABLE APRIL AND
I ONE ROOKIE OF THE MONTH WITH
SEVEN HOME RUNS.
THAT IS A BULLET.
SCOTT: OFF THE BAT OF KEVIN
PLAWECKI AND INTO RIGHT CENTER
FIELD.
TWO DOWN FOR BOSTON.
I JUST HAVE TO SNEAK THIS IN.
THE COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM.
THE ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
THAT IS SIGNED, SEALED, AND
DELIVERED.
BACK TO YOU.
CARLOS: YES, AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE
WAS IN 2013.
2012, ACTUALLY.
I HAD A HORRIBLE SPRING
TRAINING.
WE ARE STARTING AT HOME AGAINST
THE YANKEES.
JOE MADDON TOLD ME, LOOK, IT IS
GOING TO BE CC SABATHIA ON THE
MOUND.
YOU DON'T SEE HIM WELL.
LAST TIME UP, HE BROKE YOUR
HAND.
DO YOU WANT TO PLAY?
SCOTT: DOUBLE PLAY MADE.
CARLOS: HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
WE WILL GET BACK WITH YOU.
SCOTT: COLLIN MCHUGH HUGHES UPTE
AND THEY WILL BE ON THEIR WAY.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> HE WILL GO AFTER THAT ONE AND
DRIVE THAT ONE HIGH.
IT IS DEEP TO LEFT, AND THAT
BALL IS GONE.
THERE IS NUMBER TWO.
HE DID NOT WAIT LONG.
DON'T YOU THINK THE RED SOX HAVE
TO MAKE SURE HE IS IN THE LINEUP
EVERY DAY?
THAT BALL IS HAMMERED.
THAT IS A HIGH FLY BALL.
VERDUGO STRIKES AGAIN.
THAT IS A WAY TO ADD ON.
PER THAN THE FIRST ONE.
ALSO TO THE OPPOSITE FIELD.
THERE IS A HIGH FLY BALL DRIVEN
DEEP TO RIGHT.
VERDUGO BACK TO THE PEN.
LEAPS UP.
HE CAUGHT IT.
HE CAUGHT THE BALL.
HE TOOK IT BACK.
>> WHAT A NIGHT.
WHAT A NIGHT.
>> IT IS GONE.
OPPOSITE FIELD.
HOME RUN, DALBEC.
HE TIES A RED SOX RECORD.
HE DID NOT GET HOME.
BUT HE IS SO STRONG HE JUMPED.
SCOTT: WE ARE ABOUT TO BEGIN A
GRAND TRADITION, THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
LOOKING AT SOME CANDIDATE
SURROUNDING BY THE TROPHY --
SURROUNDED BY THE TROPHY.
I LOVE THE PLAY BUTTON AT THE
TOP.
YOU WILL SEE THAT TROPHY IN THE
HANDS OF ONE BIG MAN FROM THIS
GAME.
IT COULD BE THAT GUY, J.D.
MARTINEZ.
WHO IS YOUR CHOICE FOR PLAYER OF
THE GAME IF YOU ARE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW?
WEIGH IN.
BOGAERTS, MARTIN IS.
WE WILL GET BACK TO THAT IN A
SECOND, BECAUSE THAT SKIPS OFF
THE WALL AND IT IS BOBBLED AT
CENTER FOR A MOMENT BY RENFROE.
IT TURNS INTO A DOUBLE BY
AROZARENA TO LEAD OFF THE NINTH.
AGAIN, BOGAERTS, MARTINEZ,
EOVALDI, VAZQUEZ.
IT HAS TO BE A RED SOX.
IT IS 9-1 IN THE NINTH.
WINNER HOLDS THE TROPHY AND
CHATS WITH US AFTER THE GAME.
CHOICES?
JOHN SMOLTZ, YOU START US OFF.
JOHN: I PICKED BOGAERTS BEFORE
THE GAME.
HARD TO GO AGAINST A EOVALDI
WITH HOW HE WAS ABLE TO DOMINATE
THE RACE FOR SEVEN INNINGS.
I WOULD SAY IT IS BETWEEN THOSE
TWO.
SCOTT: I'M GOING TO MAKE YOU
SELECT A CHOICE.
JOHN: EOVALDI.
SCOTT: I KNOW THAT IS THE
GRINDING YOUR HEAD.
HE WAS A PITCHER AND WAS
IMPRESSIVE.
CARLOS?
WHAT YOU THINK?
CARLOS: I'M IN A GO WITH OF ALL
THE.
-- ABEL THE.
OF COURSE I PICKED J.D. MARTINEZ
EARLY IN THE GAME, BUT YOU
CANNOT ARGUE WITH THE
OUTSTANDING OUTING THAT AOL THE
-- EOVALDI JUST HAD.
SCOTT: HE RECORDED STRIKEOUTS
WITH ALL OF HIS PITCHES AND YOU
RARELY SEE THAT.
JOHN: HE IS SO IMPORTANT TO
THEIR ROTATION AS THEY GET
RODRIGUEZ BACK.
MAYBE SALE.
THEY HAVE MADE NICE UNDER THE
RADAR MOVES TO FILL IN THIS
ROTATION.
I GUARANTEE MOST PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
SCOTT: THAT IS FOR DEVERS.
THE SOX ARE TWO OUTS AWAY FROM A
SWEEP OF THE RAYS.
CARLOS: I'VE GOT TO FINISH MY
STORY.
SCOTT: YES, QUICKLY.
CARLOS: I KNOW, I GOT TO HURRY.
I DID NOT HAVE A GOOD SPRING
TRAINING AND I WAS NOT STARTING
AGAINST CC SABATHIA.
AS SOON AS I GOT TO THE
BALLPARK, JOE MADDON CHANGED HIS
MIND AND PUT ME IN THE LINEUP.
I ACTUALLY ENDED UP WHEN --
HAVING ONE OF THE BEST GAMES IN
THAT YEAR, WITH A GRAND SLAM, A
DOUBLE OFF THE WALL.
I GOT OFF TO A GREAT APRIL.
SO IT DOES NOT MATTER.
SPRING TRAINING DOES NOT MATTER.
SCOTT: CONFIRMED.
YANDY DIAZ BOUNCES OUT.
THAT WAS A NICE HUNCH BY JOE
MADDON BACK THEN.
THERE IS TWO GONE IN THE NINTH.
CARLOS: THAT WORKED OUT.
JOHN: SPRING TRAINING WAS HUGE
FOR ME BECAUSE THAT IS WHEN I
STARTED TO LEARN TO HIT KNOCKED
DOWN SHOTS.
IT IS USUALLY WINDY IN SPRING
TRAINING AND WE GOT A CHANCE TO
PLAY A LOT OF GOLF.
I FELT LIKE I COULD FLIGHT MY
BALL A LOT BETTER WHEN THE
SEASON STARTED, TO CARRY IT
THROUGH.
SO SPRING TRAINING AND MULTIPLE
START -- SCOTT: SPRING TRAINING
IN MULTIPLE SPORTS.
IT WORKED OUT FOR YOU AS WELL.
JOHN: IT WAS HUGE.
SCOTT: KEVIN PADLO LOOKING FOR
HIS FIRST CAREER HIT AS A BIG
LEAGUER.
JOHN: YOUTUBE SPECIAL.
CARLOS: LET'S GO.
SCOTT: HE WILL BE ABLE TO SCROLL
BACK TO IT AND PLAY IT BACK ANY
TIME.
A GOOD TAKE TO START OF YOUR
CAREER IF HE CAN DO IT RIGHT
HERE.
CARLOS: THAT WAS A GOOD PITCH TO
DO IT WITH.
SCOTT: DOWN THE PIPE.
HE DID WALK IN HIS FIRST AT-BAT
OF THE DAY.
NOW I AM REALLY KNOCKED --
LOCKED IN ON THIS MAYBE, MORE SO
THAN I THOUGHT I WOULD BE.
JOHN: HE'S GOT THE GLINT OF HIS
EYES.
HIS OWN RADAR GUN IS IN HIS
HE HAS SEEN A COUPLE OF PITCHES.
HE IS LOOKING FOR A MISTAKE TO
PUT ANOTHER POINT ON THE BOARD.
SCOTT: CALLED UP AND KEVIN
KIERMAIER WAS SENT DOWN.
KIERMAIER ON THE INJURED LIST.
VERY FRUSTRATING, HE SAID,
ESPECIALLY EARLY IN THE SEASON.
QUAD TIGHTNESS IS THE ISSUE FOR
THE RAYS CENTER FIELDER.
JOHN: HARD FOR ME TO NOT SELL
OUT ON THIS PITCH RIGHT HERE.
LIFT CLEAN AND SEPARATE.
SCOTT: GIVE HIM SOMETHING JUICY.
NO, ANOTHER WALK.
WELL, THE RAYS WILL RESPECT
THAT.
THEY LOVE THAT PATIENTS.
JOHN: NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
CARLOS: WE WANTED TO HIT,
SCOTTY.
SCOTT: I'M WITH YOU, LOS.
CARLOS: THERE IS SOMETHING TO BE
SAID ABOUT BEING DISCIPLINED AT
THE PLATE.
BUT JUST A QUICK STORY HERE --
IN THE LITTLE LEAGUE TEAMS WHERE
MY KIDS PLAY, THEY ARE TAKING
WALKS.
I AM LIKE, GUYS, I LOVE THAT YOU
ARE ON BASE, BUT SWING THE BAT.
SWING THE BAT.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT MIKE
BROSSEAU DOES TO LEFT.
OPEN SPACE.
IT IS GOING TO DROP.
IN COMES AROZARENA.
THE RAYS DOUBLE THEIR RUN TOTAL.
MIKE BROSSEAU WITH AN R.B.I.
KNOCK.
PADULA -- PADLO MOWS OVER TO
THIRD.
JOHN: THOSE EAT AT A PITCHER'S
HEART.
YOU WOULD JUST AS SOON HE HIT A
ROCKET OFF THE WALL, THAT HE HIT
A BIG SWING OFF THE END OF THE
BACK -- END OF THE BAT.
I AM SURE THE MIKE PICKED UP --
THE MIC PICKED UP PART OF WHAT
WAS BEING DESCRIBED.
SCOTT: GRASSO WENT AFTER THE
FIRST PITCH IN HIS FIRST AT-BAT
AND DID SO AGAIN HERE.
HE CONNECTS.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING TO POWER
STATCAST, WITH MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF DATA POINTS TO REVEAL NEW
INSIGHTS TAKING YOU DEEPER INTO
THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
JOSEPH ODOM CAME IN TO REPLACE
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
BOSTON IS ONE STRIKE AWAY.
THIS IS AN IMPRESSIVE SERIES
FROM THE RED SOX AFTER BEING
SWEPT BY BALTIMORE.
TAMPA BAY COMES TO TOWN.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN DOMINATING
THIS AFTERNOON AFTER A WALKOFF
WIN LAST NIGHT IN 12.
THE RED SOX COMMENTING WE HAVE A
RULE.
NEVER TALK ABOUT HOW FAST A GAME
IS GOING.
WE ARE A LITTLE SEDITIOUS -- L
ITTLE STITIOUS, NOT
SUPERSTITIOUS.
THE RED SOX ACCOUNT PROVIDING
SOME COMMENTARY FOR US.
CARLOS: THAT IS VERY CREATIVE.
I CAN APPRECIATE THAT.
SCOTT: THE FIREBALL REVIEW
SAYING THE COMEBACK HAS
COMMENCED.
THE WIN PROBABILITY AT THIS
POINT, 99 POINT -- ROLL UP THE
NINES.
CARLOS: SO YOU ARE SAYING
THERE'S A CHANCE?
SCOTT: THAT'S RIGHT.
2-2 TO ODOM.
DID HE GO?
YES, HE DID.
GAME OVER.
RED SOX TAKE THE GAME.
RED SOX SWEEP THE SERIES, 9-2.
ALL SMILES AFTER PUTTING UP
DOUBLE DIGIT HITS IN ALL THREE
GAMES IN THIS SERIES.
BOSTON IMPROVES TO 3-3 ON THIS
YOUNG SEASON.
TAMPA BAY DROPS TO 2-4.
JOHN: TIMELY HITTING.
DID NOT HIT A TON OF ROCKETS,
BUT WHEN IT IS GOING GOOD AND
YOU FEEL THE MOJO, THE RED SOX
WERE ABLE TO RIDE THAT.
OF COURSE, IT IS EASIER TO RIDE
WHEN YOU HAVE A STUD ON THE
MOUND DICTATING OPPOSITE TEMPO
THAN THE FEE -- FOR THE TEAM HE
IS FACING.
SCOTT: IMPRESSIVE PERFORMANCES
THIS SEASON SO FAR FOR NATE
EOVALDI.
TODAY AND ON OPENING DAY AGAINST
BALTIMORE.
THIS TIME, HE PICKS UP THE W.
IT IS TIME FOR THE YOUTUBE
POSTGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
YES, IT IS THAT TIME.
THE YOUTUBE POSTGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN SMOLTZ, CARLOS
PENA, ALANNA RIZZO, AND THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY WILL BE UNVEILED FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER.
HOPING TO BE A GRAND TRADITION.
AND WE WILL GET THAT IN THE
HANDS OF THE WINNER ACCORDING TO
YOU.
FANS GET TO VOTE ON THE POLE
WINNER.
IT ALSO DICTATES WHO WE TALKED
TO AT THE END OF THE GAME.
9-2, BOSTON TAKES IT OVER TAMPA
BAY.
CARLOS, WE KNOW HOW TALENTED
THIS RAYS TEAM IS.
THEY RETURN A LOT OF THE SAME
POSITION PLAYERS FROM LAST YEAR.
DEFENSE WAS ELITE LAST YEAR.
THEY MADE SOME MISTAKES ON
DEFENSE.
AND THEY WERE REALLY SHUT DOWN
BY NATE EOVALDI AND COMPANY.
CARLOS: THEY HAD A TOUGH TIME OF
THE PLATE.
EOVALDI WAS COMING WITH THE HIGH
FASTBALL.
WORKING ON THAT FOUR-SEAMER.
AND THEN THE OFFSPEED.
BUT IT ISN'T ESTABLISHING THE
FASTBALL -- ALL THE OTHER
OFF-SPEED'S BECOME NASTY.
HE DID A GREAT JOB OF THAT.
HIT HER HEAD TO STAY HONEST.
WHEN YOU DO THAT AND YOU KNOW
THERE IS HIGH-SPEED COMING YOUR
WAY, YOU TEND TO RUSH HER
SWINGS, WHICH MAKES YOU MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO OFFSPEED PITCHES.
THEY STRUGGLED ALSO DEFENSIVELY.
JUST NOT THE BEST SHOWING FROM
THE RAYS.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO JUST
SWEEP THIS ONE AND FLUSH IT DOWN
THE TOILET AND GET BACK READY TO
GO TOMORROW.
SCOTT: I HAVE A PRIZE, AIR HUG
OR HIGH-FIVE FOR JOHN OR CARLOS,
BECAUSE YOU BOTH CORRECTLY
SELECTED THE RIGHT ANSWER FOR
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THE FANS AGREE WITH YOU.
NATE EOVALDI STEALS THE SHOW,
DESPITE THE OFFENSIVE EXPLOSION
AGAIN FROM BOSTON.
IT IS THEIR OPENING DAY STARTER.
SHOWS UP AGAIN IN A BIG WAY.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
IS NATE EOVALDI.
JOHN: EARLY ON, HE WAS PROBABLY
A LITTLE MORE RADICAL IN HIS
LOCATION OF HIS FASTBALL.
ONCE HE STARTED THROWING THE
SPINNING BREAKING BALL FOR A
STRIKE, IT LOCKED EVERYTHING
ELSE IN.
HE CLIMBED THE LADDER, PITCHED
UP, AND PITCHED ON EVERY SIDE OF
THE QUADRANT.
HE GOT SOMEBODY OUT WITH EVERY
ONE OF HIS PITCHES.
AS THE RED SOX ROTATION GOES, OF
ALL HE WILL BE THE REASON.
-- EOVALDI WILL BE THE REASON.
SCOTT: HE WAS DOMINANT IN THE
POLL RESULTS.
HE TAKES IT OVER BOGAERTS,
MARTINEZ, AND VAZQUEZ.
FROM A HITTER'S PERSPECTIVE,
WHEN HE IS THROWING FIVE
STRIKEOUT PITCHES AT YOU, THAT
IS GOING TO BE TOUGH TO BEAT.
CARLOS: YOU HAVE TO PICK A ZONE,
PICK A SPEED.
OTHERWISE, IT IS JUST WALKING
INTO AN AMBUSH.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT IS COMING
YOUR WAY.
THE PLAN HAS TO BE ON POINT.
THE RAYS HAD A TOUGH TIME
DEFINING WITH THAT PLAN WAS.
WHATEVER THEY THOUGHT IT WAS, IT
WAS NOT EFFECTIVE TODAY.
SCOTT: WE MENTIONED EOVALDI IS
FROM ALVIN, TEXAS, SAME AS NOLAN
RYAN.
HE SAID YOU CAN SEE THE
MEMORABILIA EVERYWHERE, EVERYONE
TALKS ABOUT HIM.
A GUY WHO COMES FROM TEXAS,
THROWS REALLY HARD.
HAS A DIFFERENT GAME FROM RYAN,
BUT REALLY HAS DEVELOPED OVER
MANY YEARS INTO A SOLID VETERAN.
WHEN HE IS ON THE MOUND, HE IS
REALLY STRONG, AND HE SHOWED
THAT TODAY.
JOHN: HE HAD SOME PHYSICAL
ATTRIBUTES NOLAN RYAN HAD FROM
THE WAIST DOWN.
HE IS SO STRONG.
I DID NOT MIND WORKING OUT WITH
GLAVINE AND MADDUX IN THE WEIGHT
ROOM.
IT MADE ME FEEL GOOD.
THIS GUY IS AS STRONG AS IT
GETS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ABILITY HE
HAS TO GET BEHIND THE BASEBALL
-- THAT IS THE KEY.
WHEN HE GETS BEHIND AT THE TOP
OF THE BASEBALL, THE MOVEMENT
WILL BE THERE AND THE HITTER HAS
A NIGHTMARE TRYING TO DECIPHER
WHAT PITCH IS COMING AT HIM.
.003 OR WHATEVER TIME THE HITTER
HAS TO MAKE UP HIS MIND DECIDING
WHETHER A PITCH IS A STRIKE OR
NOT, IMAGINE WHAT THAT IS LIKE
WHEN YOU ARE FACING EOVALDI.
HE IS ON TOP OF YOU ALREADY,
6'4" FIVE, COMING DOWN THE HILL
WITH A LOW THREE-QUARTER.
WHEN HE IS ON, AS CARLOS HAS
SAID, YOU HAVE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT, WHAT MISTAKE CAN I HIT?
AND WAIT FOR A MISTAKE.
WHEN HE IS ON WITH THE
QUADRANTS, HE CAN DELIVER.
YOU BETTER HIT LIGHTNING QUICK,
MECHANICALLY SOUND, BECAUSE IF
YOU HAVE A BIG SWING, HE IS
GOING TO EAT YOU UP.
SCOTT: YOUTUBE CREATORS, WE HAVE
MANY QUESTIONS FOR NATE.
LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENTARY
SECTION RIGHT NOW.
HERE HE IS.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
NATE, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W.
THERE IT IS, THE TROPHY.
HOLD IT UP FOR US.
DO YOU KNOW THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE ARE EVER DOING THIS,
STARTING A NEW TRADITION HERE
FOR THE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE?
YOU ARE HOLDING THE HARDWARE.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
HOW HEAVY?
HOW DOES IT LOOK?
NATE: IT IS HEAVY.
IT LOOKS GOOD.
PROUD TO HAVE IT.
SCOTT: I LIKE THE DESIGN, THE
HOME PLATE AND THE YOUTUBE PLAY
BUTTON AT THE TOP.
VERY LEGIT.
HOLD IT FOR THE FULL INTERVIEW.
I LIKE IT.
THE DISPLAY SKILLS ARE PERFECT,
AND YOU EARNED THAT.
SO AS YOU ARE CHECKING IT OUT --
AND YOU WILL GET TO TAKE THAT
HOME -- AS YOU ARE WORKING WITH
THAT TROPHY, LET US KNOW HOW YOU
EARNED THAT TROPHY.
EVALUATE WHAT YOU DID TODAY ON
THE MOUND.
NATE: COMING INTO THE GAME, WE
WERE ABLE TO EXECUTE THE PLAN.
IT WORKED OUT WELL.
THE DEFENSE WAS GREAT BEHIND ME.
WE WERE ABLE TO PUT UP SOME
RUNS.
IT IS ALWAYS NICE WHEN YOU CAN
GET A LOT OF RUN SUPPORT IN YOUR
OUTINGS.
I FELT REALLY GOOD OUT THERE.
JOHN: THIS IS JOHN SMOLTZ.
I KNOW WHAT YOUR MINDSET IS.
I LOVE WATCHING YOU PITCH.
BULLDOG ON THE MOUND.
I'M INTERESTED WITH THIS
OFF-SEASON MINDSET, KNOWING
THERE WAS A SHORT SEASON
FOLLOWED BY A REGULAR SEASON OF
162 GAMES.
WHAT DID YOU DO DIFFERENTLY?
OR DID NOTHING MATTER TO YOU
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE
TRAINED YOUR WHOLE LIFE TO DO AS
FAR AS PITCHING A LOT OF
INNINGS?
NATE: HONESTLY, I DID NOT CHANGE
MUCH.
I GOT GOING AROUND THE NORMAL
TIME I NORMALLY WOULD.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO THROW IN THE OFF-SEASON
AND GET GOOD FEEDBACK ON ALL MY
PITCHES.
MY MAIN FOCUS WAS THE SPLITTER
AND THE CURVEBALL.
TODAY, I WAS ABLE TO THROW BOTH
OF THOSE FOR STRIKES.
I WAS ABLE TO THROW EVERYTHING.
TRYING TO CLEAN UP THE SLIDER A
LITTLE MORE IN THE OFF-SEASON.
I WORKED ON IT IN SPRING
TRAINING.
I FELT LIKE IT HAD GOOD BIKE
TODAY.
THE RAYS ARE A REALLY GOOD
OFFENSIVE TEAM.
SPRING TRAINING, THEY LET ME UP
WITH THE FASTBALL.
I TRIED TO LEARN FROM THOSE
MISTAKES, AND IT WORKED OUT FOR
ME.
CARLOS: YOU JUST TOUCHED ON
WORKING ON YOUR PITCHES AND HOW
YOU WANT TO IMPROVE YOUR SLIDER,
IMPROVE YOUR CUTTER AND YOUR
SPLIT AND ALL OF THAT.
HOW MUCH GOES INTO YOUR
STRATEGY?
WE KNOW YOUR STUFF IS
DEVASTATING AND WIPEOUT STUFF.
BUT IF YOU HAD TO PUT A
PERCENTAGE ON WHAT YOU WORK ON
THE MOST, WOULD IT BE WORKING ON
THE PITCHES IN PARTICULAR, OR
MORE ABOUT HOW TO UTILIZE THEM
TOGETHER AS THE SUM OF ALL
PARTS?
NATE: FOR ME, IT IS WORKING ON A
SPECIFIC PITCH.
I CAN LISTEN TO HOW WE SEQUENCE
AND HOW TO ATTACK HITTERS
DIFFERENTLY, BUT FOR ME IT IS
GETTING CONSISTENT ACTION.
THE CURVEBALL HAS BEEN FEELING
GOOD.
THE FASTBALL IS USUALLY THERE.
I USUALLY HAVE PRETTY GOOD
COMMAND WITH MY FASTBALL.
IT IS REALLY JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THE PITCHES ARE CONSISTENT.
A LOT OF THE TIMES THE TEAMS
THAT COME OUT, THEY WILL TRY TO
ELIMINATE ONE PITCH AND I CAN
USUALLY TELL WHAT PITCH IT IS
GOING TO BE, BUT I HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW I'M GOING TO THROW
IT FOR STRIKES AND BALLS.
THE HITTERS ARE SO GOOD.
THERE IS SO MUCH ANALYTICS THAT
GO INTO THE GAMES NOW.
SO I HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE TO
NOT ALWAYS RELY SO HEAVILY ON MY
FASTBALL, BUT THOSE OFFSPEED
PITCHES AS WELL.
ALANNA: THIS IS ALANNA RIZZO.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME.
YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT THE
FASTBALL WAS PRETTY MUCH ALWAYS
THERE, AND THAT IS WHAT HITTERS
HAVE COME TO EXPECT FROM YOU,
THAT HIGH VELOCITY.
ALEX CORA SAID YOU NEVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO YOU.
THE CUTTER TODAY, IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY WERE GETTING A LOT OF GOOD
SOFT CONTACT.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR YOU TO
ENFORCE THE HITTER TO HAVE TO
WAIT ON SOMETHING, TIME ONE OR
THE OTHER, BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
SIT ON BOTH?
NATE: FOR ME, IT STARTS WITH
STRIKE ONE.
I'VE GOT TO GET STRIKE ONE AND
THEN KEEP PROGRESSING.
IF I FALL BEHIND IN THE COUNT,
THAT IS WHEN I AM GOING TO GET
IN TROUBLE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO RELY ON
SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE THEY WILL
WAIT FOR THE FASTBALL.
THAT IS WHEN THE CUTTER COMES
INTO PLAY.
IT STARTS MIDDLE AND COMES IN ON
THEIR HANDS AND I GET THE SOFT
CONTACT.
I WAS ABLE TO GET QUITE A FEW
OUTS ON THE CUTTER AND THE
SPLITTER.
THE SLIDER FELT GOOD TOO.
I TRY TO MIX ALL THE PITCHES,
TRY NOT TO GET PREDICTABLE.
WHEN I'M AHEAD IN THE ZONE, I
NORMALLY DO PRETTY WELL.
SCOTT: HERE IS A QUESTION FROM
ONE OF THE CREATORS AND THE
COMMENTARY SECTION.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO THROW A 99
M.P.H. FASTBALL, AND WHO WERE
SOME OF YOUR FAVORITE PITCHERS
TO WATCH GROWING UP?
NATE: OBVIOUSLY, IT FEELS REALLY
GOOD BEING ABLE TO THROW THAT
HARD, KNOWING I HAVE THAT IN THE
BACK POCKET.
SOME OF MY FAVORITE PITCHERS
GOING UP -- YOU KNOW NOLAN
RYAN'S, ROGER CLEMENS.
I DID NOT WATCH MUCH BASEBALL
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER, BUT WHEN I
WOULD.
SCOTT: I KNOW THIS IS A BIG DAY
FOR THE RED SOX FANS WATCHING
NOT ONLY YOUR START AND HOW
GREAT YOU WERE NOW IN TWO
STARTS, BUT THE PITCHING GETS
EVEN BETTER TOMORROW BECAUSE THE
PITCHING STAFF AS A WHOLE --
EDUARDO RODRIGUEZ MAKES HIS
RETURN AFTER SITTING OUT LAST
YEAR WITH MYOCARDITIS FROM
COVID-19.
WHAT IS HE SAYING?
HAVE EXCITED IS HE?
I HEARD HE WANTED TO PITCH FOR
HIS BIRTHDAY BUT THEY WERE LIKE,
NATE HAS GOT IT.
IT IS HIS THIRD.
WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
NATE: EDDIE NEVER STOPS TALKING.
HE IS DOES NONSTOP.
WE ARE EXCITED.
IT MEANS A LOT TO THE ROTATION,
TO THE TEAM.
THAT IS WHY WE TAKE IT SO
SERIOUSLY.
HAVING HIM ON THE MOUND TOMORROW
IS GOING TO BE GREAT.
GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
SCOTT: WE WON'T SEE THE AGE
ON-AIR.
NATE: 28.
SCOTT: THERE WE GO.
WE WILL ALWAYS LOOK BACK TO
THIS.
THE FIRST TIME WE ARE GIVING IT
OUT.
TAKE IT HOME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
NATE: THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME, GUYS.
SCOTT: YOU TWO PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
LOOKS GOOD IN PERSON.
NATE LOOKS GOOD ON THE MOUND.
LOOKS REALLY SOLID.
JOHN: TROPHIES, THEY ARE NICE TO
HAVE.
SCOTT: I KNOW YOU ENJOY THEM,
AND ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEONE SO
COMPETITIVE.
WONDERING IF KEVIN PADLO WILL
GET HIS FIRST KNOCK, I TOLD YOU,
THERE IS A SPECIAL TROPHY FOR
THIS PARTICULAR NAME.
YOUR AVERAGE REGULAR SEASON
GAME, I BET THAT WOULD STAND UP
FOR YOU.
JOHN: I'M ALWAYS GOING TO
COMPETE, WHATEVER THE PRIZES.
THAT IS WHAT FUELS THE ENGINE.
SCOTT: YOU TO?
-- TOO?
CARLOS: I'M NOW COMPETING FOR
THOSE JERSEYS SMOLTZ SAYS HE HAS
SO MANY OF.
IF YOU COULD SIGN ONE, I WILL
GIVE YOU MY ADDRESS.
SCOTT: I ALSO HAVE SOME WORK FOR
YOU TO DO, MORE TRANSLATING.
LISTENING TO WILLY ADAMES THIS
GAME.
MORE PLAYERS MIC'ED UP.
>> CARLOS PEÑA, PLAKATA, MI
PAPA.
SCOTT: AMAZING, CARLOS.
THEY SAID YOUR KEYWORD.
CARLOS: YOU'VE GOT TO LOVE THAT.
HE KNEW WE WERE ON, OF COURSE.
HE MADE SURE THAT HE EXTENDED
SAYING HELLO.
WILLIE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
I AM BIG FAN OF HIS.
EVERYTHING HE DOES.
SCOTT: WHAT DID HE SAY EXACTLY,
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT
KNOW YOUR CATCHPHRASE?
CARLOS: THE PLAKATA -- HE GOES,
WHERE IS HE AT?
HE STARTED LOOKING IN THE STANDS
TO SEE WHERE WE WERE AT.
WE ARE A LITTLE FAR AWAY RIGHT
NOW.
BUT I WILL MAKE SURE I TEXT HIM
FROM THE STUDIO.
I WILL CATCH YOU LATER.
SCOTT: THAT IS GOOD PERSPECTIVE.
EVEN THOUGH THE RAYS DID NOT
PLAY WELL TODAY OR IN THIS
SERIES, THEY KNOW HOW GOOD THEY
ARE.
THIS IS BASEBALL.
THEY ARE NOT OVERREACTING TO A
SLOW START.
JOHN: THE CULTURE STARTS WITH
THE MANAGEMENT AND GOES RIGHT
DOWN TO KEVIN CASH.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE PIECES OF
162 GAMES AND WHAT EACH ROLE IS
GOING TO BE IN THE TEAM.
YOU NEVER WANT TO GET SWEPT.
THE KEY PROVING EVERYBODY WRONG.
I WOULD BE AMAZED WITH WHAT THE
FRANCHISES ABLE TO DO IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THEY SEE THE W'S, THEY SEE THE
LOSSES, BUT THEY ARE GOING TO
RUN INTO A BUNCH OF THEM.
THEY ARE PUTTING TOGETHER A
SOMEWHAT BRAND-NEW PITCHING
STAFF.
THAT TAKES A LITTLE TIME
OFFENSIVELY.
THEY ARE WHO THEY ARE.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO GET THE
TRAIN OFF THE TRACKS.
SCOTT: LAST YEAR, THEY HAD BLAKE
SNELL AND CHARLIE MORTON.
INSTEAD, IT IS YARBOROUGH.
AND THINGS SKIPPED UP A LITTLE
BIT.
NATE EOVALDI GETS THE TROPHY.
HE GETS THE HIGH FIVE.
EVERYTHING IS GOING FOR THE RED
SOX STARTER.
WE WILL STEP ASIDE.
MORE ON YOUTUBE POST GAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
THE RED SOX WIN BIG AND SWEEP
THE SERIES AGAINST THE RAYS.
>> MY BALLCLUB.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> IT IS BLOWING ALMOST AT A 45
DEGREE ANGLE COMING IN FROM THE
WEST.
>> THEY LOST MOMENTUM.
COME ON.
WE'VE GOT THIS.
>> IT IS REALLY COMING DOWN.
THAT TARP IS NOT UNROLLING
SMOOTHLY AT ALL.
>> DARVISH LOST HIS GLOVE.
JUST ADDED A NEW PITCH TO HIS
REPERTOIRE, I THINK.
MY GLOVE ADAM.
-- THROW MY GLOVE AT HIM.
LOOK AT THAT.
STILL MANAGES TO THROW A STRIKE.
>> A ROCKET TO LEFT.
IT GOT THE BEAR.
>> STILL SMILING.
>> I CAN'T BEAR TO WATCH.
WOW.
>> LOOK OUT.
>> DOING THE LIMBO.
>> THAT WAS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
>> YES, IT WAS.
SCOTT: WE ARE BACK WITH THE
YOUTUBE POST GAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
THE RED SOX WENT BIG.
IT IS A STATEMENT SERIES.
CAN YOU CALL IT THAT?
THE BEGINNING OF THE SEASON.
MORE FOR THE BOSTON SIDE BASED
ON LAST YEAR'S PERFORMANCE, LAST
PLACE FINISH IN THE DIVISION.
IKE ALEX CORA SAID, WE ARE GOING
TO HEAR IT IF WE HAD A SMALL
START.
JOHN: THIS IS ABOUT THE FIRST
THREE GAMES NOT GOING THE WAY
THEY WANTED AT ALL.
YOU ARE STILL AT HOME AND YOU
ARE GOING TO FACE A TEAM THAT
ALMOST WON THE WORLD SERIES.
IT IS A TOTAL STATEMENT AND A
CHARACTER BUILDER FOR THE CLUB
EARLY ON.
EVERYBODY IN BASEBALL, THEY ARE
NOT DEALING WITH THE NARRATIVE
OR THE CITY.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR -- I
COME ON OVERSTATED ENOUGH.
THAT CLUBHOUSE FEELS GOOD ABOUT
RALLYING LAST NIGHT, TAKING CARE
OF BUSINESS TODAY.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY ARE 3-3.
THEY START THE SEASON FEELING
LIKE WE ARE IN GOOD SHAPE.
EVERYTHING IS GOOD.
SCOTT: YOU START TO SEE WHAT
MAKES THE RED SOX TEAM SPECIAL,
THE OFFENSE.
THAT IS THE PART OF THE GAME
THAT SHINED LAST YEAR, TOP FIVE
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE IN RUNS
SCORED.
CARLOS, BASED ON WHAT YOU HAVE
SEEN IN THIS FIRST WEEK, WITHOUT
OVERREACTING, CAN YOU CONFIRM OR
DENY THAT THE RED SOX MIGHT BE
BETTER THAN THEY APPEARED
HEADING INTO THIS SEASON?
CARLOS: I THINK I HAVE BEEN
GUILTY OF LEAVING THE RED SOX
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION AND THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE EAST.
BUT YES, AFTER WATCHING THEM
TODAY, THE WAY THEY GO ABOUT
THEIR BUSINESS AT THE PLATE, I'M
NOT SURE WE SHOULD DO THAT.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
OF COURSE THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS WITH THE PITCHING
STAFF.
SMOLTZ WAS TALKING ABOUT IT.
AS EOVALDI GOES, THE WHOLE STAFF
IS GOING TO GO.
RODRIGUEZ IS ABOUT TO COME BACK.
IF THOSE TWO ARE DOING WHAT THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING, THEY
WILL GIVE A LOT OF QUALITY
STARTS AND A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE RED SOX TO BE RIGHT
WHERE THEY WANT TO BE.
I WOULD PUT THE RED SOX BACK IN
THE MIX EVEN THOUGH I DID LEAVE
THEM OUT EARLY IN THE YEAR,
LOOKING AT THEM ON PAPER.
THE OFFENSE IS STILL THERE.
IF THE PITCHERS DO THEIR JOB AND
JUST CONTRIBUTE -- THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO HAVE MONSTER YEARS.
JUST DO WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO DO.
IT WILL BE IN THE HUNT IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE EAST.
SCOTT: THEY HAD TO BALTIMORE
AFTER THIS, THE HOME OPENER FOR
THE ORIOLES TOMORROW.
THEY STARTED AGAINST THE ORIOLES
0-3, BUT THEY PICK UP THREE WINS
AGAINST TAMPA BAY.
THE LATEST ONE LOOKED LIKE THIS.
XANDER BOGAERTS WITH DEVERS ON
SECOND.
BOGAERTS GOLFS IT TO CENTER.
THAT IS GOING TO FALL IN FRONT
OF MARGOT.
-- MARGEAU.
XANDER BOGAERTS EVENS THIS GAME
AT 1-1 WITH THE R.B.I. KNOCK.
JOHN: HE IS JUST TOO GOOD
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHERS.
HE IS TOO GOOD IN GENERAL.
SIMPLE APPROACH.
DOES NOT MISS HIS PITCH.
HE HAS REALLY HAD SUCCESS
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
SCOTT: 10 HOME RUNS IN HIS FIRST
FOUR SEASONS IN THE BIG LEAGUE,
AND A CAREER-HIGH 23 ALL OF A
SUDDEN.
THE 2-1 OFFERING IS BLASTED.
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ LIVES UP TO
HIS NEW NAME AND GOES ALONG.
CARLOS: ON CUE, SCOTTY.
THAT SEEMED LIKE IT WAS
SOMETHING UP AND IN.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THAT CUTTER.
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ WAS READY FOR
IT.
HE GOT READY EARLY ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO GET HIS SWING IN.
SCOTT: AND A HEALTHY RIGHT IN
THE DUGOUT.
IT IS THE NEW CELEBRATION.
HIT HARD, YOU RIDE THE ROLLER
COASTER.
HITLESS THIS AFTERNOON, BUT OFF
TO A 10-23 START.
TWO HOMERS, FIVE DOUBLES.
AND HE GIVES THAT BALL A RIDE.
DEEP LEFT.
WILL IT STAY FAIR?
AND IT IS HIGH OFF THE WALL.
AND IT WILL SCORE A COUPLE RUNS
FOR BOSTON.
PLAWECKI COMES IN, SO DOES
HERNANDEZ, AND DID HE HAS A RUN
SCORED DOUBLE.
CARLOS: WAS SLIGHTLY EARLY ON
THIS PITCH RIGHT HERE, BUT HE
WAS ABLE TO KEEP THAT IN THE
ZONE FOR LONG ENOUGH.
SCOTT: AND HE'S TEAMMATE IS THE
FIRST PLAYER IN RED SOX HISTORY
WITH AN EXTRA-BASE HIT IN HIS
FIRST SIX GAMES OF THE SEASON.
JOHN: STARTING TO SHOW A BIT OF
THEIR OLD SELF WHEN THEY WERE A
CRICKET NUMBER MACHINE, MEANING
THEY COULD PUT UP A CRICKET
NUMBER IN ANY OF THOSE NINE
INNINGS.
SCOTT: DROPS ONE INTO SHALLOW
LEFT AND THAT WILL SCORE ANOTHER
ONE FOR BOSTON.
IT IS 6-1.
HUNTER RENFROE 0-2 TODAY.
ROQUE HIS BAT.
SOURCE ONE UP HERE FOR A DONNA'S
-- ADAMES.
THE THROW SKIPS AWAY AND
BOGAERTS COMES HOME.
A 7-1.
HERE COMES ANOTHER.
IT IS VAZQUEZ.
RACING AROUND THEY GO.
A KEY MISHAP FROM TAMPA BAY ON
DEFENSE.
IT OPENS THIS ONE UP.
IT REALLY DID.
THROUGH THE GAME WIDE OPEN FOR
BOSTON.
THIS IS HOW IT FINISHED UP.
TAYLOR GETS ODOM.
IT IS DONE.
THE RED SOX SWEEP.
LOOK AT THAT LITTLE PUNCH.
A LITTLE BASEBALL CHUCK.
HIS TEAM IS THRILLED.
9-2 WINNERS AS THEY IMPROVED TO
3-3 ON THE SEASON.
ALANNA RIZZO AT THE BALLPARK.
HOW IS IT GOING OUT THERE?
ALANNA: IT IS GOOD.
NICE TO WRAP THINGS UP FOR
FENWAY.
IF YOU ARE A RED SOX FAN, YOU
WERE PLEASED WITH NOT ONLY WHAT
YOU SAW TODAY, BUT WITH THE RED
SOX WERE ABLE TO DO OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST THREE GAMES.
IT HAS BEEN WELL-DOCUMENTED THAT
THEY STARTED THE SEASON AT HOME.
THE WORST SINCE 1948.
THEY EVENED UP THE SEASON
SERIES, THREE AND THREE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK AT
THOSE ORIOLES AS THEY START A
THREE-GAME SET WITH THE O'S IN
BALTIMORE TOMORROW AFTERNOON.
AS FAR AS THE RAYS ARE
CONCERNED, THEY LEAVE HERE
PERHAPS WITH A BIT OF A SOUR
TASTE IN THE MOUTH.
RYAN YARBROUGH HAD SUCH A GOOD
START IN HIS FIRST OUTING OF THE
YEAR.
A LITTLE MORE SHAKY AS FAR AS
THE MECHANICS AND THE DELIVERY
WERE CONCERNED.
BUT RED SOX FANS HAVE A LOT TO
LOOK FORWARD TO.
THE TEAM CERTAINLY LIKELY HAPPY
WITH THEIR PERFORMANCE.
SCOTT: AND IT IS ALEX CORA BACK
WITH THE TEAM AFTER SITTING OUT
LAST YEAR.
HE HAS GOT TO BE PLEASED WITH
WHAT THEY JUST PUT TOGCAN
LEAGUE CHAMPS.
WE HAVE MORE COMING AT YOU IN
THE POSTGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY IN A MOMENT.
>> YOU MAKE FUN OF ME AND MY
BALLCLUB?
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE CAREER IN HIS 1200
25TH GAME.
TODD FRAZIER IS GOING TO PITCH.
SWANSON HITS ONE OUT TO CENTER
FIELD.
MARISNICK BACK TO THE WARNING
TRACK.
FRASER IS LOOKING TO CASH IN.
HE GOT THE KNUCKLEBALL FOR A
STRIKE.
STRUCK HIM OUT.
>> MY GOSH.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> NOT TOO MANY THROW THEM IN
GAMES WHEN THEY GET A CHANCE.
>> ON COMES MARISNICK.
A 1, 2, THREE INNING FOR THE
KNUCKLEBALLER.
THE >> IN THE AIR TO RIGHT
FIELD.
ADELL WAS IN, ANGLING BACK.
HE JUST PUT IT RIGHT OVER THE
FENCE.
LIKE A CENTER IN VOLLEYBALL.
HE JUST PUSHED IT RIGHT OVER.
>> ABOUT FIVE FEET AWAY.
SCOTT: WE ARE BACK.
IT IS THE YOUTUBE POSTGAME SHOW,
SCOTT BRAUN, JOHN SMOLTZ, AND
CARLOS PENA WITH YOU.
THE RED SOX TAKE IT OVER THE
TAMPA BAY RAYS.
THEY TWEAK -- THEY SWEEP TAMPA
BAY.
VERY IMPRESSIVE PERFORMANCE.
THE SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE SAYS
LET'S DO THIS AGAIN SOON,
EVERYONE.
MORE COMING UP IN JUST A MOMENT.
WE WILL TELL YOU WHAT THE NEXT
GAME LOOKS LIKE.
CHRISTIAN VAZQUEZ HOMERED LAST
NIGHT AGAINST DIEGO CASTILLO.
SAVED THE GAME FOR BOSTON.
HOW IMPRESSIVE DOES THE RED SOX
CATCHER -- I KNOW HE WAS D.H.'ED
TODAY.
HOW DOES HE LOOK IN TERMS OF
WHAT HE IS ABLE TO BRING AT THE
PLATE?
VERY DIFFERENT FROM HOW HE
LOOKED IN HIS FIRST THREE YEARS.
CARLOS: TIMING IS THE NUMBER
ONE, MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
HITTING.
THIS IS SOMETHING HE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON.
LOOK OUT EARLY HE GETS READY TO
GET THE HEALTHY SWING AT THE
BASEBALL.
YOU WANT TO GET AS MANY OF THOSE
AS POSSIBLE.
109 M.P.H. OFF HIS BARREL.
THAT BALL WAS ABSOLUTELY SMOKED.
IF YOU SWING HARDER, IT MEANS TO
GET READY EARLIER.
YOU GET IN CADENCE WITH THE
PITCH.
I THINK HE HAS GOTTEN A LOT
SMARTER WHEN IT COMES TO THAT, A
LOT MORE EFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES
TO MAKING SURE HIS TIMING IS ON
POINT FOR THE PITCHER HE WAS
FACING ON A NIGHTLY BASIS.
WE HAVE SEEN IT TODAY.
SCOTT: HE HAS ROUNDED INTO ONE
ALL-AROUND PERFORMER FOR BOSTON.
HE WAS KNOWN RIGHT AWAY FOR HIS
PITCH FRAMING, HIS GAME CALLING.
YOU LOVE TO THROW TO HIM.
JOHN: EVERY TIME I SAW A PLAYER,
MY TEAMMATES -- YOU WOULD SEE
THE MECHANICS CLICK IN, WHERE IT
UNLEASHED SOMETHING THAT MAYBE
WAS NOT THERE BEFORE.
HE HAS THAT CONFIDENCE NOW.
IT HAS CHANGED HIS CAREER.
A PART-TIME CATCHER KNOWN FOR
HIS DEFENSE, HE NOW HAS AN
OFFENSE.
HE IS GOING TO BE IN THEIR THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME.
THE TRAJECTORY HE HAS TAKEN --
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS TAKE TIME
TO CONVEY OR GET OUT.
TO CARLOS'S POINT, HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT.
THE TIMING -- AT TIMES, IT LOOKS
LIKE THE BEACH BALL IS COMING IN
AND GOING OUT.
GOOD FOR HIM AND THE RED SOX.
SCOTT: ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE A
CATCHER, THERE IS A LOT TO LEARN
WHEN YOU WORK YOUR WAY UP
THROUGH THE MINOR LEAGUES AND
INTO THE MAJORS TO LEARN YOUR
PITCHERS.
HE DID THAT.
HE ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
AND THEN CAME HIS HITTING
PROWESS.
CONGRATS TO VAZQUEZ AND THE RED
SOX FOR THE WIN.
WE DO THIS A LOT THIS YEAR.
THURSDAY, APRIL 22, ANGELS AND
ASTROS, COVERAGE BEGINS AT 7:30
EASTERN TIME.
ON THE CALL, YOU CAN SEE MATT
VASGERSIAN, MARK GUBICZA, GEOFF
BLUM, AND BRETT DOLAN.
IT IS THE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE ON APRIL 22.
WE WILL HAVE OVER 20 GAMES
COMING AT YOU THIS SEASON.
IT IS ALL FREE.
IT IS ON YOUTUBE.
AND WE WILL BE BRINGING THAT
BEAUTIFUL TROPHY WITH US, THE
TRIP -- THE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
YOU WILL SEE THAT EVERYWHERE.
NATE EOVALDI SHOWED IT OFF WELL,
BUT ALSO REALLY SHOWED OFF HIS
STUFF THIS AFTERNOON FOR THE
BOSTON RED SOX.
LET'S PUSH IT FORWARD.
YOU HAVE THE ANGELS TAKING ON
THE ASTROS IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE WEST.
WE TALK OVERREACTION CITY IN THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE SEASON.
SOME MIGHT SAY THE ANGELS AND
ASTROS LOOK LIKE THE BEST TEAMS
IN THE DIVISION WHILE THE A'S
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING OUT OF THE
STRETCH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE A.L.
WEST SO FAR IN THIS FIRST WEEK
OF THE SEASON?
CARLOS: INTERESTING.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY WE SCRIPTED
IT.
I HAVE THE A'S GETTING AT THE
GATES HOP.
IT IS A LONG SEASON.
BUT THE ASTROS -- EVEN THE
ANGELS ARE LOOKING AT THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE ALSO CANDIDATES TO
BE IN THE MIX.
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE THAT LINEUP
TO DO SO.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW THE LONG SEASON PLAYS OUT.
AS WE ALLUDED TO IN THIS
PROGRAM, YOUR WEAKNESSES WILL BE
EXPOSED IN A LONG YEAR.
162 GAMES.
GETTING OFF TO A GOOD START, IT
CAN ONLY HELP.
THESE GUYS HAVE DONE EXACTLY
THAT.
SCOTT: IT HELPS WHEN YOU ARE
HEALTHY, TOO WHEN YOU HAVE SHOKO
TONY, -- SHOHEI OHTANI ON THE
MOUND.
SUFFERING INJURIES.
THAT IS YOUR EARLY-SEASON
OVERREACTION.
BUT HOW DO YOU SIZE UP THE
LEAGUE?
JOHN: WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FANS
AND WE TALK ABOUT NOISES AND
SOUNDS OF THE GAME, THE ASTROS
ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH THAT THIS
YEAR.
THE ASTROS SEEM TO HAVE SOME
FORM OF THE CHIP THAT REMAINS ON
THEIR SHOULDER TO PROVE WHY THEY
ARE A VERY GOOD BASEBALL TEAM.
THAT WHAT HAPPENED A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO IS IN THE PAST.
I THINK THE WAY THEY HANDLED IT
AND THE WAY DUSTY BAKER HAS
BROUGHT THIS TEAM -- IT IS A
YOUNG TEAM.
BOTH TEAMS, TO ME OFFENSIVELY,
DOES NOT HAVE AS MANY CONCERNS.
CAN EITHER TEAM FIND ENOUGH
PITCHING TO GET THROUGH THIS
162?
FRAN BEER -- HE IS A STUD THAT
UNFORTUNATELY GOT AN INJURY FOR
THE ASTROS.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE FIRE
BURNING TO PROVE SOME THINGS
STILL THIS YEAR.
THAT IS GOING TO SERVE THEM
WELL.
SCOTT: THEY ARE BALANCING THE
CHIP, KEEPING IT ON THEIR
SHOULDER.
JOHN: I PLAYED WITH A CHIP ON MY
A LOT OF PLAYERS CAN PLAY WITH A
CHIP ON THEIR SHOULDER AND IT
SERVES THEM WELL.
SOME, IT IS A DETRIMENT TO THEM.
I THINK JUST THE CORE YOUNG
PLAYERS THAT ARE STILL THERE,
THEY WANT TO PROVE WHY THEY ARE
SOME OF THE BEST OFFENSIVE --
THEY COULD BE ONE OF THE BEST
OFFENSIVE TEAMS IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
SCOTT: STAR POWER IN THAT GAME,
SO GET READY.
IT IS THE ASTROS AND THE ANGELS.
IT IS KOREA, TROUT, OHTANI.
THE NAMES GO ON AND ON.
THAT IS IT FOR THIS GAME AT
FENWAY PARK AND THE YOU TO POST
GAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
FIDELITY.
THE NEXT ONE COMING AT YOU APRIL
22.
PASTORS AND ANGELS.
COVERAGE BEGINS WITH THEIR
PREGAME SHOW AT 7:30 EASTERN
WITH HALL OF FAMER JOHN SMOLTZ,
BIG, STRONG CARLOS PENA, THE
GREAT ALANNA RIZZO, AND OUR
ENTIRE SUPERSTAR CREW.
I AM SCOTT BRAUN LOGGING OUT FOR
NOW.
THANK YOU FOR WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY FIDELITY.
WE WILL SEE YOU FOR THE NEXT
ONE.